Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Du hast Themen mitgebracht. Na dann leg mal los.
Naja, wir müssen schon über Jeffrey Epstein sprechen. Du verfolgst das sehr rege oder wie sieht dein Medienkonsum da aus?
Ich habe, es gibt ja immer das Thema und dann das mediale Dings dazu und ich frage mich die ganze Zeit, ob sie wirklich so katastrophal dumm sind oder ob es eine Strategie gibt. Und die einzige Strategie, von der ich glaube, dass sie so, aber das wäre auch total erhindersich, dass man jetzt einfach alles veröffentlicht, weil man gerade denkt, ja so in 25 Prozent der Amtszeit hofft man, dass es bei 35 Prozent dann absch und bei 75 Prozent und dann sind Wahlen und so weiter und so fort. Also dass man einfach so einen Zeitpunkt wählt, wo man sagt, nee bis November ist noch so und so lang und so weiter.
Und ich glaube, es wird ja auch so kommuniziert, dass man sagt, mehr gibt es auch nicht, mehr gibt es nicht zu veröffentlichen, weitere Infos wird es nicht geben.
Und da sage ich, diese Strategie ist so doof, dass ich sie mitmache. Also sobald mir irgendwas wieder unterkommt, wo ich denke, wow, noch mal ein neuer Ding, noch mal neu irgendwie, mache ich einfach eine Story draus. Weil ich denke, das wird ja nicht aufgehen. Nur weil die das als Idee haben, dass man jetzt so langsam die Temperatur erhöht und dann ist irgendwann so, ah ja gut, okay, wir haben uns dran gewöhnt. Also ich glaube in dem Falle wirklich nicht an den Gewöhnungseffekt.
Nein, das glaube ich auch nicht.
Von daher denke ich mir all in. Ich meine, das, was wir jetzt gerade haben, ich habe die These schon ein paar Mal gemacht, aber das, was wir jetzt gerade als sogenannten rechtsradikalen Backlash in der westlichen Welt haben, wurde ausgelöst durch, ah nein, eventuell gibt es irgendwo eine Regelung, dass man mal was gendern muss. Und jetzt frage ich mich natürlich, was für ein Backlash wird es geben, weil irgendwo echte Menschen irgendwie Babys gefuttert haben, weil sie dachten, wenn sie die unter Stress töten, entsteht da irgend so ein Hormon und so weiter. Und von daher denke ich mir, ja, schöne Strategie, das langsam Durchsetzen der Gesellschaft mit diesem Thema in der Hoffnung, dass es abäppst. Du gehst aber jetzt noch weiter an als das, was gerade publiziert wurde. Nee, das wurde alles so publiziert. Also, dass es so einen Stresszustand gibt, in dem man im richtigen Moment die Menschen dann töten muss, weil dann die Organe mit diesem Hormon voll sind, scheint Theorie dieser ganzen Bande zu sein. Und jetzt gerade ist es halt so ein Sexskandal, weil wir das so ein bisschen kennen. Und Ice White Shut ist ja auch ein Film, der das thematisiert, wie auch immer. Aber dieser Abstehen hatte wohl wirklich diese Idee, auf seiner Insel sollen immer gleichzeitig 20 schwangere Frauen rumlaufen, damit da genug Material einfach da ist für diesen Irrsinn, den sie da hatten und so. Von daher weiche ich gerade nicht ab von dem, was publiziert ist.
Wie würdest du aber dann doch die Rolle der US-Demokraten einschätzen? Denn die haben ja lange Zeit das sehr runtergespielt, haben dann aber plötzlich eine Idee gehabt, vielleicht kann Trump über die Epstein-Files stolpern und sind dann sehr für Aufklärung, was dann sogar so weit geht, dass sie dann fordern, dass Bill Clinton und auch seine Gattin Hillary sich bitte äußern sollen, die das dann lange verweigern. Jetzt wollen sie doch vor dem Kongress sprechen. Es ist ja doch ganz erstaunlich, dass die US-Demokraten lange Zeit das unter den Teppich gekehrt haben und auch wenn ich jetzt mir die deutsche Medienlandschaft ansehe und es tut mir ein bisschen leid, das zu sagen, aber es war ja doch so, dass eigentlich an diesem Epstein-Fall und an einzelnen Enthüllungen am meisten Springer tatsächlich dran war und eigentlich da immer wieder zu publiziert hat. Auch schon damals, als es den, und ich sage, dass sie auch ganz bewusst angeblichen Selbstmord gab, an den ich natürlich nicht glaube, sondern ich würde sagen, da sind noch andere Mächte mit im Spiel und dass man da das immer sehr runtergedrückt hat von anderer Seite. Also nicht bewusst im Sinne von, wir wollen da nicht zu publizieren, weil wir gesagt bekommen haben, wir sollen das nicht tun, sondern wir haben einen Diskurs gehabt, der sich mit Verschwörungstheorien kritisch auseinandersetzte und zeigte, wie schnell solche Verschwörungstheorien oder manche sagen auch Erzählungen entstehen, wie die Struktur dieser Erzählung ist. Und das ist ja auch wichtig, sich die Geschichte der Verschwörungstheorien anzusehen, zu sehen, wie damit manipuliert wird, also indem man solche Spin-Doktoren anstellt, die dafür sorgen, dass die eine oder andere Verschwörungstheorie dann so verfängt, dass plötzlich damit ein Wahlkampf bestritten werden kann. Alles gut und schön. Aber man hat im Zuge dessen, also der kritischen Auseinandersetzung mit Verschwörungstheorien, bisweilen so getan, als gäbe es keine Verschwörungen. Und es gibt aber Verschwörungen, wie wir jetzt hier in aller Deutlichkeit sehen. Und sie betreffen Leute, die sonst als Wohltäter auftreten, nicht alle. Also wir haben natürlich auch Leute wie Howard Lattnick oder Trump da drin. Von denen haben wir nicht vermutet, dass sie Wohltäter sind. Und wir bekommen es da auch nochmal bestätigt. Aber wir sehen eben auch andere Kandidaten, wie beispielsweise Bill Gates, die da auftauchen. Oder die von der Adelspresse so geliebte Mette Maret, wo man jetzt sagen muss, die ist jetzt nur da erst einmal aufgetaucht mit, sie trifft sich regelmäßig mit Epstein. Ich wundere mich aber auch, oder wie das alles sein kann, dass man einen verurteilten Mann hat, der 2013, meine ich, aus dem Gefängnis wiederkommt, wegen Mädchenhandels und all dem. Und dann ist aber so eine Elite.
Also 2008 wurde verurteilt damals.
Okay, dann war es vielleicht 2011, 2011.
Ja, also so.
Und er kommt aus dem Gefängnis. Also er ist verurteilt, kommt aus dem Gefängnis. Und eine Woche später trifft er schon wieder Damen aus der High Society, die mit ihm essen gehen. Und er macht so eine kleine Image-Kampagne für die ein oder andere Kronprinzessin, die dies und das werden will. Ich meine, das ist doch, also wie kann das sein? Also wie kann es sein, dass diese Leute trotzdem, dass alles bekannt ist, diese Nähe weiterhin gesucht haben? Also es ist ja eben nicht so, auch wenn die das jetzt mitunter so darstellen, als würde das jetzt ihnen klar werden, was das war. Sondern wenn hier schon jemand deshalb im Gefängnis war, dann ist es ja schon sehr eigenartig, wenn ich mich fünf Tage später melde und sage, wollen wir nicht was essen gehen?
Ja, sehr viele Fragen. Ich rolle sie mal von hinten auf oder von vorne auf. Also hier in meiner Podcastlandschaft hieß es schon immer keine Angst vor Verschwörungstheorien. Ja. Und als Trump eins regierte und es hieß Fake News, habe ich gesagt, mir ist das halt fabriziert. Dass sie dann auch noch gelogen sind, ist das Problem. Aber man kommt nicht drumherum und zu sagen, Nachrichten sind grundsätzlich mal fabriziert. Manchmal passieren Fehler, manchmal passieren Lügen, wie auch immer. Das Drama ist gar nicht so groß. Zurück zum Thema, also unter diesen beiden Maßgaben. Hier schlummern ja, weil du es nach den Demokraten fragtest, mehrere Skandale. Ich habe gerade meine Verwunderung darüber geäußert, dass Pam Bondi diese Sachen jetzt einfach veröffentlicht hat. Unter der Idee, dass man das irgendwie so langsam köchelt und dann fädet es wieder aus.
Du musst sagen, wer Pam Bondi ist.
Also die von Trump eingesetzte, seine Justizministerin. Und der Tom Blanch, also ihr Vizier, der ja Trump damals schon verteidigte in seinen Sechstern. Sein ehemaliger Anwalt. Genau. Also die haben jetzt diese Idee, wir kochen das langsam und dann wird das schon die Leute, ein paar Storys, aber mehr wird nicht passieren. Die Alternative dazu ist ja, es nicht zu veröffentlichen, aber das Material zu kennen. Also Fotos wie da einfach zwei Hühnchen liegen, um zu Essen bereit gemacht zu werden und dazwischen aber ein menschlicher Körper. So und der wird aber dann redacted und dann fragen sie sich, warum? Und dann hat man aber vergessen, den Fuß mit zu redacten und so. Er ist ja völlig bescheuert. So, diese Entscheidung, das nicht zu veröffentlichen, aber das Material zu kennen, hat auch ein weißes Haus getroffen, nämlich das von Joe Biden. Was bedeutet, beide Administrationen stecken ganz tief drin, sind da ganz tief verbundelt und haben jeweils für sich eine Entscheidung getroffen, von denen ich sage, die sind beide total doof, aber es gibt keine dritte Alternative. Also entweder veröffentlicht oder halt nicht. Jedes weiße Haus hat jetzt eine der beiden Entscheidungen getroffen. Was bedeutet, wir als normale Leute sind jetzt wirklich in einem existenziellen Kampf gegen die Mächtigen und auch jemand, der das nicht möchte, ist halt trotzdem da drin. Also man ist ja positioniert durch Vermögenswerte oder politische Handlungsfähigkeit oder was auch immer und wir sehen gerade und wir haben uns schon jahrelang über Elon Musk als der dummste und gleichzeitig reichste Mensch der Welt und jetzt lassen wir die Politik immer unter Gemeinwohl laufen und stellen fest, nee gar nicht, genau das Gegenteil. So und jetzt muss jeder für sich und mit muss meine ich jetzt wirklich muss. Man kann es auch einfach auslaufen lassen und dann hat man halt auch eine Entscheidung getroffen. Also die Duldung ist erstmals eine richtige Handlung. So man muss sich jetzt selber ins Benehmen setzen, in welchem Verhältnis man zu Eliten grundsätzlich steht.
Ja und ich will da nicht hören, ja Elitenkritik ist generell problematisch. Die ist erst mal sehr wichtig und wir haben ja das Buch hier im Salon besprochen von Rutger Brüchmann, der sagte ja diese Mächtigen, die haben schon etwas gemeinsam.
Irgendetwas stimmt da nicht mit denen und jetzt sehen wir, was können wir da sehen? Irgendetwas stimmt da nicht mit denen.
Und es ist ja auch in dem Sinne konsequent, wir thematisieren hier im Podcast fortwährend, dass diese Mächtigen sich über Regeln, zum Beispiel über Regelungen, wie man besteuert hinwegsetzen können ohne Probleme, also wie sie sogar so weit gehen können, dass sie als Amazon-Chef noch ein Kindergeld beantragen können, weil sie bedürftig sind, ja. Also, dass sie im Prinzip weniger Steuern alle zahlen als wir. Warren Buffett hat ja auch das mal genauso in aller Ehrlichkeit gesagt, mein Sekretär zahlt mehr Steuern als ich. Also, die sich über all das hinwegsetzen können und eine ganz eigene Logik verfolgen, die mit den Privatschütz durch die Gegend fliegen, weil sie sagen, es ist angenehmer und all das. Und dass die natürlich dann auch sich über andere Gesetze hinwegsetzen. Also, was da eigentlich entstanden ist, ist eine Aristokratie in noch viel schlimmeren Ausmaß, weil die Aristokratie natürlich noch so einen gewissen Kodex hat, der mit einer Moral oder so verbunden ist. Aber das ist wirklich verbunden mit einem radikalen Nihilismus, den man da sehen kann, der wirklich nur darauf aus ist zu sagen, ich mache das, was ich will, weil ich es geschafft habe, steht mir das zu. Und dann zugleich möglicherweise zur Kompensation oder weil man auch nicht die ganze Zeit bei Apps, denen auf der Insel sein kann, macht man irgendwelche Charity-Projekte oder kümmert sich um die Bekämpfung von Malaria.
Ja, also in diesen Dingern sind so grundsätzlich ganz traurige Geschichten drin, ja. Also Elon Musk, der am 25. Dezember.
Morgens früh.
Ja, also der und also schon im deutschen Maßstab, ja, okay, die Geschenke gibt es am 24. Dezember. Und man ist am 25. Dezember genervt, von Familie, ich möchte raus, wie auch immer. Also man kann sein nahes Umfeld einfach überhaupt nicht er tragen. So. Nur in Amerika gibt es ja die Geschenke am 25. Dezember. Also während die Kinder die Geschenke auspacken, schreibt er, ich brauche unbedingt eine Party, kann ich mal schnell hier und so weiter. Ja, und es ist doch, das ist doch nicht, also wer soll das erklären? So.
Ja.
Und da gibt es so ganz viele. Ja, du hast jetzt gleich diese Melinda Bill und Melinda Gates Geschichte und so. Ich kenne den Clip noch nicht, aber ich habe natürlich auch mitbekommen, wie sie so darüber redet und lauter solche Sachen. Also wir haben es hier wirklich mit. Also wir müssen es uns noch verdeutlichen. Die Visualisierung fehlt noch, weil wir können jetzt nicht direkt diese Serie Altered Carbon zum Beispiel, wo die Superreichen einfach in kilometerhohen über den Wolken Türmen leben und da so ihre eigenes Leben. Und dann haben die schon so menschliche Körper entwickelt und tauschen sich da immer aus und sind im Grunde unsterblich und so. Aber so in diesem Maße sind die ja geistig entrückt einfach. Die wissen nicht mehr, was sie mit ihrem Geld machen sollen. Also kaufen sie sich so das Blut von Babys, dass sie dann nach irgendwelchen Ideen und so weiter und so fort. Und jetzt ist ja diese Frage, was bedeutet das für jeden Einzelnen? Also wir haben den Auftrag, unsere Bundesregierung zu fragen, wie sie dazu steht. Ich finde, mit so einem Regime kann man gar kein Business machen, egal was es kostet. Also dann müssen wir einfach hier wirklich jetzt Microsoft Word ausschalten und mal gucken, wie die Unternehmen zurechtkommen. Was konkret bedeutet, sollte ich jemals in eine Abendveranstaltung eingeleitet sein, wo der Bundeskanzler kommt, ist mir die Tagesordnung da komplett egal. Herr Schulz, wir haben sie hier für einen Vortrag gebucht. Nein, während der Bundeskanzler redet, stehe ich auf und frage, sind sie bescheuert? Also nur für den Fall, dass sie mich einleitet. Das ist dann das Programm. Und ich möchte, dass jetzt jeder für sich so eine ganz kleine Strategie, die man dann nicht erst, wo die Gelegenheit da ist und so, sondern das einfach mal durchvisualisieren, wie würde man in verschiedenen Situationen reagieren? So und das dann einfach wie so ein Sportler, der schon mal in seinem Geiste den Hang runterfährt, das einfach üben, um dann im richtigen Moment zu handeln. Ja. Weil das also das ist nicht mehr, ich habe jetzt schon gesagt, Kommunalpolitik ist mal ein neues Thema. Ich werde wahrscheinlich dann in zwei Jahren oder so ein Buch drüber schreiben. Darin wird es auch ein Kapitel geben. Das hatte ich mir natürlich schon länger zurecht gelegt. Aber es wird immer driftiger. Kommunalpolitik heißt, man tritt vor die Tür, man sieht Sachen, man berührt Sachen, man hört Sachen. Also die eigene Sinneswahrnehmung ist erschöpft von dem, was man da wahrnimmt. Und wenn man eine Sorge hat, dann geht man zum Bürgermeister und sagt, ich habe ein Problem und sei es nur, dass man klingelt, wie auch immer. Da kann man also hingehen. Ab der Landespolitik. Erst recht bei Bundespolitik und insbesondere bei dem allen, was wir aus Amerika sehen. Das ist reine Fantasy, dass sich Leute noch damit beschäftigen, weil sie im Fernsehen glauben, als ordentlicher Staatsbürger gucke ich natürlich Nachrichten, nehme das alles ganz ernst und dann mache ich mir kurz Gedanken darüber, wie ich das jetzt finde, was in Venezuela passiert ist. Der Modus muss jetzt grundlegend geändert werden. Also alles, was wir bisher so in 80 Jahren Nachkriegsordnung, nachdem der Kaiser verschwand und wir so neue Orientierung geübt haben, scheint irgendwie in die falsche Richtung geführt zu sein.
Ja, ja.
Also, ich will es ganz deutlich sagen.
Man wundert sich ja manchmal, ich habe jetzt viele Romane gelesen aus dem 19. Jahrhundert, wie dort die Aristokratie mit ihren Angestellten umgeht oder sie noch nicht einmal in einem Roman beim Namen nennt. Also es gibt einfach nur irgendetwas, was aus der Küche kommt. Wer das da macht, keine Ahnung. Es gibt irgendwelche Diener, die kein Gesicht, keine Namen haben. Und man fragt sich, was ist das eigentlich für ein Verhältnis zu anderen Menschen? Ja, also natürlich gibt es eine arbeitsteilige Gesellschaft und so kann es auch einen Chauffeur oder so geben. Aber man fragt sich, was ist das eigentlich, dass also noch nicht mal mehr die einen Namen bekommen? Und man denkt sich, ah, das ist diese überwundene Zeit. Lange ist zäher. Und dann liest man hier mit diesen Appsteinfiles, dass wir es da nur mit Menschen zu tun haben, die sich als Elite begreifen und das auch ganz klar untereinander so kommuniziert. Und alles darunter muss dienen oder wird also eben wird nicht mehr mit den menschlichen Maßstäben behandelt. Missbrauch, alles ist dann möglich, denn die gehören ja nicht zu Elite. Das sind irgendwelche Mädchen von irgendwo her.
Ja, austauschbar.
Und Jungs, ja wohl auch, wie man jetzt immer mehr liest.
Genau. So eine deutsche Story finde ich wahnsinnig interessant. Sie erfüllt mich auch ein bisschen mit Genugtuung. Aber ich wirklich sehr wütend war über Jahre. Immer wenn ich hier irgendwas mit Technik und KI und irgendwas weiter. Also ich meine schon die Jahre auch vor Corona und so. Gab es immer so eine Horde von Leuten, die mir in die Kommentare geschrieben haben? Stefan hat wieder keine Ahnung. Er sollte mal mit Joscha Bach reden. Kann er nicht mal Joscha Bach in Podcast einladen? Ach ja, dann irgendwelche Links zu diesen CCC Vorträgen und so weiter. Und meine Antwort war immer und ich sah es in allen, die es gab. Ich weiß nicht ob alle, aber sagen wir so ab 2013, also wenn Joscha Bach da auftrat dann beim CCC und so. Weil ich jedes Mal da rein bin und mir dachte, mal sehen, was dieses Jahr wieder für ein Scheiß ist. Dann habe ich so einen kleinen Tweet dazu gemacht oder was auch immer. So und dass wir heute wissen, dass Joscha Bach intellektuell der allergrößte Hochstapler ist, der sobald er Texte vorgelegt hat, überall eine Abfuhr bekommen hat, in keiner Uni angestellt wurde, sondern immer nur, ja, der hat so Drittmittel selber mitgebracht und die sind alle von Jeffrey Epstein. Über eine Million Euro hat der Spiegel geschrieben. Also dass da einfach eine Publikumsbespielung stattfand.
Und Flüge wurden organisiert, die Familie und das war...
Um Leuten irgendwie einzureden, da sei was dran, dass die transhumanistische Zukunft der Mensch gelöst von seinem Bewusstsein und der ganze Scheiß. Das erfüllt mich so mit Genugtuung, dass ich euch allen jetzt sagen kann, die mir jemals so ein... Stefan hat keine Ahnung, der soll mal hier den Joscha Bach Vortrag, ja? Ja, schaut ihr mal den Joscha Bach Vortrag jetzt nochmal an. Und überlegt ihr mal, warum hat er da beim MIT keinen Fuß in die Tür gekriegt, in Harvard nicht, in Stanford nicht und nirgendwo. Ja, warum ging das immer nur mit, ich hab meine Drittmittel dabei, ich brauch auch kein Büro, ich brauch hier nur einen Briefkasten und so. Das ist einfach diese verlogene, intellektuelle Hochstaplerei, bei der wir jetzt wissen, das hat alles Methode. Das müsste man natürlich in riesigen, machen wir dann Ende des Monats auch, wie das alles mit Pizza Gate, warum 4chan, 8chan plötzlich so durchgedreht ist und so. Das ist ja alles so wahnsinnig.
Also wir müssen das noch größer aufgreifen.
Also wirklich bescheuert.
Ich hab jetzt mal nur einen Clip mitgebracht, denn wir kennen das ja noch alles von Corona, als uns natürlich zu Recht erklärt wurde, dass diese Verschwörungstheorien von wegen Bill Gates will uns chippen, idiotisch sind. Aber was im Zuge dessen auch passiert ist und das hat mich schon damals geärgert, ist, dass plötzlich auch gerade aus einem linken Umfeld oder linksliberalen Umfeld Bill Gates plötzlich als der größte Wohltäter der Welt gesehen wurde und es wurde überhaupt nicht mehr über problematische Dinge bei ihm gesprochen. Nun gab es damals ja schon immer wieder diese Beziehungen, Epstein, Gates, was ist da dran? Wir wussten auch, Melinda Gates hat sich scheiden lassen. Alles ein bisschen unklar. Warum ist das so? Im Übrigen ja auch, wie dann hier auch von so Leuten, die die US-Demokraten ganz toll finden in Deutschland, immer wieder gesagt wurden, ne, das hat nichts zu bedeuten, wenn Clisane Maxwell auf der Hochzeit der Tochter von den Clintons ist. Also ich weiß nicht. Also ich frage mich jetzt, wenn jetzt über mich bekannt würde, ja, deutscher Filmkritiker hat jedes Jahr irgendwie Urlaub mit Harvey Weinstein gemacht, dann würde man auch mal vielleicht die andere Frage gerne stellen. Also dann sagt man nicht, ja, wird wohl, hat nichts damit zu tun. Also sowieso, da waren eigentlich so viele...
Da sind ja tausend Leute eingeladen, weißt du?
Ja, da sind so viele Dinge, denen man doch eigentlich nachgehen müsste, schon seit Jahren. Und jetzt hat man diese Art der Veröffentlichung, du hast ja zu Recht darauf hingewiesen, es ist ein ebenso großer Skandal, dass die Beide Administrationen reingeschaut hat, wieder zugemacht haben, gesagt, das lassen wir jetzt mal liegen.
Ja, das ist so krass. All diese Sachen tauchen ja nicht jetzt plötzlich auch. Das finde ich auch in der deutschen Diskussion immer. Das ist ja so eine typische journalistische Sprache. Der Epstein-Skandal zieht immer weitere Kreise, als wäre das so ein Unwetter, das jetzt gerade jemanden erwischt, weil ein Name wieder auftaucht.
Der ist seit über sechs Jahren tot.
Die Leute haben seit 30 Jahren mit ihm zu tun. Nur die Veröffentlichung zieht weitere Kreise, aber doch nicht der Epstein-Fall. Also es ist doch absurd.
Wir reden ja jetzt hier auch bei Melinda Gates von Vorfällen, die zwölf, dreizehn Jahre zurückliegen. Sie wird hier jedenfalls in dem Podcast Wildcard von Rachel Martin dazu befragt.
Ich muss die Elefanten in der Runde erinnern. Dein Ex-Husband, Bill, ist in der neuesten Tranch von Epstein-Fallen namen. Und es gibt neue, verabschiedete Details über sein letztes Behavior. Und ich will dir die Möglichkeit geben, in welcher Weise du willst, zu reagieren.
Also, lass mich das sagen. Ich denke, wir haben eine Rechnung als Gesellschaft, richtig? Keine Frau, keine Frau sollte in der Situation, in der sie von Epstein und was auch immer mit all den verschiedenen Menschen um ihn herumgegangen war, keine Frau. Ich meine, es ist einfach, es ist außergewöhnlich herrschend, richtig? Ich erinnere mich an die Zeiten, in denen die Mädchen waren. Ich erinnere mich an meine Tochter, die in diesen Zeiten war, richtig? Also, für mich ist es persönlich hart, wenn diese Details aufkommen, richtig? Weil es die Erinnerungen von sehr, sehr schmerzbaren Zeiten in meiner Begegnung zurückbringt.
Das sie aber doch hier durchblicken lässt, dass sie offenbar Infos lange hat, die jetzt an die Öffentlichkeit gelangen und sie quasi auch Teil des Schweigekartells ist, auch wenn sie sich dann von diesem Mann aus diesen Gründen, die wir jetzt gerade erfahren, getrennt haben.
Also, wir haben heute Bücher im Salon, die uns nochmal die 200 gängigen Denkfehler vor Augen führen. Also, wir können unsere eigene Psychologie nicht überwinden. Und ja, sie gehört zu dieser Elite, die ganz nah dran war. Aber wir wissen auch, gerade in Ehen wird so krass viel versteckt, dass vielleicht gerade die Nähe auch wieder Distanz bedeutet, wie auch immer. Und ich finde, man sollte nochmal ganz scharf unterscheiden zwischen die, die jetzt auf jeden Fall Aussagen machen müssen. Also Bill Clinton, wenn der jetzt da vorgeladen wird vom Kongress und diese Gelegenheit nicht nutzt, einfach alles von sich aus zu erzählen. Ein Jahr bevor er eh stirbt, sage ich mal grob. Sondern jetzt Fragen kommen an ihn und er, wir sehen einfach, dass er ausweicht. Das wird ein ganz schlechtes Signal für sehr viele Leute sein, die dann, das muss auch eine Gesellschaft dann erstmal verarbeiten, dass da Leute einfach so mauern. Allerdings schon bei den Ehefrauen, die sich so äußern wie sie, würde ich sagen, es ist halt wirklich schwierig, dadurch, dass da psychologische Hürden sind. Sie zählt nicht zu den Täterinnen.
Nein, nein, das nicht.
Und ab da, ja.
Es ist nur interessant, dass sich jetzt aufgrund der Enthüllungen dann solche Äußerungen finden lassen von Linda Gates und von anderen.
Aber überleg mal, wie viel jetzt möglich gemacht werden musste, damit man sie zumindest bis dahin bringt. Also so eine super mächtige, unabhängige Frau.
Und es geht ja jetzt noch einen Schritt weiter. Die Moderatorin fragt noch mal nach. Also sie ist froh, von all dem Dreck entfernt zu sein.
Für den Kontext unserer Zuschauer. Die E-Mails und die Fakten zeigen, dass Bill Gates zusätzliche Verhandlungen hatte und dass er versucht hat, Medikamente zu behandeln, um eine sexuell verabschiedete Infektion zu behandeln. Und dass er dir die Medikamente geben würde, ohne dich zu wissen. Sein Representative hat gesagt, dass all das falsch ist. Es ist nicht an dir, um zu den Details der verabschiedeten Verhandlungen zu verantworten. Aber ich frage mich, was deine dominanten Emotionen sind, wenn du diese Newsartikel mit diesen Details lernst.
Schmerz, einfach unglaubliche Schmerzen. Unverglaubliche Schmerzen, richtig? Und wieder, ich kann meine eigene Schmerzen nehmen Ich sehe die jungen Mädchen und sage, oh mein Gott, wie hat das mit diesen Mädchen passiert? Und für mich ist es nur Schmerz. Schmerz für, ich habe meine Beziehung verlassen, ich musste meine Beziehung verlassen, ich wollte meine Beziehung verlassen, ich musste die Beziehung verlassen, ich musste die Foundation verlassen, also ist es nur Schmerz. Das ist die Wahrheit, richtig? Und es ist so, zumindest für mich, Ich hoffe, es wird in deinem Leben weitergehen. Und ich hoffe, es gibt etwas Gerechtigkeit für die nun weiblichen Frauen. Wir sehen sie, die vor Mikrofonen in DC stehen. Was sie durchgeführt haben, ist einfach unvorstellbar, denke ich.
Ich muss mich das mal vorstellen. Bill Gates hat dort Sex. Wir wissen nicht, ob er Sex mit Minderjährigen hat oder so. Wir lassen das hier natürlich alles offen und das werden die Recherchen dann ergeben. Aber er fängt sich da was ein und schreibt dann, als der Mann, der ja für Medikamente berühmt ist, dass er sie überall in die Welt bringt, schreibt dann Jeffrey Epstein. Hast du da mal ein Antibiotikum? Also stellt so Jeffrey Epstein die Frage, die man erst für GPT stellt und dann dem Hausarzt. Also man geht, man sagt, ah, es ist mir jetzt gerade ein bisschen unangenehm, ich frag lieber mal danach. Und jetzt, also es ist ja auch so diese, und das ist, glaube ich, auch die Faszination, dieser, all dieser Fälle ist, dass es ja so, so unglaublich unwürdig ist.
Für den reichsten Mann der Welt?
Wie sich dort alle, alle verhalten, ja.
Es ist wirklich unglaublich. Jetzt gibt es natürlich die Forderung nach direkten Konsequenzen. Die sind sicherlich für Juristen politisch interessiert und so wahnsinnig interessant. Das wird auch noch sehr heikel und umständlich. Aber soziologisch interessant sind ja die indirekten Konsequenzen. Was bedeutet das jetzt grundsätzlich für alle Familien der westlichen Welt, in denen zum Beispiel die 17-jährige Tochter sagt, ich habe eine mega Gelegenheit bekommen, in der Vorstandsverwaltung in Manhattan bei so einer Firma mitzuarbeiten. Da machen sich Familien plötzlich Gedanken. Und das wird auch zu Konsequenzen führen, halt indirekt so. Aber hier ist wirklich einiges in Bewegung. Also es ist wirklich, es ist auch crazy, dass das alles gleichzeitig passiert. Also hier unglaubliche Menschenverachtung, die da drinsteckt. Gleichzeitig diese Leute in Amt ohne Würden, die dann Minneapolis und so nochmal mit so einer Menschenunwürdigkeit überziehen.
Ja, in Davos erzählen, wir brauchen eigentlich keine menschlichen Beziehungen, sondern nur noch Roboter.
Genau. Also die politischen Mächtigen drehen komplett frei. Die ökonomisch Mächtigen drehen auch komplett frei. Es ist eine ganz große, dunkle Zeit der Orientierungslosigkeit. Und für Leute, die jetzt immer so Morgenmagazin gucken und dann hat Dunja Hayali, Luis Fandala oder wie er heißt, zu Gast und fragt nochmal, was bedeutet das jetzt für die Midterms und so, ja. Also wirklich Schuss nicht gehört. Da kann ich auch diese Sätze mit, droht jetzt ein Bürgerkrieg, also der ist doch längst da, der ist in den Köpfen schon voll da. Ja, so. Die Frage ist jetzt, wie er ausgelebt wird und was auch immer, welche Möglichkeiten sich da geben.
Also mein Modus ist jetzt, sobald ich da jemanden von denen so sehe, also von diesen Eliten, dann sage ich, war der auch in den Epstein-Files? Google ich nochmal schnell nach.
Erst mal nach googeln, genau. Wie viele Treffer?
Ja.
Und dann aber, es heißt ja nicht gleich, dass man da und so weiter, aber komisches Schutt.
Irgendwie so gut.
Und wir sollten uns ja auch bewusst sein, Epstein ist seit 2019 tot. Aber dadurch ist ja nicht das, was dort getan wird einfach vorbei, sondern wo sind die neuen Ringe? Wo passiert genau so etwas wieder? Das ist ja eigentlich die Frage. Und dann will ich nicht hören, wenn da wieder irgendwelche Verdachtsmemente kommen, dass man dann sagt, ne, ne, das ist Verschwörungstheorien. Und ich erkläre ihnen nochmal, wie Verschwörungstheorien funktionieren. Also ich wäre eigentlich mal ganz interessiert daran, wenn die, die uns in den letzten Jahren immer Verschwörungstheorien erklärt haben und uns gezeigt haben, wie falsch die alle sind. Wenn die mal gescheite Beiträge zu genau diesem Thema hier machen, das würde mich nämlich mal interessieren, wie die dem begegnen. Weil da kann man jetzt nicht einfach nur so Schulterzucken dastehen und sagen, ja, ach so, ja gut, da hat es dann mal vereinzelt was gegeben, sondern das ist nicht vereinzelt, das ist flächendeckend und das ist alles viel größer, als die Skandale, die wir so in den letzten Jahren hatten, aus der Popmusik oder so. Hier haben wir eine Verwandlung von Kapital und politischer Macht und eben diesem missbräuchlichen Verhalten in verschiedener Hinsicht, dass man da eigentlich mal doch interessiert wäre, wie dort die großen Aufklärer zum Thema Verschwörungstheorie zu stellen.
Absolut. Bevor wir jetzt die Superreichen, wie heißt es nochmal, wenn man denen alles wegnimmt? Besteuern?
Enteignen? Du bist jetzt beim Enteignen.
Radikale Enteignung. Will ich noch mal einen Punkt machen, der jetzt gerade für uns aktuell ist, da Sebastian Seufert uns einen öffentlichen Kommentar schrieb am 1. Februar zu einem anderen weltbewegenden Thema, nämlich KI. Wortlaut. Gut, dass du, er meint dich, Stefan, re KI, immer wieder einhegst Wolfgang. Aber wie mir scheint, er wird einfach ein Krittin. Also es ist jetzt, ich habe eine Aussprache Datenbank nochmal nachgeschaut, Krittin. Er wird immer ein Krittin bleiben, der in diesem Aspekt nur funktional denkt, auch wenn er ihr oft in die Oper geht. Was ist das jetzt so in Zusammenhang mit der Oper? Sehr viele Fragestellungen. Ich gehe mal ein paar Fragen durch, die mich sich mir stellen. Der Krittin ist also jemand, der an Kritanismus oder sowas leidet. Das heißt, wenn man relativ früh so eine Schilddrüsenunterfunktion oder irgendwas hat und gewisse Entwicklungsstadien nicht überschreitet, also für immer so ein bisschen debil und blöd bleibt. Das ist jetzt eine Stellung für mich. So, die Frage ist jetzt, wenn ich über KI rede und ich will auf eine Pointe von letzter Woche schon jetzt drei Tage später quasi eine Megapointe oben drauflegen. Weil ich hatte ja kurz gesagt, Anthropic hat jetzt so ein Plugin veröffentlicht für Excel. Das heißt, alle Funktionen von Excel stehen jetzt plötzlich auf Zufuft zur Verfügung. Man braucht keine Excel-Weitmeisterschaft mehr. Jeder kann das jetzt. Die Software, auf dem das ganze ökonomische läuft, ist jetzt wie jeden. Nur eine Woche später möchte ich gerne fragen. Ja, ich habe jetzt das Plugin, aber wozu brauche ich Excel? Wozu braucht irgendwer noch Excel? Ich habe meine eigenen Finanzdaten der letzten Jahre. Die Banken stellen sie ja mittlerweile als CSV, strukturiert zur Verfügung. Ich gebe das einfach kloot. Ich sage kloot nicht mehr, bitte leihert es einmal durch Excel, je nachdem, welche Funktionen Microsoft sich irgendwann mal ausgedacht hat, die jetzt zur Analyse dienlich sind, sondern ich sage kloot, was ich will, unabhängig davon, welche Entscheidung die 5 Billionen-Firma Microsoft mal getroffen hat, was man jetzt mit solchen Daten macht. Also wir sind so jenseits von allem einfach, dass ich mir denke, diese Arbeitswelt, die wir gerade haben, die unter dem Diktum läuft, alles, was automatisiert werden kann, muss von Maschinen erledigt werden, weil ansonsten die Maschine mit dem Mensch im Wettbewerb steht und der Mensch diesen Wettbewerb immer verliert, muss hier ganz große Befreiung stattfinden. Was ja bedeutet, Leute, die jeden Tag acht Stunden starr auf den Computer schauen und allenfalls die Hand so ein bisschen bewegen, also sowohl Handgelenke als auch Nackenschmerzen bekommen davon und dann sozusagen Feierabend erleben, die müssen jetzt wirklich befreit werden. Und damit meine ich so ungefähr halb Deutschland. Also wir als Wohlstandsnation, in der jeder jetzt durchgesetzt hat, dass man natürlich einen Arbeitsplatz mit Tageslicht und so weiter hat, das sind ja genau diese Computer-Arbeitsplätze, diese Evolution der letzten 30 Jahre. So und jetzt ein Hinweis auf die Oper. Wir können nicht diese Arbeitswelt, wie wir sie haben, verteidigen, gegen Maschinen auch noch. Also nicht nur gegen Eliten, jetzt müssen wir auch noch gegen Maschinen verteidigen. Und dann einfach sagen, aber abends sind wir richtig Menschen und gehen in die Oper. Also das ist einfach, das passt überhaupt gar nicht zusammen. So wenn ihr glaubt, das ist ein geschlossenes, auch noch sozusagen Plädoyer-fähiges Weltbild, dann möchte ich nicht, dass da die Oper drin vorkommt, weil ich sehe da ganz andere Sachen. Ja, das ist einfach völlig absurd. Also bitte jetzt im Kopf auch ein bisschen upgraden. Es ist immer schön, sich über mich lustig zu machen, weil ich alles mit AI mache und so. Gerne, also her damit. Aber nicht in dieser Art und Weise, dass man den einen Menschen als biologisch beschädigt nach der Geburt darstellt, der einfach Entwicklungshirten nicht nimmt. Aber zum Glück noch in die Oper geht, du Opfer. Also da wirst du noch mal angesungen und kannst passiv vertragen, was andere sich toll ausgedacht haben. Es ist ja völlig so gestört, kann man gar nicht sein in seiner linken intellektuellen Blasenhaftigkeit.
Meinst du, das war ein Linker?
Da ich mittlerweile ja sage, wir müssen überhaupt über alles nachdenken, verwende ich links natürlich auch nur noch als Beschimpfung hier in diesem Fall. Also wirklich schlimm. Wolfgang macht mit euch die Verteidigung der Bullshit-Jobs auch nicht so.
Nee, das will ich ganz klar sagen. Ich verteidige nicht die Bullshit-Jobs. Ich bin etwas skeptischer, was das anbelangt, was durch die KI ersetzt werden kann. Ich glaube, dass doch zum Teil kompliziertere Aufgaben sind im Sinne von, es braucht zwischenmenschliche Interaktion, um diese Dinge zu lösen. Aber klar, diese Fälle, die wir haben, wo man sagt, da muss jemand Excel-Tabellen einfacher ausfüllen. Und da fehlt nur noch jemand, dass wir das Programm haben, dass uns das einfach automatisiert macht. Da bin ich überhaupt kein Verteidiger, zumal wir ja beide große Profiteure genau all diese Entwicklungen sind. Also dass man mit Diepel sich alle möglichen Seiten übersetzen lässt, dass man diesen Podcast, du schneidest ihn ja, aber dank KI und so auch in einer anderen Geschwindigkeit schneiden kann, als das sonst üblich wäre. Dass wir eben diese ganzen Möglichkeiten haben der Recherche durch KI. Also ich bin jetzt niemand, der irgendwie sagt, schade, dass wir jetzt in dieser Welt angekommen sind. Und das wäre aber toll, wenn wir Jobs verteidigen, bei denen viele Leute ein sehr entfremdetes Leben führen. Also das kann ja nicht der Sinn sein. Weil dann sind wir wirklich in der Konstellation, die David Graeber beschreibt. Ja, also da ging es ja dann darum, wie könnte man eigentlich das Versicherungssystem und all das vereinfachen und das wäre möglich. Und Obama wird darauf angesprochen und sagt, ja, das würde so viele Jobs kosten. Also man lässt es einfach unnötig kompliziert, um dann zu sagen oder ich habe ja selbst damals, man kann es wirklich nachhören, vor dem Salon, war das, glaube ich, oder direkt im Salon zu der Graeber-Folge. Habe ich damals gesagt, ich habe einen Bullshit-Job ausgeführt. So, und was war mein Bullshit-Job an der Uni als wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter? Nicht nur, ich will jetzt nicht nur klagen, aber ein doch nicht oderheblicher Bestandteil war der, dass ich von meiner Doktor-Mutter Aufsätze bekam, die sie geschrieben hatte und die angepasst werden musste dem jeweiligen Style-Sheet, den die unterschiedlichen Verlage haben. Das heißt, die einen machen da ein Semikohl und die anderen da einen Komma und da einen Doppelpunkt und da ein Anführungszeichen und dort Fett gedruckt und sonst was. Und das ist einfach eine Arbeit, die in keiner Weise sinnvoll ist. Das ist eine Arbeit, die nur Fleiß bedeutet und man muss sich höllisch konzentrieren, weil man natürlich lauter Fehler macht, dass man dann sagt, ach Kommapunkt, ist mir doch jetzt egal. So, und wenn man das nun einfach Vibe, mit dem Vibe, ich hab keinen Bock, liebe KI, mach das mal hier, das ist ja dieser Style-Sheet, dann kann man damit einfach diese Bullshit-Shops wegfallen lassen, beziehungsweise die Zeit, die Bullshit-Zeit kann man dann wegfallen lassen. Und ich hätte in der Zeit mich zum Beispiel lieber mit den Studenten unterhalten und denen in irgendeiner Weise weiter geholfen, statt so einen Unsinn zu machen. Und davon gibt es schon sehr, sehr viele Tätigkeiten. Und wenn diese Tätigkeiten von der KI übernommen werden, dann ist das sehr gut. Nämlich dann ist das eine wirkliche Entbürokratisierung, die stattfindet.
Genau. Wenn ihr wollt, dass eure Eltern später von Menschen gepflegt werden, müsst ihr euch halt dieser Technologie zuwenden, die die Menschen, die eure Eltern pflegen, davon befreien, irgendwelche Berichte zu schreiben und so. Das ist einfach völlig eins plus eins ist hier zwei. Und dass es dann noch Elon Musk daneben gibt und seine Anhänger, die dann sagen, ey, die Betreuung des Hundes, er wird jetzt der KI übergeben, das ist halt deren Problem. Aber das ist ja nicht, ich bin ja nicht deren Verfechter. Das wird jetzt die Altenpflege, die Kindererziehung und die Haustiere an die KI-Auslage.
Ja, ich glaube, dass du manchmal gerne so die anthropologische Philosophie überspringst und dann die KI in einer Weise als Denken des Wesen uns darstellst, dass wir oft, zumindest wenn du mit uns sprichst, mit mir und den Hörern, den Unterschied zwischen dem Menschen und der KI nivelliert bekommen. Und da ist der Punkt, wo ich dann hier einhacke und sage, so geht es ja nicht.
Ich kann jetzt aber nicht noch ein drittes Buch über Familie schreiben und Oxytocin.
Familie und KI vielleicht.
Ja, da wo KI nichts zu suchen hat, Familie.
Das wäre ein guter Titel, da wo KI nichts zu suchen hat.
Aber das kann man sich auch selber denken. Also manche Sachen sind einfach zu offensichtlich, als dass ich da jetzt noch mal Hörnschmalz einlege, den Leuten zu sagen, ne bitte Elon Musks Idee nicht ernst nehmen. Also da muss einfach ein kloster Podcast Zuruf reichen und das ist dann auch so.
Ich mach den Zuruf dann.
Gut, genau. So jetzt nehmen wir den reichen alles weg, was sie haben. Ihr Geld, ihre Würde, ihr Intellektuelles und so weiter, Selbstverständnis. Diese Clip-Rundowns hier laufen auf ein Jahrhundert-Clip hinaus. Ich möchte es nur schon mal anteasern. Ja, wir hören jetzt ein bisschen Lars Klingbeil und ein bisschen Robert Alexander. Und danach kommt ein Jahrhundert-Clip. Also Lars Klingbeil zum Vorstoß.
Ich habe bei mir mal auf dem Dorf gelernt, du strengst dich an und du kommst in deinem Leben voran. Aber du kannst heute der Beste in der Schule sein, die Beste in der Ausbildung, im Studium, der fleißigste im Job.
Und du wirst dir keine Eigentumswohnung in Berlin, in Hamburg oder in München leisten können. Wenn du gut geerbt hast, dann ist das der Fall. Und das verstößt gegen das Leistungsbeginn. Und das ist ein ganz großer Unterschied.
Und das ist ein ganz großer Unterschied.
Dann ist das der Fall und das verstößt gegen das Leistungsprinzip.
In der CSU wollen sie davon nichts wissen.
Ja, die CSU, die CSU, die CSU. So, Lars Klingwald ist Finanzminister. Er könnte ja auch ein innerliches Argument mit Cancellfond machen, vibet aber so vor sich hin, was ich nicht gut finde. Denn das Programm der SPD ist ja viel besser. Zum Glück gibt es ja noch die Tagesthemen. Also ganz kurz hören wir hier diesen einen Punkt, der ganz wichtig ist in der Diskussion.
Auch bei der Erbschaftssteuer für jedermann schlägt die SPD eine Reform vor. Aktuell dürfen Elternteile alle 10 Jahre 400.000 Euro an Kinder vererben oder verschenken, steuerfrei. Stattdessen soll jeder Mensch künftig einen sogenannten Lebens-Frei-Betrag in Höhe von einer Million Euro erben können, ohne dies besteuern zu müssen. Das selbstgenutzte Eigenheim soll außerdem steuerfrei bleiben.
So, alle 10 Jahre 400.000 Euro, niemand versteht das. Das ist so völlig Nonsens. Da könnte die Philippa Segel-Klöckler wieder ein gutes Geldbuch drüber schreiben und sich fragen, wo kommt diese Zahl her? Ja, keine Ahnung. Aber was jeder versteht, eine Million Euro und das Haus der Eltern. Das prägt ja die Diskussion heute, dass irgendwelche Leute glauben, sie müssten das Milliardäre verteidigen, weil sie ja mal ein Haus erben. Und dass die SPD ja einfach sagt, wenn du nur das Haus deiner Eltern erbst, bist du nicht superreich, dann bist du einfach gar nicht gemeint. Und das ist ja einfach diese Million pro Person, wo einfach jeder von sich selber kurz, da muss man nicht mal, also mit Leuten schon mal gar nicht reden, da muss man nicht mal die KI fragen. Ich kann mich einfach kurz drüber nachdenken. Eine Million? Bin ich Millionär? Nee, okay, gut, dann bin ich raus. Wenn du nicht Millionär bist, bist du hier raus. Das bedeutet, von den 85 Millionen Menschen in Deutschland sind schon mal 83 Millionen hier gar nicht gemeint. Für die wird eine Steuerbefreiung, nicht mal eine Steuersenkung, sondern eine Steuerbefreiung stattfinden. Die SPD möchte dich von Steuern befreien.
Ich möchte den Vorschlag ergänzen, denn ich finde das immer noch komisch, dass wir so viel in den letzten Jahren darüber geredet haben und auch rechtlich einiges umgesetzt haben, um die Kernfamilien nicht als das einzige mögliche Modell zu denken. Und man aber beim Erben immer noch so dabei ist, dass man steuerfrei vererben kann, bis zu einem gewissen Betrag, wenn es die Eltern an die Kinder sind. Aber dass es zum Beispiel Freunde nicht können. Nun stehen aber viele Leute den Wahlverwandten viel näher als der eigenen Familie. Ich verstehe nicht, warum hier immer noch diese Unterscheidung aufrechterhalten wird. Das geht ja bis in die Linkspartei, zumindest ein Teil der Linkspartei, hinein, dass man immer noch diese Unterscheidung macht und man einfach sagen müsste, ja, dann soll die Person diese Millionen erben können. Und dann geht es auch nicht darum, wer ist jetzt wie gerade verwandt. Das ist alles unsinnig in meinen Augen.
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob das so stimmt, denn das Erbe und das Schenken ist so ziemlich gleichlautend im Gesetzestext.
Ja, aber bislang ist es ja immer noch so geregelt, dass wir eine höhere Erbschaftssteuer haben. Also wenn du mir jetzt was vererbst, dann muss dann viel höhere Erbschaftssteuer draufgezahlt werden, als wenn meine Eltern mir was vererben. Das ist ja so.
Das kann sein.
Und da gibt es ja noch mal einen anderen Verwandtschaftsgrad. Wenn du jetzt mein Onkel wärst, dann hätten wir so einen etwas besseren Steuersatz. Aber wo wir gar nicht miteinander verwandt sind, würde dann eine entsprechend hohe Steuer abfällig werden. Ich sage nur, man machte eine Unterscheidung plötzlich da zwischen Familie und Nichtfamilie, wo wir zu gleichen gesellschaftlichen Diskurs haben, wo man sagt, ja meine Freunde sind auch meine Familie.
Das ist ein anderer Punkt. Ich müsste selber noch mal nachgucken, weil jetzt triggert mich das natürlich. Denn die 400.000 Euro Freibetrag pro Kind alle 10 Jahre ist ja keine Erbe, sondern das ist ja eine Schenkung.
Das ist ja auch eine Schenkung.
Weil das ist ja noch nicht elternteilig gestorben. Und bei dem sehr berühmten Fall, Matthias Döpfner kriegt eine Milliarde, das war ja auch jenseits der Geburtenfolge. Also er war ja nicht die Tochter von, sondern es war ja auch eine Schenkung. Und er hat dann trotzdem im Rahmen dieser Schenkung die Bedarfsbedarfsprüfung entgegengenommen. Also ist ja wirklich alles zur Erbschaft.
Ja, aber das Erbrecht ist in Deutschland immer noch an der Familie ausgerichtet. Das ist auf jeden Fall wichtig. Wie das jetzt mit den Schenkungen geregelt wird, wird man sehen. Aber man kann auch in den Vorschlägen, zum Beispiel zur Erbschaftssteuer bei der Linkspartei oder so, stark sehen, dass man eigentlich an dem Modell festhält, dass sozusagen das Haus der Eltern und so etwas eine andere Rolle spielt, als wenn du mir jetzt ein Haus vererbst. Das halte ich für falsch.
Und da kann man immer wieder auch auf diese Pointe nur hinweisen, dass wir das bei der politischen Macht absolut ausgeschlossen haben. Also da musst du im Greichen sofort zurücktreten, weil da waren mal Trauzeuge irgendwo. Also die Vererbung von politischer Macht, sofort fettern wir Wirtschaft, das machen wir nicht, das ist Korruption, wie auch immer. Vererbung ökonomischer Macht, das Selbstverständlichste auf der Welt. Also da waren null Modernisierungen die letzten 300 Jahre statt, das ist schon interessant. So jetzt Robin Alexander in seinem Machtwechselpodcast. Vielleicht hören wir hier schon, wie das so ist, wenn man Podcasts ohne Springer im Hintergrund macht. Wir können das ja mal überprüfen.
Ja, also ich finde das Argument, das Urteil kommt erst in ein paar Monaten.
So, also hier die Diskussion kennen wir ja, dass die CSU und die CDU jetzt immer kommen und sagen, warum kommt denn die SPD jetzt mit Vorschlägen zur Erbschaftssteuerreform? Es dauert doch noch eine Weile, bis das Bundesverfassungsgericht dazu ein Urteil spricht, wo ich mir denke, er ist doch super klug, in dem Moment dann was in der Schublade zu haben, dass auch allen schon so ein bisschen bekannt ist, wie zum Beispiel eine Million Euro. Du bist frei und sei es für die Diskussion, misch dich nicht ein, forder, stell Sachen. Aber es geht nicht um dich, sei dir das bewusst. So, und dass überhaupt jemand in der CDU kommt und sagt, das ist ja ganz doof, dass die sich schon mal das Feld bereiten für die Diskussion und so. Und du denkst, der macht doch ein Game-Vorschlag.
Vorher dürfen die Parteien dazu nicht sagen. Das verstehe ich nicht, weil glaubt man zu wissen, in welche Richtung das Urteil geht. Und zweitens Parteien tragen zur Meinungsbildung bei. Also ich möchte das SPD-Konzept kennen und ich möchte auch das CDU-Konzept kennen und sonst.
So hört das sich also an, wenn Robin Alexander nicht mehr bei Springer ist und nicht mehr der CDU das Wort redet und uns erklärt, was Merz wieder Kluges gemacht hat und warum es jetzt ganz wichtig ist, in Detail zu gehen. Ja klar, das macht doch voll Sinn, dass eine SPD zur Willensbildung beiträgt. So, wer kann denn da was dagegen haben?
Einige Konzepte, um mir eine Meinung bilden zu können. Also die Strategie der CDU, bis das Urteil kommt, sagen wir hier gar nichts, die erschließt sich mir nicht. Also da finde ich, da bin ich eher bei der SPD. Und die SPD hat natürlich einen Punkt, selbst wenn man geschworener Marktwirtschaftler ist, wie wir beide, dazu müssen die Hörer wissen, bei Dagmar Rosenfeld zu Hause steht eine kleine Statue von Ludwig Erhard.
Genau, ich habe dir sozialen Marktwirtschaft Unterschlupf gewährt.
Aber selbst wenn man halt so drauf ist wie wir, muss man doch sagen, das große Argument gegen die Erbschaftssteuer ist ja, bereits versteuertes Einkommen wird dann nochmal besteuert. Und man nimmt den Leuten einen Leistungsanreiz, weil ein sehr gesunder Leistungsanreiz ist. Ich möchte gerne meinen Kindern was vererben, dass meine Kinder es mal besser haben. So, das ist das Argument dagegen. Nur das Argument dafür ist natürlich in einer Vermögenssituation, die immer weiter auseinandergeht in der Bevölkerung, kommst du irgendwann zu so einer krassen Verzerrung der Ausgangslage, dass du keine Leistungsanreize mehr hast, dass die geschwächt werden. Das ist das Argument, das Lars Klingball zum Beispiel bringt. Er sagt, man kann arbeiten, wie man will. Man kann sich keine Eigentumswohnung in Berlin mehr leisten und das ist nicht in Ordnung. Und ich finde, das ist ein Argument, wenn man mit Christdemokraten abseits der Mikrophone spricht, sind die dem durchaus zugänglich.
Ja, was man ja mal festhalten kann ist, also Ammlinger und Nachtweih machen dieses Buch zerstörungslos und reden dort von blockierten Leben, was dazu führt, dass Leute sehr wütend sind und lieber alles zerstören wollen als und so weiter. Was wir auf jeden Fall haben, selbst bei den Leuten, die nicht ein blockiertes Leben in sich spüren, ist, dass wir eine blockierte Republik haben. Leute können nicht mehr umziehen, weil sie sich das nicht zutrauen, weil ich kriege ja keine Wohnung und dann hänge ich, was mache ich dann jahrelang in Stuttgart, bis ich da und so weiter. Also wir sind hier sehr, sehr, sehr blockiert einfach. Und deswegen nutzt Robin Alexander nicht nur die Gelegenheit, dass die CDU noch nicht sprechfähig ist, aber legt den schon mal Argumentationen in die Worte, um ihn dann zu widersprechen, sondern obwohl die SPD selber ja gerade sehr redselig ist, bringt er sogar deren Punkte noch mal selber in seine Diskussion ein.
Also die Lage ist ja jetzt, dass durch die Gesetzgebung etwas entstanden ist, dass die Erbschaftssteuer eigentlich eine dummen Steuer ist.
Ja, das traut sich die SPD nicht zu sagen. Aber es ist ja genau so. Also traut sich jetzt Robin Alexander das einfach zu sagen, weil es ist ja so. Ich finde, ihr werdet schon neuer Wind durch diesen Machtwechsel-Podcast. Das ist ganz erstaunlich.
Über die Freibeträge so arbeiten, dass man fast nichts zahlen muss. Und irrerweise, je mehr man erbt, desto weniger muss man zahlen. Da gibt es den Begriff der Verschonungsbedarfprüfung. Und die fällt an, wenn du mehr als 26...
So Verschonungsbedarfprüfung. Warum durfte man da? Unterspringer dachten, nie drüber reden. Ach ja, wegen Topfnau und der Milliarde und so.
Jaja, das ist genau das, was ich hier punkt.
Das ist natürlich jetzt hier ein bisschen anders...
.1.000.000 Euro erbst, also in diesem Wert. Dann musst du in der Regel keine Erbschaftssteuer zahlen. Und hier sieht die SPD auch einen Kampagnenmoment. Und ich glaube, die CDUs, die CSU sind gut beraten, das ernst zu nehmen. Weil das Argument, wenn du ein Haus erbst und dieses Haus steht in einer guten Lage, dann musst du über das, was über den Freibetrag hinaus ist, Steuern zahlen für das eine Haus, was du erbst. Wenn du 301 Häuser erbst und die vorher in eine Immobilienfirma getan worden sind, dann musst du keine Erbschaftssteuer zahlen. Und das verstößt gegen das Gerechtigkeitsempfinden von weiten Teilen des Volkes. Ja, genau so ist es.
Wir wollen gar nicht in das Sprechen.
Deswegen hören wir hier mal weiter. Das ist ja unglaublich.
Ja, ein spektakulär faszinierendes Manöver. Muss man auch erst mal drauf kommen. Du stellst ein Konzept vor und an der entscheidenden Stelle trägst den X ein. Nämlich wie hoch sind die Steuersätze? Sie sagen nur Progression nach dem Freibetrag. So und wenn das so bliebe, wie es jetzt ist, dann wäre es ja in der Spitze 50 Prozent. Dann wäre es zu hoch. Dann müssten viele Leute die Unternehmen verkaufen. Also das kann es nicht sein. Aber das Interessante ist, dass die SPD jetzt nicht gesagt hat, wir stellen ein in sich geschlossenes, vernünftiges Konzept vor, sondern eben extra diese Leerstelle programmiert hat, gegen die jetzt die Union polemisieren kann und dann aber gleichzeitig der Union die Möglichkeit eröffnet, in Verhandlungen zu treten und zu sagen, guck mal, jetzt haben wir aber schöne, niedrige, vernünftige Sätze rein verhandelt. Also sie haben quasi der Vernunft und dem Koalitionspartner das gleiche Türchen offen gelassen, was schon echt ein spannendes Manöver ist.
Ja, hört, hört Leute, hört, hört. Letzter Clip dazu, wir wollen natürlich jetzt, wo gerade die große Ehrlichkeit hier einzieht, in der deutschen Podcastlandschaft noch mal hören. Wer ist jetzt unser aller zentraler politischer Feind?
Seit 20 Jahren doktert die Politik an diesem Problem rum und das Verfassungsgericht sagt immer wieder, so geht das nicht. Und die beiden Kernargumente des Verfassungsgerichts sind, ihr müsst die Leute gleich besteuern und ihr dürft nicht ohne wenigstens zu prüfen Steuern erlassen. Also und Per Steinbrück, Roland Koch, Wolfgang Schäuble, also ja nicht die Schlechtesten haben sich daran versucht. Und warum sind die gescheitert?
Ich sage nur drei Buchstaben CSU.
So ist es. Die CSU hat sich immer auf den Standpunkt gestellt, das geht alles zu weit und wir sind die Schutzmacht der Familienunternehmen und auch der anderen Unternehmen.
Sag mal, haben die beiden das Buch von Martina Linato?
Also es ist ganz erstaunlich. Alle jammern immer rum, weil das Jahr so und der Januar allein alles so dramatisch. Aber der Machtwechsel Podcast ist dramatisch besser geworden.
Wir wollen schauen, ob das so bleibt. Aber hier ist es ganz bemerkenswert.
So, jetzt kommt ein Jahrhundert Clips. Wirklich ganz erstaunlich. Wir sprachen schon mal über den All-In-Podcast.
Ja.
Drei Milliardäre und jemand, der nur 600 Millionen Dollar auf sich vereint. Was bedeutet? In Amerika gibt es gerade 350 Millionen Menschen, aber nur 2000 Milliardäre. In Prozenten, wir reden ja mal gerne von den 99 Prozent, den 1 Prozent und so weiter. Also dieser Podcast wird gestaltet, vier Leute von denen 0,001 Prozent. Ja. Wir sind ja noch jenseits von allem, was wir je in Büchern gelesen haben. Wenn man in Büchern mal so, bei Milano wird es schon so 0,001 Prozent. Wenn vielleicht nochmal die 001 Prozent. Aber jetzt hören wir die 0,001 Prozent-Klasse. Die Billionär-Klasse. Und David Friedberg, ich stelle ihn nur kurz vor, war einer von den ersten 1000 Mitarbeitern bei Google, direkt mit Larry Page gearbeitet, wahrscheinlich sehr umtriebig. Insgesamt hat er dann so durch die Lande gefahren, hat gesehen, ah krass, Wetter ist ja doch voll und voll bedeuert. So die Climate Company gegründet, die also Wetterdaten verkauft. So ein bisschen wie hier Kachelmann das ja auch macht. Also das große Angebot, wie wird das Wetter bei uns? Wird es glatt? Und dann aber so ganz punktuell auf deinem Acker, auf deinem Firmengelände, wann muss hier abgepumpt werden, wie auch immer. Und diese Firma hat Monsanto damals gekauft, für 1,1 Billion, also Milliarden, weshalb er seitdem Milliardär ist. Und dieser Umtriebigkeit halt weitergeht. Und er macht jetzt folgende Beobachtung. Und wir hören jetzt nicht nur, was zu erwarten ist, und zwar einer ganz schönen A, B Dichotomie, sondern auch, warum sind die eigentlich so reich? Wir können jetzt mal hören, was er erklärt, warum die so reich sind und uns fragen, hat das mit irgendeinem Leistungsgedanken noch zu tun? Das meine ich jetzt nicht auf dieser vulgärartigen, da arbeiten andere für dich oder so, sondern es sind doch, wie man jetzt so hört, ganz große politische Wetterlagen, die irgendwas mit Zinsen und der Fett und irgendwas mit der globalen Wirtschaftslage zu tun haben und gar nicht so sehr mit, ob überhaupt noch jemand arbeitet oder so. Also hier bei David Friedberg aus dem All-in-Podcast Episode 259 im Januar, da hört man es mal ganz deutlich.
Ich möchte nur noch einen letzten Punkt machen. Es ist ein Moment der De-Dollarisation. Es ist immer wert, eine Reflexion darauf zu haben. Aber ich möchte es einfach zurück zu Minnesota, Donald Trump und Sozialismus. Und ich denke, es ist wichtig für uns, dass, wenn ihr Inhalte habt, wie wir es tun, die vier von uns, wir haben Inhalte, wir haben Real Estate, wir haben andere Inhalte. Als die Dollar innen und alles innen und wertig ist, gehen unsere Inhaltepreise hoch und wir werden wealthier und wealthier und wealthier. Die Mehrheit der Amerikaner hat keine Inhalte. Sie sind nette Inhalte. Als Ergebnis leben sie aus Inhalt und sie haben keine Vorteile aus der De-Dollarisierung, wie die Inhaltepreisenden. Das ist das, was die Populisten in den USA letztlich füllen. Die Populisten in den USA sind das, was den Sozialismus betrifft. Die Response zu diesen Behavioren ist das, was Donald Trump gewählt hat, und die Response zu den Donald-Trump-Aktionen ist das, was die zivilen Unreste in Minnesota und anderen Plätzen betrifft. Ich glaube grundsätzlich, dass viel der Unreste, der zivilen Unreste und letztlich dieses Bedeutung in diesem Land durch die Faktoren, dass die De-Dollarisierung wegen der überlegten Spenden der Regierung letztlich die Mehrheit der Menschen in diesem Land zu fühlen, verletzt und hinterlassen, weil sie ein paar Menschen in diesem Land sehen, die ihre Netzwerte zerstören, wie wir alle hier sind, und es gibt keinen Weg für sie, sich zu fangen, weil sie eigentlich keine Inhalte haben. Also, ich werde mit euch ehrlich sein, und ich werde eine Verwaltung machen. Ich war heute Morgen im Gym, auf der Treppe. Du warst im Gym? Ja. Und während ich da war, dachte ich über die Wachstumskraft, die in Kalifornien geht. Ich frage mich, ob es eine Unwahrheit sein könnte, um die USA von einer Zivilwahl zu halten. Ich meine das sehr ganzheitlich. Ich weiß einfach nicht, ob es eine Art von Solving dieses Fiskalproblems ohne eine funktionale Wiederverwaltung von Wohl ist. Und die Frage ist, kann man es violence oder non-violente machen? Und wenn es einen non-violenten Weg gibt, denke ich, das ist wahrscheinlich der preferable Weg.
Ja, ist ja ganz erstaunlich.
Er war heute Morgen im Fitnessstudio, Ich glaube, er hat sich mal kurz so Gedanken gemacht und meinte, krass, wir sind ja vor allem Bürgerkrieg, außer wir kriegen noch mal eine zivilisierte Umverteilung hin.
Ja, dass er dafür bis ins Jahr 2026 schreiten muss, um bei dieser Erkenntnis anzukommen, ist dann ja immer ganz bemerkenswert, aber so ist es dann.
Hier hört man jedenfalls nicht raus, dass die Milliardäre sind und dann noch mehr Milliarden haben, Jahre später, weil irgendwer fleißig gearbeitet hat, weder sie selbst noch ihre Mitarbeiter, sondern hier gibt es einfach Großwetterlagen in Währungsdissbalancen. Und dann wird das halt ausgeglichen durch politische Versuche, dass durch hier noch Dollar drucken und da und 30 Billionen Schulden kommen, legen wir noch drauf und so weiter. Und wir wissen ja, wie dieses Geld dann fließt. Jeder, der im Supermarkt feststellt, das ist aber teuer hier, ja, das Geld ist dann nicht weg. Es hat nur die Seite gewechselt. Ja, und es ist halt irgendwo und da ist es halt.
In Bilanzen denken wir jetzt gleich auch im Salon. Noch ein kleiner Hinweis. Am 13.02. bin ich mit Ole in Hamburg.
Welche Städte?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das heißt jetzt gerade. Jedenfalls erzählen wir dort die deutsche bundesrepublikanische Wirtschaftsgeschichte anhand von Schlagern.
Ist sehr gut. Stellt ihr euch da auch eine Statue von Ludwig Erhard hinten ins Bücherregal?
Nein, aber Ludwig Erhard wird bestimmt auch fallen, dieser Name. Aber vielleicht dann doch.
Singt ihr diese ganzen Schlager?
Wir singen nicht alle Schlager, aber wir werden auch singen. Wir werden auch singen, aber wir werden nicht alle Schlager singen. Das wäre ein bisschen viel.
Okay.
Jetzt aber zu unserem Salon. Wir wollen unseren Blick weiten ins Globale. Das tun wir mit Patrik Kacmarczyk. Der hat ein Buch geschrieben, das heißt Zerfall der Weltordnung, die Ignoranz des Westens und der Aufstand des globalen Südens. Das ist ein Buch, das uns mitnimmt in die großen Institutionen, die wir eigentlich fast nie kritisch beleuchten. Was tut eigentlich der IWF? Was ist mit der Weltbank? Inwieweit oktouieren wir den armen Ländern Austeritätspolitik auf? Wie sind sie abhängig davon, wenn jetzt gerade der Dollar mal so oder so von der FED ausgerichtet wird, wenn wir eine Hochzinspolitik haben? Was bedeutet das eigentlich in den anderen Ländern? Es ist ein Buch, das uns mit Wahrheiten konfrontiert, wo man eigentlich sagen muss, mich wundert ja, dass überhaupt noch jemand aus dem globalen Süden mit uns spricht. Jetzt kann man sagen, die Alternativen sind auch nicht so grandios, aber es ist wirklich so drastisch, wenn man das alles mal so aufgeschrieben bekommt, in sehr knappen Kapiteln uns erklärt wird, wie das wo funktioniert. Argentinien wird hier als Beispiel uns auch sehr genau erläutert. Es ist tatsächlich ein Buch, das einen ja auch mit Wut erfüllt, weil man so, also diese Ordnung, die als Ordnung immer beschrieben wird, war halt immer eine Ordnung für uns. Und für andere bedeutet das eigentlich Willkür und Chaos.
Ja, das sagst du so. Also, ich hab mir beim Lesen auch die Frage gestellt, wer ist hier eigentlich globaler Süden? Ich hab da Sachen wie Ostdeutschland gelesen, bei denen ich mir denke, schön und gut, dass Amerika der Weltpolizist ist. Aber wenn er in Minnesota auftritt, dann kann man nicht einfach sagen, oh, zum Glück bin ich Amerikaner, ich bin hier geschützt. Sondern da richtet sich die Ordnung doch gegen viel.
Ja, also diese...
Die regelbasierte Ordnung.
Ja, also diese ganze marktliberale Ideologie wird hier sehr gut analysiert und wirklich auch anhand der Institutionen gezeigt, wie es funktioniert. Das ist also das Buch, über das wir gemeinsam diskutieren. Außerdem gibt es von mir wieder einen Musik-Tipp, Klavier-Trio. Dann fragen wir uns, gibt es einen neuen faschistischen Körper? Und wenn ja, wie sieht er aus? Dagmar Herzog hat dazu ein Buch geschrieben, dann lange schon angekündigt, jetzt endlich Thomas Wagner, Wege aus der Gewalt, Impulse für ein neues politisches Denken. Gibt es also eine Möglichkeit, jenseits des Sozialstaats zu denken? Außerdem blicken wir auf die Streamingplattform Mubi, die sich enorm entwickelt hat, aber jetzt doch auch mit einigen Ärgernissen zu kämpfen hat. Und wir schauen uns noch an, wie eigentlich Öl von Venezuela nach China gelangt. Da gibt es eine Recherche aus dem Handelsblatt.
Haufen wir keine Pipeline? Nein. Okay, sehr gut. Das nicht über Politik reden Buch schieben wir nochmal auf für ein anderes spektakuläres Buch. Ich war so gefesselt, selten war ich so gefesselt von einem Buch. Ich habe es gehört, von der Autorin selbst gelesen, Giulia Enders, organisch. Es kam schon im August. Ich habe es gar nicht mitbekommen. Aber sie hat nach damit Charme 10 Jahre als Ärztin hinter sich gebracht und hat jetzt ein neues Buch vorgelegt. Es ist wirklich ein Spektakel. Und unter den Gesichtspunkten, in denen wir, der Körper im Faschismus, der Körper als Sinngebung fürs Leben, die KI hat keinen Körper, was bedeutet das alles? Das wird mir richtig gut aufgeklärt. Dann stelle ich zwei Texte gegenüber, die New York Times. In search of a platonic co-parent. Leute nutzen es nicht nur in Datingplattformen, sondern sie suchen auch Leute, mit denen sie Kinder großziehen können. Und sie sagen ausdrücklich, ich will schon weiter rumdaten und so weiter. Mir geht es hier nur um die Kindererziehung. Und das gleichen wir danach ab mit diesem neuen Text von der Heritage Foundation, Saving America by saving the Family. 150 Seiten Policy Paper. Ich weiß nicht, also die drehen mittlerweile so am Rat, das ist wirklich unglaublich. Und zum Abschluss Dario Amodei, der Anthropik Chef. Von dem haben wir ja schon diesen Text geschrieben, Machine of Loving Grace oder sowas, wo also die utopischen, wir werden, alles wird 40 mal schneller entwickelt und so weiter und so fort. Er hat jetzt einen zweiten Text geschrieben, den hat er ja auch da, wo es schon so ein bisschen angekündigt, The Adolescence of Technology. Dieser Text ist sehr lang, was ich witzig finde, da wir alle wissen, also schon ohne KI schreiben diese Leute diese Texte nicht selber. Mit KI und vor allem mit eigener wissen wir ungefähr, wer diesen Text geschrieben hat. Also habe ich ihn auch von Claude lesen lassen. Wir lesen also nur, was Claude mir gesagt hat, was in dem Text drin steht.
Und darauf vertraust du, dass Claude das kann?
Also wenn mich Claude jetzt belügt, dann wurden wir halt hin ins Licht geführt und der Abo da hat über was anderes geschrieben und ich frage mich, ja und? Es ist ja nur ein literarischer Beitrag, was?
Was heißt nur ein literarischer Beitrag?
Naja, der Typ weiß, also der hat für sich entschieden, dass er seine Ideen über Technologie in die Welt bringt. Ja, ich frage mich, warum schreibt überhaupt Texte? Ehrlich gesagt ist es auch bei Palantir und The Technological Republic so. Dieses Buch, da wir es sehr kritisch lesen können, schadet ja eher dieser Mission, weil es doch sehr viel Skepsis unterfüttert, die man Palantir entgegenbringen kann. Also wir hätten sehr viel weniger Argumente dem bayerischen oder baden-württembergischen Grünen nochmal zu sagen, warum sie Palantir, wenn er das einfach nicht geschrieben hätte.
Ja genau.
Genauso wie zu Gutenberg jetzt Bundeskanzler wäre, hätte er einfach keine Dissertation geschrieben. Also Texte können auch schädlich sein für die Leute und in der Hinsicht finde ich es schon witzig, dass er auch nochmal im Sinne von für ihn nur Literatur vorlegt.
Gut bei Gutenberg ist es glaube ich etwas anders. Da geht es um Zertifikate zu erhalten. Aber hier in diesen Fällen möchte ich jetzt ganz klar sagen, diese Leute sind ja so von sich überzeugt, dass sie eigentlich so eine Verfassung schreiben. So muss man das eigentlich sehen. Wie würde ich jetzt eine Verfassung schreiben? Ich stelle mir mal folgendermaßen die Welt vor. Ich schreibe es mal genau nieder. Und so machen das die ja eigentlich. Also auch Antriessen Horowitz, die auch immer solche langen Texte herausgeben, die schreiben gerne so auf, wie sie die Gesellschaft haben. Man könnte dann sagen, wir haben doch hier schon ein Grundgesetz rumliegen. Ja, ne, interessiert mich nicht. Ich habe mir so eine eigene Verfassung.
Okay, dann frame ich es anders. Superreiche, supermächtige, super schöne Leute lassen sich morgens eine Morgenlage vorlegen. Wir kennen sehr viele Leute, die daran arbeiten, MIG zum Beispiel, die so eine Morgenlage aufbreiten. Also es gibt Leute, die lesen wirklich, was in der Welt steht. Und andere kriegen dann so ein Konzentrat so, ja.
Und du machst das jetzt im Prinzip mit der KI auch, wie die Mächtigen sagst, leg mir mal eine Morgenlage vor.
Also ich bin sehr gespannt, falls es Diskussionen dazu gibt. Also die Kritik nehme ich gerne entgegen, dass ich ja den Text von Dario Amodei nicht vollständig über meine Augen konsumiert habe, während wir alle wissen, wer der Autor ist und welche Technologie er in Anschlag bringt und so weiter. Also für die auch witzig.
Das alles werden wir gleich diskutieren, besprechen, empfehlen im Salon. Den Salon kann man hören, wenn man ein Abo abschließt. Es ist also ein Zusatzinhalt zu den Neuen Zwanzigern. Manchmal muss man es noch mal dazu sagen, weil manche glauben auch, es sei ein einfach getrenntes Podcast oder so.
Weil du sagst, das ist der Zusatzinhalt. Das stimmt. Aber wenn ihr bei Steady euch einen Account macht, dann das Geld bezahlt und dort Zugriff auf den Salon habt, dann ist der Salon sozusagen ein eigenständiger Podcast. Also wenn ihr dann in die Apple Podcast App geht, weil das eure Lieblingspodcast App ist, und ihr nehmt den RSS Feed des Salons, den ihr von Steady bekommt, und ihr tragt den in der Apple Podcast App ein, dann ist in der Apple Podcast App der Salon ein eigener Podcast. Ihr seht dann trotzdem immer noch die von Apple angebotenen Salonfolgen im allgemeinen Podcast. Aber das darf euch bitte nicht länger verwirren. Ich hab jetzt ein paar E-Mails dazu geschrieben. Apple weiß nicht, dass ihr Salon-Abonnenten seid. Euch wird also das dort nicht einfach ausgeblendet. Sondern das ist halt trotzdem da. Aber ihr habt ja schon den Salon als eigenständigen Podcast. Ihr könnt also diesen teureren Button-Click da einfach ignorieren, denn es ist ja derselbe Salon.
Genau. Und man kann dann über diesen RSS-Fit, den man von Steady erhält, generell alles hören. Das heißt, man muss nicht noch zusätzlich die Neuen Zwanziger nochmal irgendwo anders abonniert haben, sondern es reicht eigentlich. Mit Steady ist man rundum versorgt.
Genau. Wenn ihr bei Steady-Abonnenten seid, könnt ihr überall anders den Podcast ignorieren, denn ihr bekommt ja auch die Monatsfolge ohne Werbung im Salon-Feed dann bei Steady.
Und jetzt noch zum Schluss, wer das gerne lieber verschenken möchte, kann das auch tun. Für ein Jahr kann man via Steady den Salon verschenken. Außerdem freuen wir uns, wenn ihr überhaupt den Salon und die Neuen Zwanziger weiterempfehlt und den Podcast positiv bewertet. Ich würde sagen, genug der Werbung. Wir gehen jetzt hinein in den Salon.
So ist es. Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Trumps way or the highway? Stimmst du zu?
Wirklicherweise schon.
Ja, das ist nämlich ganz erstaunlich. Wir haben ja also ein Buch mit einem Vorwort, das es in sich hat, von Heiner Flassbeck. Und es sind Sachen, die wir schon wissen, aber sie nochmal offensichtlich auf so kurzen, also so offensichtlich dargeboten auf so kurzem Raum, einfach als der große Hinweis, man braucht für die Politik der Welt und damit ist auch jeder einzelne Wähler gemeint, der sich daran gliedert, ein intellektuelles Fundament oder ein Überbau oder wie man das auch immer bezeichnen. Und wenn man sich das so anschaut, haben wir ja schon häufiger das Play-Doh-Jeh dafür gemacht, zu sagen, man kann die Kohle auch einfach raushauen.
Ja.
Man muss jetzt nicht jedes Mal eine Verteilungsdebatte im Sinne von der Bundeshaushalt ist nur so und so groß. Wenn wir jemandem was geben, müssen wir jemandem was wegnehmen. Also wie viel weniger bei den Bürgergeldempfängern sollen es denn sein, damit wir uns Deutschland-Tickets leisten können oder was auch immer. Und jetzt sagt Heiner Flassberg einfach völlig verkehrte Frage. Und offensichtlich ist auch der Einzige auf der Welt, der das versteht, Donald Trump, der nämlich Amerika regiert und Amerika hat es schon immer so gemacht. Was kostet die Welt? Ach so, ja dann Billionen.
Er schreibt, während die gesamte Welt und selbst Europa vom IWF gemahnt und gedrängt werden, in Sachen Staatsschulden die Kirche im Dorf zu lassen, erlauben sich diverse Regierungen der USA eine Schuldenexplosion, die ihresgleichen sucht. Wüsste man, dass die amerikanische Position unhaltbar und auf Dauer wirtschaftlich schädlich ist, man könnte sich beruhigt zurücklehnen und auf den Tag warten, an dem die amerikanische Illusion an der Wirklichkeit zerschellt. Doch was, wenn es umgekehrt ist, wenn der amerikanische Pragmatismus in Sachen Staatsverschuldung vollkommen gerechtfertigt und notwendig wäre, um in dieser Welt erfolgreich zu wirtschaften.
Ja, das ist doch, und er sagt es dazu, niemand kann darauf eine exannte Antwort geben. Aber die Frage ist so trifftig, dass wir uns als diejenigen, die nun wirklich auch selbst über ihr Geld bestimmen. Wir hängen ja nicht vom Dollar ab, wir haben ja ein Euro. Wir haben beim Zahlungsverkehr ein bisschen ab, aber das ist ja Service. Also wir stehen hier vor, wie soll man sagen, wir wollen ja Trump eigentlich abklären und so. Aber jetzt holt er sich einen neuen Fatshelf, der ihm natürlich die, den Joke habe ich ja immer gemacht, wenn jemand Geld braucht, ich fahre auch immer bei der EZB vorbei. Ich kann auch den Brief dort reintun, in den Briefkasten bei denen und sagen, bitte überweisst. Und die machen das ja auch. Die schreiben ja selber flehende Briefe, bitte gib die Kohle aus. Und jetzt wird Trump noch mal drei Jahre mit einem eigenen Fatshelf regieren und das genauso machen. Der einzig vernünftige Weg und der einzige, der es macht.
Wir lesen das Buch Zerfall der Weltordnung, Die Ignoranz des Westens und der Aufstand des globalen Südens von Patrick Kaczmarczyk. Patrick Kaczmarczyk ist Wirtschaftswissenschaftler und er kennt sich aus in internationalen Beziehungen. Er war jetzt auch stellvertretendes Mitglied der Expertenkommission der Bundesregierung zur Reform der Schuldenbremse und er ist jemand, der ja internationale Entwicklungsarbeit wirklich kennt, denn er war dort tätig. Er kennt sich außerdem sehr gut aus, was Ostafrika belangt, wie auch den Nahen Osten. Er hat ja auch mit Adam Toos in der Zeit einen Artikel zum Krieg in Gaza veröffentlicht. Patrick Kaczmarczyk schafft es also wirklich einen globalen Blick auf die Welt einzunehmen. Wir lesen also jetzt zum zweiten Mal dicht hintereinander ein Buch, nachdem wir Branko Milanovic schon gelesen haben, das sich ja traut, einmal aus so einer rein eurozentrischen oder westlichen Perspektive auszubrechen. Aber nicht in dem Sinne so, ich gucke da jetzt mal so mit einer romantisierten Art oder so drauf, sondern hier ist jemand, der weiß, wie die Institutionen funktionieren, der weiß, was Schulden da und dort bedeuten, wie Geldpolitik in den USA sich auswirkt auf die gesamte Welt. Und da ist jemand, der versteht, in Bilanzen zu denken, weshalb auch interessant ist, dass er immer wieder uns zeigt, wenn wir hier den einen oder anderen Schritt fordern, also mit wir meine ich jetzt die westliche Hemisphäre mit ihren Institutionen, dann hat das drastische Auswirkungen, es sind skandalöse Zahlen, das Buch ist voller skandalöser Zahlen. Was ich vor allem bemerkenswert finde, ist, dass er immer wieder auf China zu sprechen kommt und damit ja auch schon diese Verbindung zu dem Fluffspec vor Wort hergestellt ist. Denn was wir hier sehen, ist ja, dass Trump sich nicht um irgendwelche EBF-Maßgaben schert und überhaupt die USA da immer wieder von sich gelöst hat und gesagt hat, wir machen hier unser eigenes Ding. Wir investieren auch groß da, wo es sein muss. Wir merken das jetzt gerade auch bei dem KI-Hype. Und dieses Buch beschäftigt sich ja auch mit dem Aufstieg Chinas und zeigt ja, China hat sich dem Internationalen Währungsfonds und der Weltbank auch nicht in dem Maße unterworfen, wie das andere Entwicklungsländer getan haben oder tun mussten vor allem. Und das bedeutet, dass, wo man sich gerade der marktliberalen Logik entziehen kann, dass dort tatsächlich der Aufstieg geschieht, während diejenigen, die an diese Logik gebunden sind und noch nicht mächtig sind, also es ist immer eine Politik der Mächtigen gegen die, die noch ohnmächtig sind, dass man dann auch auf einem niedrigen Entwicklungsstatus bleiben wird. Es sind sehr, sehr wichtige Erkenntnisse, die wir hier rausziehen können und alles Themen, die kaum präsent sind in unserem Diskurs über globale Gerechtigkeit und all das.
Das ist ja in Deutschland, also da hat er ja einige Pointen, auf die wir gleich zu sprechen kommen. Das, was du jetzt beschrieben hast, für Amerika, gilt ja für Deutschland. Aber wir werden gleich nochmal auffächern, ob es jetzt für die deutsche Bevölkerung von Bedeutung ist. Aber insgesamt haben wir ja schon diese Beobachtung gemacht die letzten Jahre, dass wenn eine Krise droht, der IWF dann immer kommt und sagt, Beispiel Griechenland, die Troika, also IWF, Europäische Kommission, Europäische Zentralbank, ihr müsst sparen, ihr dürft nichts mehr ausgeben, ihr dürft nur noch einnehmen, bitte verkauft alles. Während in Deutschland Krise, Abfragprämie, wir geben euch Geld, kauft ein Auto. Krise, Lohnfortzahlung bei Auftragsflaute. Diese Nullrunden, nicht Nullrunden, sondern diese, wie heißt es?
Kurzarbeitergeld.
Kurzarbeitergeld, genau. Betriebe werden stillgelegt wegen Corona, sie werden Corona-Hilfen gezahlt, dass es danach Skandal mit diesen Rückzahlungen gibt und so mal eingepasst. Aber wir haben auch nie so auf eine Krise reagiert, dass wir gesagt haben, ah Krise, wir machen erst mal alle Krankenhäuser zu. Wie der IWF einfach sagt, Gesundheitsausgaben. Das finde ich interessant, dass dann der Wirtschaftsrat kommt, der CDU. Also dass der IWF die brutale Politik für den globalen Süden jetzt als innenpolitische Maßnahme zu Hause vorschlägt, als in Form von CDU-Politik. Das sind natürlich so tagesaktuelle politische Proanten, will man mal sagen, die wirklich schlimm sind, wenn man so ein Buch gerade liest. Also Einführung, Krankheitsbild. Wir kriegen eine richtige Diagnose. Die Weltordnung zerfällt. Ich war mir ein bisschen unklar im Verlauf des Textes, ob hier wirklich eine Weltordnung zerfällt oder in den letzten Zügen der nochmal Einbetonierung gerade steckt. Ja, also es ist weniger mit einem Zerfall als es könnte sein, dass es demnächst einfach in die Luft fliegt. Weil bei Milanovic haben wir ja schon so die Langsamen. Also er hat ja auch beschrieben, bei dem Entwicklungsgrad jetzt gerade wird Amerika noch über Jahrzehnte dominant bleiben. Der Dollar unausweichlich und so.
Ja, vielleicht hat Kacmarczyk aber da recht, wenn er von einem Zerfall der Weltordnung spricht. Denn es ist natürlich etwas, was sehr schrittweise funktioniert und auch nur schrittweise funktionieren kann, es sei denn, es wäre da eine andere Ordnung dann da. Also wenn wir jetzt über das Ende dieser Weltordnung reden oder vom Zerfall dieser Weltordnung, dann schwingt er ja immer so mit und dann kommt die neue Ordnung. Also beispielsweise China als ordnende Macht. Aber das ist ja auch nicht zu sehen. Also wir sehen ein mächtiges China und auch wie China mächtiger wird. Genau, aber wir werden nicht sehen, dass das jetzt wie nach 45 die neue Weltordnung wird. Und deshalb ist vielleicht Zerfall ganz gut. Man muss auch dann sagen, aber auch ein genereller Zerfall der Weltordnung. Man könnte vielleicht behaupten, dass es dann eine dauerhafte Weltunordnung ist, in der wir leben. Jedenfalls ist dieser Gedanke, auf die eine Ordnung kommt die nächste Ordnung, nicht so sinnvoll zu denken. Und wir haben es eher mit so einem Zerfall zu tun, was aber ja sehr viele Akteure, die noch an dieser alten Weltordnung festhalten und sie aufrechterhalten wollen, zu Maßnahmen führt, dass sie jetzt so eine Überreaktion gerne am liebsten. Oder man könnte es vielleicht eher sagen, so eine Angstblüte erleben wir bei denen, dass sie jetzt noch mal gerade besonders vehement eine Weltordnung verteidigen wollen, was dann natürlich auch ziemlich viele Konflikte mit sich bringen kann.
Oder es ist eben was wir in Davos auch beobachtet haben oder schon in diesem Venezuela-Fall. Und das liegt eben dieses Vorwort nahe in dem Flashback-Aufteil zwischen der materiellen und der ideellen Weltordnung. Was wir auf jeden Fall sehen, ist ein Fall der ideellen Weltordnung.
Ja.
Also, dass Trump sich nicht mehr die Mühe macht, sein Militärs zu erklären, wir fahren jetzt nach Venezuela wegen den Frieden und der Freiheit, sondern wir machen das nur wegen dem Öl, zeigt ja, dass die materielle Weltordnung schlägt jetzt auf die intellektuelle Weltordnung durch. Statt da noch ein gegen oder ein erweitertes Programm zu fahren. Und das muss man ja auch erst mal aushalten. Das gab es ja nicht ohne Grund, sag ich mal so. Und so ist ja auch der Einstieg ins Buch. Also, Flassbeck redet noch von der 200 Jahre alten englischen Theorie des internationalen Handels, die, würde ich jetzt sagen, einfach, was man so intuitiv halt denkt, formuliert. Und Patrick beginnt damit der Belle Époque, also der schönen Epoche zwischen den Kriegen 1871 bis 1914, die Hochphase des damaligen Internationalismus. Man hatte sich grad so eingerichtet, bis dann die Katastrophe des ersten Weltkriegs noch keine neue stabile Nachkriegsordnung hergestellt hat, weil sein Vertrag, das hat ja dann erst wieder gedauert. Und so könnte man ja auch diesem intellektuellen Teil, diesem Überbau nachgehen und sagen, naja, in dieser schönen Zeit bis 1914 gab es Ideen der internationalen Zusammenarbeit, die wurden dann im ersten Weltkrieg zertrümmert. Die materielle Unordnung wurde nicht durch neue Ideen wieder aufgefangen, sondern man war einfach wütend, man hat einen wütenden Überbau. Wir zerren euch jetzt aus, wir bauen euch den Ruhrpott ab und so weiter. Und das führt dann natürlich dann in die größere Katastrophe, was ja bedeutet, ein Zerfall der ideellen Weltordnung, dem sollte man ganz ernst nehmen. Also wenn wir, also das ist sozusagen der Unterschied zwischen Katastrophe, erster und zweiter Weltkrieg, 100 Millionen Tote mehr, einfach nur, weil eine ideelle Weltordnung zerfiel oder gar nicht erst etabliert wurde zu materiellen Durcheinander.
Und dann kommt das, was man gerne als regelbasierte Ordnung beschrieben hat, also nach 45, wobei gleich eine paradoxe Situation ausgemacht wird. Da heißt es, wir sehen uns einerseits als Verfechter des freien Marktes, haben andererseits aber keine Probleme, unsere Wirtschaft durch Protektionismus und Interventionen zu schützen. Einerseits werfen wir anderen Ländern vor, mit Exportüberschüssen gegen die Regeln des Freihandels zu verstoßen. Andererseits sind wir stolz auf unsere eigenen Überschüsse, die alles übersteigen, was man in den größten Volkswirtschaften dieser Welt finden kann. Und dann zählt ja noch weitere Widersprüche auf, dass also diese Wirtschaftsordnung, die dann etabliert wird und die durch die westlichen Institutionen aufrechterhalten wird, eigentlich ein Widerspruch nach dem anderen produziert wird, von dem die Länder des globalen Südens, oder sagen wir alle Länder, die nicht der Westen sind, wissen. Das heißt, wenn wir uns jetzt gerade wundern, warum es so einen starken Vertrauensentzug des globalen Südens gibt, dann hängt das mit vielen Dingen zusammen, zumindest hängt es auch damit zusammen, dass es alternativ Angebote gibt in der multipolaren Weltordnung. Und diese Entwicklungsländer zum ersten Mal auch Möglichkeiten haben, sich für den einen oder anderen oder sogar beide Partner gleichzeitig zu entscheiden, während sie vorher doch sehr an der Kandare geführt wurden und mussten sich eigentlich immer nur diesem westlichen Regime unterwerfen. Wenn man auch hinzufügen muss, das ist noch sehr, sehr stark. Also wir haben es jetzt noch nicht mit einer Welt zu tun, in der man sagen kann, IWF und Weltbank verlieren an Macht. Aber wir sehen neu aufkommende Akteure.
Ich habe mich auch an diesem Einstieg ein bisschen festgebissen. Da ist doch mehr drin, als jetzt der Text selbst bot, so. Denn Woodrow Wilson war in Amerika von 1913 bis 21 Präsident. Führte dann Amerika auch in den Ersten Weltkrieg und hatte aber schon eine Nachkriegsordnung, Stichwort Völkerbund, im Hinterkopf. Heute wissen wir, die Idee war ungefähr so gut wie die der UN. Wie gut die UN war, sehen wir. Also 80 Jahre Frieden und jetzt so ein bisschen durcheinander. Und die Ironie der Geschichte ist auch, dass man damals den Vertrag von Versailles und so weiter gemacht hat, weil die gute Idee des amerikanischen Präsidenten, der also Truppen in den Europäischen Krieg, erster Weltkrieg geführt hat, vom eigenen Kongress nicht unterstützt wurde. Das hieß, am Ende gab es ein Völkerbund, aber der amerikanische Kongress hat seinem eigenen Präsidenten die Unterschrift verwehrt, da teilzunehmen. Was bedeutet, die erste Idee, eine UN zu gründen, ging nicht auf, weil der Ideengeber und größter, damals auch schon ein bedeutendster Anteil nicht teil war. Das sind also alles solche kleinen Stolpersteine in der Geschichte, wo man sich fragen könnte, was lernen wir denn daraus? Ja, so insgesamt. Wenn sich jetzt Amerika wie da aus allem rauszieht und man sich fragt, ja, Herr Karnel, gut gebrüllt, Löwe, aber willst du jetzt eine Mittelmächte Idee aufbauen, ohne Amerika, die aber nochmal dafür da ist, den globalen Süden weiter zu ignorieren? Denn das ist nochmal ein wichtiger Hinweis, auch in vielen Kommentaren, die wir bekommen hatten. Nein, Karnel hat auf den globalen Süden keine Rücksicht genommen. Nein, nein, nein. Der Stub aus Finnland hat das ganz kurz angemerkt in einem Gespräch zu seinem Buch in Davos. Hat keiner hingeschaut, so. Aber der Karnel hat auf den globalen Süden keine Rücksicht genommen, sondern es ging um die Idee, die Mittelmächte nochmal ohne Amerika zu ertüchtigen, das Programm weiterzufahren und schwierig.
Ja, ja, also ich will das auch nochmal deutlich machen, weil das mir auch aufgefallen ist, als würde ich ja so getan, weil die Rhetorik ja so ist, du hattest ja zu Recht gesagt, es klingt so ein bisschen, als hätte die afrikanische Union sich entschlossen, mal so eine antikolonialistische Rede zu formulieren. Nein, Karnel ist nicht gegen diese Art von Kolonialismus von IWF und Weltbank, die wir hier in dem Buch grandios beschrieben bekommen, sondern er sagt, jetzt können wir uns auf Amerika nicht mehr so verlassen. Und eigentlich war diese Partnerschaft auch immer ein bisschen asymmetrisch und wir haben gar nicht so sehr profitiert, wie wir uns das oft eingeredet haben. Aber er hat jetzt nicht gesagt, wir müssen als erstes, denn das wäre dann der Satz gewesen, der hätte fallen müssen, dass wir als erstes jetzt einen radikalen Schuldenschnitt für die Entwicklungsländer machen. Dann würde man sagen, okay, und mit denen setzen wir uns jetzt ins Benehmen und bilden gemeinsam als Mittelmächte und Entwicklungs- und Schwellenländer einen Block gegen meinetwegen die USA und wegen die auch noch gegen China oder so. Das wäre jetzt wirklich ein antikolonialistisches Programm. Er möchte nur, dass die Privilegien des Westens aufrechterhalten bleiben, auch ohne die USA beziehungsweise hin und wieder sogar gegen die USA und man sieht dann nicht, dass er sich jetzt anlegen wird mit EZB, Brüssel oder sonst irgendetwas. Das ist nicht das Programm.
Genau. Außerdem fand ich noch ganz interessant, also Bretton Woods, die Nachkriegsordnung kommt, der IWF kommt auch, aber wie so häufig, muss man sich das noch mal genau anschauen. Erst in den 80ern mit dem Washington-Konsensus wird das so pervertiert. Also man hijackt eigentlich eine politische Institution, die aus anderen Gründen und anderen Funktionsweisen und behält einfach die Marke bei sozusagen und verdreht das dann alles. Also man kennt es auch nicht den IWF per se, so wie man immer die EU per se oder die UN per se, sondern es kommt ja immer drauf an, wie es mit Leben gefüllt wird.
Eigentlich haben wir institutionell eine Machtordnung bis heute, die geprägt ist von 1944. Also da hat sich eigentlich wenig getan, obwohl wir solche wirtschaftlichen Entwicklungen haben und so viele wichtige Akteure jetzt auf dem Parkett sehen. Die militärische Dominanz, die wurde vor allem durch Institutionen ersetzt. Zwar haben die Amerikaner, wie wir wissen, so viele Militärbasen, aber sehr gut regieren kann man auch dadurch, dass man die Institutionen hat, dort entsprechende Veto-Rechte besitzt, beziehungsweise der Westen, das so für sich gestaltet hat, dass der globale Süden eigentlich marginalisiert wird, wo er doch allein schon, was die Bevölkerungsanzahl und auch die Anzahl der Länder betrifft, eine viel größere Rolle spielen müsste. Es ist eigentlich jetzt so eine Rückkehr der Anarchie. Und da sagt Kaz Maschek auch, das birgt natürlich für die Mittelmächte, also über die Kani gesprochen hat, eine große Unsicherheit. Aber die Sache ist auch, dass sich aus diesen Mittelmächten heraus nicht eine Formation ableitet, die jetzt das anders machen will mit Blick auf den globalen Süden. Und das könne man ja auch zum Beispiel besonders deutlich daran sehen, wie man sich zu dem Krieg in Gaza verhalten hat, dass man also hier deutlich signalisierte, vor allem dann von Deutschland, aber auch USA und andere europäische Länder, na ja, mit dem Völkerrecht, sagen wir mal so, das gilt für andere, aber nicht für uns. Und das, sagte auch Karl Smatschek, und er betont es ja an mehreren Stellen, hat eine große Auswirkung auch auf die wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit. Er kommt auch kurz auf Corona zu sprechen und sagt auch da, dass die Industriestaaten sich die Impfstoffe gesichert haben und dann diese Covax-Initiative aufgelegt haben, die aber ganz lange auf sich warten ließ, bis dann auch die Entwicklungsländer entsprechend beliefert wurden. All das zeigt natürlich, dass diese westliche Ordnung ein Vorteil ist für den Westen, aber nicht für den globalen Süden, weshalb sich da auch vermehrt Widerstand mobilisiert.
Ja, also bei dem Stopp, ich sag's nochmal, da kommt das Wort Nachkriegsordnung und 80 Jahre im Zitat vor. Das, was bei Carney fehlt. Wir haben also eine Nachkriegsordnung, wie du uns schon gesagt hast, die das bedeutet. Damals, der Queens-Bancor-Plan, also der 1944 dann zu den großen Abmachungen führte, da gab's zwei Alternativen. Man hatte auch noch die Idee, ein Bancor, das war aus England eine Idee, also eine supranationale Währung einzurichten. Durchgesetzt hat sich aber die USA, die sagte, ne, ne, wir nehmen mal Gold, koppeln den Dollar an Gold und dann alle anderen Währungen an den Dollar. Und damit war sozusagen Login, das ist die Nachkriegsordnung, die dann 40 Jahre später ermöglichte, den IWF zu so einem Missbrauchsinstrument zu machen. Also wir haben es hier mit einer durchaus aufklärungswürdigen Geschichte zu tun, die, wenn überhaupt jemand wie Kani sagt, die alte Ordnung gilt nicht mehr, da muss man die nochmal verstehen und dann eine neue bauen, aber nicht einfach jetzt durchschleifen, dass einer ausschert und man versucht, das Ding aufrecht zu erhalten. Also dass das Buch genau jetzt kommt, wo wir Davos gehört haben, ist natürlich nicht schlecht, denn die politische Kurzsichtigkeit, schreibt Patrick, ist damals wie heute. Wir haben zum einen eine aufgepeitschte Stimmung, da sieht man ja schon, wie alle in Davos ihre Reden beginnen. Also wir sind alle ganz aufgeregt und so. Macron macht noch Witze. Dann haben wir einen erheblichen Druck der öffentlichen Meinungsmacher. Also das sehen wir. Schüren von Angst, also das ist auch sehr prägend und ein Gefühl der Alternativlosigkeit.
In 2029 ist Krieg oder das ist der letzte Sommer des Friedens und so weiter. Er sagt, die Industriestaaten entdecken plötzlich, da ihre Unternehmen auf den Weltmärkten nicht mehr die unangefochten Nummer eins sind, dass sie auf protektionistische und industriepolitischen Maßnahmen zurückgreifen müssen. Auf Maßnahmen also, die sie den Entwicklungs- und Schwellenländern seit jeher verwehren. Da der freie Markt für ihre Entwicklung sorgen soll. Reflexartig kommt der Vorwurf, dass dies Jahr unter normalen Umständen auch der Fall sei. Aber China, dass China industriepolitisch sehr aktiv war und ist und dies bei einem Land, das nahezu ein Fünftel des globalen kaufkraftbereinigten BEP erwirtschaftet, auch weitreichende Folgen hat, lässt sich nicht beseitigen. Allerdings sollte man in der Kritik berücksichtigen, dass kein größeres Entwicklungsland auf dieser Welt es bisher geschafft hat, sich ohne industriepolitische Maßnahmen eine industrielle Basis aufzubauen. Die Industriestaaten selbst griffen am Anfang ihrer Entwicklung darauf zurück und tun dies auch weiterhin. Und er hat da ein Zitat von Präsident Ulysses Grant, der hat geantwortet auf Vorwürfe, die wurden in den Jahren 1861 bis 1865 laut, also wir gehen hier jetzt mal weit zurück, dass die USA sich doch bitte den Prinzipien des Freihandels unterwerfen sollten und dass es nicht sein könne, dass man so protektionistisch handelt. So wurde das vor allem von Großbritannien vorgetragen. Die Antwort des US-Präsidenten war, in 200 Jahren, wenn Amerika alles aus der Protektion herausgeholt hat, was sie zu bieten hat, wird es den Freihandel auch übernehmen.
Ja, das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen. Also heute, retrospektiv, macht das total Sinn, aber dass man damals schon so eine Voraussicht hatte, er kommt ja auch noch mal auf Hamilton zu sprechen, dass da einfach gesehen wurde, ne, die Prinzipien sind so eindeutig und klar, das wird die Entwicklung sein, wenn wir uns dafür entscheiden, finde ich schon sehr beachtlich. Also eben meinst du ein Zitat, habe ich gedacht, du liest den Londoner Professor Ha-Yon Chang vor, der nämlich eine schöne Gegenüberstellung gemacht hat. Er hat seinen Professoren die Aufgabe gegeben, nehmt mal hier diese zwei Länder und vielleicht lohnt sich, das wirklich in Länge vorzulesen. Das erste Land. Noch vor einem Jahrzehnt herrschte in diesem Land Protektionismus. Der Einfuhrzoll auf Industriegüter lag im Durchschnitt weit über 30 Prozent. Obwohl er kürzlich gesenkt wurde, blieben wichtige sichtbare und unsichtbare Handelsbeschränkungen bestehen. Das Land hat den grenzüberschreitenden Kapitalverkehr stark eingeschränkt, verfügt über einen staatseigenen und stark regulierten Bankensektor und hat eine Reihe von Restriktionen für Finanzanlagen verhängt. Und so weiter und so fort. Es geht um die Diskriminierung durch differenzierte Steuersätze. Es gibt keine Wahlen. Korruption ist allgegenwärtig. Eigentumsrechte sind undurchsichtig und kompliziert. Große Zahl staatseigener Unternehmen. Hohe Verluste werden mit Subventionen durch staatliche Garantien, weil man Monopolrechte schützen und politische Ideen durchsetzen will, durchgesetzt. Das ist das eine Land. Und alle, ja, ja, das ist China. So, und jetzt liest er bei dem zweiten Land. Lautet die Vorlesung. Die Handelspolitik des Landes war in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten mit einem Importzoll auf Industriegüter von 40 bis 55 Prozent buchstäblich die protektionistischste der Welt. Die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung darf nicht wählen. Stimmkauf und Wahlbetrug sind an der Tagesordnung. Korruption greift um sich. Politische Parteien verkaufen Regierungsämter. Der Staat hat noch nie einen Beamten mittels einer offenen Ausschreibung eingestellt. Also alles nur auf Zuruf und Freundesbasis. Staatsschulden, auch ausländische Investoren, die öffentlichen Finanzen stehen dermaßen auf der Kippe, dass die Staatsschulden auch ausländische Investoren beunruhigen. Ausländern wird niemals Führungsposition zugestanden. Wettbewerbsrecht fehlt völlig. Schutz geistigen Eigentums sehr löchrig. Das ist einfach das Amerika von damals, das du gerade vor 200 Jahren beschrieben hast. Also es ist wirklich diese Verlogenheit, die da drinsteckt, dass man den anderen nicht gönnt, weil man eine Entwicklungsgeschichte macht und dann quasi diktieren möchte von außen, wie China jetzt bitte am Welthandel teilzunehmen hat, ist wirklich beträchtlich.
Was ich auch bemerkenswert finde, das Buch ist so voll von kleinen Zahlen, bei denen man zu Stutzen denkt. Ach ja, also eine europäische Kuh wird nochmal mit zwei Dollar pro Tag subventioniert.
Sie gehört also nicht zu den 40 Prozent der ärmsten Menschen.
Sie wird mit zwei Dollar pro Tag subventioniert, damit wir auch schön exportieren können. Tomaten, also das ist auch so ein irres Beispiel. Also wie schafft man es, dass man aus einem Land zwar die Ressourcen, die man gerne haben möchte, bekommt, aber dieses Land jetzt nicht dadurch so reich wird, dass es eigenständig auftreten kann. Beispiel Tomaten. Da heißt es, in den Industriestaaten fallen auf verarbeitete Produkte wie Dosen Tomaten höhere Importzölle an, als auch frische Tomaten. Dies erschwert es den Entwicklungs- und Schwellendändern, eigene Verarbeitungskapazitäten aufzubauen und die damit verbundene Wertschöpfung im eigenen Land zu fördern. Das heißt, die sollen die Tomaten bitte rausrücken, aber nicht in Dosen packen, weil dann haben die ja eine höhere Wertschöpfung. Das heißt, wir verdienen ja dann weniger daran. Deswegen setzen wir da einen hohen Zoll drauf und dann bekommen wir die Tomaten so.
Ja, überlegen wir mal, wie verlogen die Welt ist, dass wir es jetzt gut finden und ich finde es wirklich gut, dass die spanische Regierung gegen europäische Widerstände sagt, diese 500.000, 700.000 Leute, die uns die Tomaten hier pflücken, werden zumindest mal eingebürgert gegen europäische Bürgerrechte. Obwohl das natürlich eigentlich, dass das überhaupt hier stattfindet, ist ja schon ein Skandal. Warum sind die nicht zu Hause, sage ich mal, etnopluralistisch, wo sie auch sein könnten? Also warum findet hier so ein riesengroßer Import von allem Möglichen statt? Und dann braucht man bis 2026, um die Idee aufzubringen, statt NATO-5-Prozent-Beitrag, bürgern wir jetzt mal diese Bürger ein, die ganz Europa mit Tomaten versorgen. Also diese Verlogenheit, da macht Patrick auch sehr gute Anmerkungen. Wir haben eine regelbasierte Ordnung, attackieren aber ständig wieder die Institutionen der globalen Judikative, die dann, wie zum Beispiel der internationale Strafgerichtshof oder andere Gerichte, dagegen vorgehen, was da passiert. Wir sind Verfechter des freien Marktes, solange wir in diese Regeln bestimmen. Wenn jemand anders einen freien Markt entfordert, nee, dann machen wir Protektionismus. Wir haben diese exorbitanten Exportüberschüsse. Also Deutschland mit 80 Millionen Einwohnern ist Exportweltmeister. Und es beschwert sich dann bei China, dass sie mit 1,4 Milliarden Beschäftigten sind. Exportweltmeister sind natürlicher Stand der Dinge. Wenn man so viele Leute hat, ist man natürlich Exportweltmeister. Warum kam überhaupt Deutschland auf die Idee, das sein zu müssen? Ich finde es sehr gut, dass Patrick hier einfach nach diesem Vorwort von Vlasberg mit dem Verweis auf die ideelle Ordnung, die hier auch von Bedeutung ist, schreibt, dass diese Reformen umgesetzt werden, also die er vorschlägt oder von denen er schreibt, dürfte zwar in der gegenwärtigen Lage nahezu ausgeschlossen sein, das gehört zur bitteren Wahrheit dazu. Und dennoch können solche Ideen als Orientierungspunkt für die Zukunft und zur Einordnung der Politik der Schlafwandler dienen. Also er kommt hier mit einem Optimismus des Willens, beim Pessimismus des Verstandes von Gramsci und so, um sich noch selber zu positionieren. Wenn man sich mit dieser globalen Ökonomie befasst, kommt man nicht umhin, Sachen zu beobachten, bei denen alle sagen, das ist so wahnsinnig, ich kann es nicht ganz glauben, aber man muss sie dann trotzdem ausformulieren. Und ein Buch, einfach nur als hier wirklich zu sagen, okay, ich weiß, das sage ich ja manchmal auch bei der Alten Republik, wenn ich so bei Abendtermin bin, dass ich sage, wir sprechen über Probleme, zu denen es keine Lösung gibt, aber das heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass wir jetzt nicht mal über die Probleme sprechen. Das finde ich schon sehr gut. Also das ist auch ein sehr ehrlicher Umgang mit dem eigenen Text, das jetzt gleich die Revolution allen zu versprechen.
Nee, das wäre ja auch illusorisch, das zu tun, aber wir haben ja in Davos erlebt, wie Friedrich Merz hingemäß sagt, Europa muss sich einnen, muss stärker werden und wir müssen alles für mehr Wettbewerbsfähigkeit tun. Und dass das nicht zusammengeht, sehen wir da schon und das bedeutet das natürlich auch auf globaler Ebene. Dann kann ich sagen, wir wollen die Armut bekämpfen in der Welt oder wir wollen, dass es allen besser geht und sagen dann zugleich, wir müssen wettbewerbsfähiger werden. Also wenn man anfängt, in Bilanzen zu denken und da ist jetzt das mit den Handelsbilanzen eigentlich ganz gut, dann sieht man ja, wenn wir sehr viel exportieren in andere Länder, dann müssen die das ja offenbar uns abkaufen, weil wir das ja nicht dahin verschenken. Das bedeutet aber dann, wenn wir einen Überschuss haben, dann können die anderen ja nicht auch einen Überschuss haben.
Genau, es geht ja nicht auf, denn und das ist ja eins der großen intellektuellen Herausforderungen, die Welt ist begrenzt, irgendwann gibt es nichts mehr zu kaufen und nein, man kann diesen Bereich des Kaufbaren nicht einfach auf junge Mädchen erweitern.
So zur App-Star.
Ja, aber das ist sozusagen, irgendwann ist die Welt einfach.
Aber bleiben wir mal bei den Bilanzen. Er schreibt es ja hier konkret. Während der 2010er Jahre verliefen sich die deutschen Leistungsbilanzüberschüsse im Durchschnitt auf 7,5 Prozent des BIP. Also das heißt, man hat sehr viel exportiert, das musste gekauft werden vom Ausland. Das Ausland, sage ich jetzt gleich noch hinzu, soll aber bitte auch sparsam sein. Also sie sollen es abkaufen und sparsam zugleich sein. Das ist auch interessant. Bei China lagen diese Leistungsbilanzüberschüsse bei 1,9 Prozent. Seit 2007, als der chinesische Überschuss mit 9,8 Prozent einen Rekordwert erreichte, ging er permanent zurück, während Deutschland keine Anstalt machte, etwas gegen die eigenen Überschüsse zu tun. Das heißt, alles, was wir an China kritisieren, müssen wir doppelt an Deutschland diskutieren, es sei denn, und das ist natürlich die nationalistische Denkweise, man sagt, ja, uns steht das aber zu, weil wir Deutsche sind. Dann muss man das aber auch so kommunizieren. Dann muss man aber vielleicht auch gucken, ob man, weiß ich nicht, bei der AfD einen Anklang findet.
Ja, er sagt ja auch, das sind ja immer dieselben Argumente. Es ist ja auch unsere qualitative Arbeit, die wir da exportieren. So, jetzt haben wir natürlich dieses große Durcheinander. Ich habe ja schon diesen einen Punkt kurz herangezogen, wie er das Buch begründet, nämlich zu sagen, okay, das ist ein ganz großes, also ein Buch über ganz große materielle Unschärfen und ich mache einfach einen ideellen Punkt. Ich gebe jemandem die Möglichkeit, mal eine etwas informiertere Rückfrage bei einer Podiumsdiskussion zu stellen oder irgend sowas, ja. So, und jetzt gibt es einen zweiten Punkt, für den habe ich natürlich eine entsprechende Sensorik die letzten Monate entwickelt. Ich bin gespannt, wie du das gelesen hast. Er bezieht sich ja auf sein Christensein.
Ja.
So.
Er ist katholisch.
Genau. Und die Weisoo Jesu, bevor man jemand anderen auf den Splitter im Auge hinweist, könnte man ja erstmal am eigenen Balken im Auge rumdoktern. Finde ich natürlich sehr gut. Vielleicht sollte man wirklich häufiger nicht das Christentum oder sowas, aber so eine Ideenwelt, so einen semantischen Überbau ganz ernst nehmen. Ja. Und den Leuten nicht nur davon sagen, sondern auch ihnen nochmal dazu sagen, dass man das jetzt ganz ernst nimmt.
Ja.
Also, dass man hier jetzt auch verletzt wäre, wenn jetzt jemand mit einer Kritik kommt, die so aus der Hüfte geschossen kommt oder sowas.
Ja, ich finde das sehr richtig. Und beim Katholizismus haben wir es natürlich mit einem universalistischen Modell zu tun. Denn katholisch kann nun jeder sein. Da gibt es eigentlich keine nationalen Grenzen oder irgendetwas. Und wenn wir uns auf diese Lehren beziehen, dann ist das ja auch wiederum ein Denken in Bilanzen. Ja, also du redest vom Splitter. Was ist eigentlich mit dem Balken? Und so findet man eigentlich jemanden, man müsste wirklich sich so ganz in den Kopf reinarbeiten können, dass man alle Zahlen immer präsent hat. Also wenn da jetzt zum Beispiel jemand sitzt auf einem Podium und sagt, naja, also im Jahr 2022, da haben mir die ganzen reichen Staaten ja 211 Milliarden Dollar Entwicklungshilfe gegeben. Reicht das denn nicht mal? Und in dem Moment müsste man die Zahl haben, die jetzt Patrick uns liefert, ja, insgesamt standen aber diese Entwicklungshilfezahlungen, Schuldendienstzahlungen gegenüber, die die Entwicklungsländer leisten mussten. Und die lagen bei 443 Milliarden Dollar.
Also doppelt so hoch.
Ja. Und das müsste man quasi präsent haben, um gleich zu sagen, ja, kannst du gerne sagen, es sind tolle hohe Summen, ja, 200, 11 Jahre ist ganz viel Geld. Aber guck mal, die müssen, die sind so hoch verschuldet bei den ausländischen Kreditgebern, also auch bei uns, in dem sind also bei, beim Westen, bei seinen Institutionen, den Banken, den Investoren oder all das, dass sie mit diesen Entwicklungsgeldern nicht weit kommen können.
Ja, das ist auch sehr interessant. Er hat im Rahmen dieser Diskussion, wie wir das in Deutschland so herausholen, also Deutschland ist, ich sage mal, Radwege in Peru und so. Ja. Kommt auch so ein Hinweis auf diese Relativen im Vergleich zu absoluten Zahlen. Und er redet von der Elefanten und dem Elefantenrücken von Milanovic und dem Hockeyschläger.
Ja.
Also es gibt Leute, die verdienen zwei Euro am Tag und welche, die verdienen 2000 Euro am Tag. Das heißt, wenn man hier einfach das so aufschlüsselt, wie Wachstum stattfindet, also der eine kriegt dann drei Euro am Tag und dann kriegt der andere 3000 am Tag, dann hat man ja, wenn man das nach relativen Gesichtspunkten sieht, ein Elefant im Sinne von die ganz Ärmsten haben jetzt 50 Prozent mehr und die superreichsten auch und die globale Mittelschicht geht so ein bisschen verloren. Also man hat so bei den ganzen Armen so einen Buckel und dann nochmal den Elefantenkopf sozusagen bei denen, die ein bisschen so brech sind. Wenn man jetzt aber in absoluten Zahlen denkt, steht natürlich 1 Euro 1000 Euro gegenüber. Und dann hast du plötzlich einen Hockeyschläger. Der sieht gar nicht mehr aus nach Elefant und gleich und balanciert.
Und bei einem Euro 50 Prozent sind 50 Cent mehr. Oder bekommt man 500 Dollar mehr.
Also in Relation zu denken, zu bilanzieren, der Splitter und der Balken, das ist auch eine große Lehre, die hier in dem Buch drinsteckt, dann hätte man fast noch mal mehr didaktisch und methodisch an die Sache rangehen müssen für Leute, die noch unbedarfter sind, als wir, die jetzt schon vorher Milanovic und so gelesen haben. Wenn man das Buch jetzt wirklich jemandem verschenkt und so, dass man da noch mal das ein oder andere so auf diesem didaktischen Sinne entfaltet.
Ja, auch die Stimmeanteile zum Beispiel im IWF, wie ungleich das verteilt ist, da heißt es, obwohl die Industriestaaten nur 13,7 Prozent der Weltbevölkerung stellen, halten sie 59 Prozent der Stimmrechte, während die USA sogar ein Vetorecht haben. Die übrigen 86,3 Prozent der Weltbevölkerung müssen sich mit 41 Prozent der Stimmrechte begnügen. Also das ist unglaublich. Dann hat man zwar die UNO, aber da sind die Resolutionen der Generalversammlung völkerrechtlich nicht bindend. Und bei der Generalversammlung, da gibt es dann die völkerrechtlich bindenden, aber da gibt es die ständigen Mitglieder. China, Frankreich, Russland, USA, UK. Und die haben aber wiederum ein Vetorecht. Auch interessant, 55 Prozent der Finanzierung der UNO stammt von den Industriestaaten. Klingt ja erstmal gut, generös. Bedeutet aber, wenn die UNO sich nicht entsprechend positioniert, kann auch gleich mit Mittelentzug gedroht werden. Also die sind nicht unabhängig.
Ja, da finden Erpressungen statt. Das ist dafür, dass wir die... Also ich meine, am Ende ist ja immer... Wir haben halt am Anfang auch gesagt, es gibt eine Nachkriegsordnung, die ist irgendwie dominant. Ja. So UN und wir finden sie alle gut und wichtig. Also wird auch mal wieder betont. Egal welcher deutsche Außenminister, wird immer betont, wie wichtig. Aber dass natürlich einfach im Abstimmungsverhalten Erpressungen stattfinden. Wie er hier schreibt, es findet ja... Das ist einfach die Dirty Work. Es gibt so eine Hypothese entwickelt von... Er nennt den Namen die Dirty Work Hypothese von Alex Dreher, der damals Forschung dazu gemacht hat, historische Forschung im Abstimmungsverhalten. Und da konnte man einfach sehen, wie Drecksarbeit über diese Gremienarbeit gemacht wird, indem gesagt wird, naja, wir Amerikaner feiern jetzt nicht mit Militär. Also machen wir auch, aber nicht immer. Manchmal machen wir es auch über die EDL-Schiene. Dann wird einfach eine Resolution geschrieben. Dann werden die Mitglieder der Räte erpresst und dann hat man eine Mehrheit für, ja, ja, also hier muss jetzt mal und so weiter. Und dann sind irgendwelche Leute unter Länder unter der Knute von UN-Resolutionen einfach nur, weil über Bande Drecksarbeit der Siegermächte gemacht wurde.
Ja.
Und dann ergeht ja die Länder dann so durch, ne, also hier Bangladesch und so, die typischen Opfer.
Auch interessant ist, dass die UNO, Organisation für Welthandel und Entwicklung in Deutschland, immer ihren Report vorstellte, Trade and Development, aber in den frühen 2000er Jahren, und das ist der Report eigentlich, in dem alles drinsteht, in den 2000er hat man beschlossen, wir stellen das ein, wir reporten den nicht mehr in Deutschland, stellen den nicht mehr in der Pressekonferenz vor. Denn es war so, dass in diesen Pressekonferenzen häufig nur ein einziger Journalist sich noch hin verirrt hat. Das heißt, wir erfahren da wirklich was über Weltwirtschaft und den Zustand von Ungleichheit von den Ländern, wie sie entwickelt sind und man sagt, boah, interessiert mich gar nicht. Da geht keiner hin. Man hat also noch nicht mal mehr eine Pressekonferenz dafür. Zugleich muss man hier auch wieder, es sind so viele Zahlen, es ist so interessant, weil wir die ganze Zeit diese Debatten haben um Bürokratieabbau. Dann erfahren wir hier in dem Buch, also es gibt bilaterale Investitionsabkommen en masse, 2800 Investitionsabkommen. Kann man sich vorstellen, wie er soll durch dieses.
Ja, da werden natürlich Rechtstexte geschrieben, die dann einfach nur noch durchgesetzt werden müssen, weil wir sind ja alle rechtsstaatlich. Ja, das ist ja ganz wichtig, dass wir die Rechtsstaatlichkeit hochhalten, dass da keiner, wie Döpfner sagt, Rumpf vorwirkt in der Rechtsstaatlichkeit.
Ja, kommen wir mal zu dem Kapitel ein bisschen ausführlicher. Du hast es jetzt schon angesprochen mit Pranko Milanovic zur globalen Armut, denn das ist ja wichtig, um das einzuordnen. Wo stehen wir da? Erstmal kann man sagen, der Kapitalismus hat die Leute doch reicher gemacht, wohlhabender, es geht ihnen besser. Und tatsächlich haben wir Rekorde weniger Kindersterblichkeit, weniger Analphabetismus. Das pro Kopf Einkommen liegt weltweit im Schnitt bei über 13.100 Dollar und ist damit auch so hoch wie nie. Man kann aber auch sagen, es gibt extremen Hunger. Ja, alle fünf Sekunden stirbt ein Kind im Alter von unter zehn Jahren. Ein Drittel der Menschheit leidet unter Ernährungsunsicherheit. Es ist also nicht klar, ob sie morgen genügend zu essen haben. Man kann es aber mal durchrechnen, wie viel ist eigentlich da und wie viel Nahrung wird produziert. Dann kann man schon mal festhalten, man könnte, stand jetzt, zwölf Milliarden Menschen ernähren. Also erheblich mehr, als auf diesem Planeten sind. Und diese Einkommenszuwächse, die da immer so beschrieben werden in Prozenten, du hast das jetzt schon hingewiesen, was Branko Milanovic da uns zeigt, das ist eben das Interessante. Also es wird übrigens immer, weil manche vielleicht denken, ja, warum rechnen die jetzt alles so mit Dollar, wie geht das? Also es gibt den Kaufkraftparitäts-Dollar, mit dem ist das quasi alles bereinigt, die Unterschiede, weil natürlich hier der Dollar, den ich jetzt in Frankfurt ausgeben kann und der Dollar, den ich in einem ostafrikanischen Land ausgeben kann, ja eigentlich anders gewertet werden muss. Und man versucht das dann damit zu bereinigen. Jedenfalls sehen wir, ja, es gibt natürlich bei den ganz Armen diesen enormen prozentualen Anstieg, dass die ihr Einkommen verdoppeln oder verdreifachen konnten. Das meint aber dann irgendwie, statt 1,70, 3,40 zu verdienen. Und bei den Reichen sprechen wir über davon, wenn die ihr Einkommen verdoppeln oder nur 10% oder 5% mehr haben, dass sie direkt mehrere tausend Geld haben. Das bedeutet also, man muss über die absoluten Einkommenszuwächse sprechen und schaut man sich da dann die Entwicklung an von 1988 bis 2018, dann sehen wir eben bei den unteren 40% einen kaum wahrnehmbaren Anstieg. Der ist sehr, sehr, sehr gering und dann gibt es die Mittelklasse, geht das so ein bisschen nach oben, zum Teil geht es ja aber auch, bleibt es dann unten stagnierend, das ist ja auch was, worüber Milanowitsch dann spricht, so eine westliche Mittelklasse, wo das dann in stagnieren kommt. Und dann gibt es so die oberen 96 bis 99 beziehungsweise das oberste Prozent. Da geht es dann, katapultiert es sich nach oben, auch bei den absoluten Einkommenszuwächsen, was wir dann ja auch gut beschrieben bekommen haben von Markowitz in The Meritocracy Trial.
Also ich finde die These, dass ohne China kaum Fortschritt zu verzeichnen ist, kennt man ja so weit. Aber das fand ich in Zahlen auch. Also 10 Prozent der Leute verdienen mehr als 13 Dollar am Tag und der Wert hat sich über 40 Jahre eigentlich nicht geändert. Du hast jetzt die 1918er angesprochen. Und 60 Prozent immer noch unter 5 Dollar 50. Also mehr als die Hälfte der Welt lebt am Tag von 5 Dollar 50 und mehr als 40 Prozent weniger als 3 Dollar 20.
Also das globale Medianeinkommen, Jahreseinkommen liegt bei 3600 Dollar.
Das sind die erschränkenden Zahlen.
Also es ist die höchste Dichte an Menschen hat man bei 700 Dollar im Jahr. Der Anteil der Armen ist von 37 auf 8,5 Prozent gesunken. Da muss man aber auch mal sagen, wie wird dieser Schnittarmut da gerechnet. Da reden wir wirklich immer von so Anstiegen von statt 1,95 sind jetzt 2,20 werden verdient. Dann ist man nicht mehr in der Statistik drin. Oder 2,30. 1990 waren 800 Millionen Menschen unter der Armutsgrenze. Heute sind es tatsächlich nur noch 1 bis 2 Millionen Menschen in China. Das bedeutet also, 800 Millionen Menschen waren in China 1990 unter der Armutsgrenze. China hat Protektionismus gemacht, hat Industriepolitik gemacht, Subventionen und und und, hat sich auch den Märkten geöffnet, hat versucht, Exportnation zu werden. Noch lange nicht so weit wie Deutschland. Hat aber Wirkliches geschafft, von 1990 bis heute, diese 800 Millionen Arme nach oben zu heben, dass sie nicht mehr unter die Grenze fallen. Also sind da noch 1 bis 2 Millionen Menschen, ist ja auch wahnsinnig viel, aber 1 bis 2 Millionen Menschen, sind also noch unter dieser Armutsgrenze in China. Das heißt also, durch die chinesische Politik wurden 800 Millionen Menschen besser gestellt. Wenn wir jetzt aber da hören von Dr. Dr. Dr. Rainer Zittlmann und anderen, dass der Kapitalismus eine Erfolgsgeschichte sei, weil 800 Millionen Menschen weniger arm sind in den letzten 30 Jahren, dann können wir sagen, ja, wegen China. Und es ist wirklich sehr maßgeblich, China und Umgebung, also auch andere asiatische Länder, haben einen enormen Fortschritt gemacht. Nicht alle, aber doch einige. Wenn man sich aber zum Beispiel das östliche und südliche Afrika ansieht, dann gab es in den vergangenen 35 Jahren so gut wie keine Veränderung. Also da sind wir schon auf dem allerniedrigsten Niveau.
Genau, was ja bedeutet, hier muss man ja eigentlich auch noch mal ein großes Bild der Lebenslüge sozusagen zusammenbauen. Denn China kommt ja immer wieder in Diskurs vor. So wie du es jetzt beschrieben hast, dass man sagt, okay, dank China ist das passiert. Ja, aber China hat es eben gegen unsere Ordnungsdiktate durchgesetzt.
Ja.
Das heißt, unsere Ordnungsdiktate hätten eigentlich bedeutet, alle bleiben arm. Jetzt wiederum haben wir diesen Zustand, das beschreibt er ja oben im Buch, dass wir wieder ökonomisch von Kooperation umstellen auf, wie er schreibt, harte Bandagen und Faustkampf, dass so ein Sozialdaminismus einzieht. Das haben wir ja in Davos gesehen. Ja. Dass jetzt diese Weltordnung, die also die letzten 40 Jahre eigentlich den Hunger zermentiert hat, China ist dann ausgebrochen und hat sozusagen die Statistik geschönt für uns mit, dass wir jetzt sagen, wir müssen jetzt umso mehr noch mal diese Weltordnung, die einfach 80 Prozent der Welt in Trümmern zurücklässt, einbetonieren, weil China, weil die ja gerade so Entwicklungssprünge machen, und wir jetzt nicht zulassen können, dass die jetzt die KI, da muss man auch mal fünf grade sein lassen, wenn Scale AI in Bangladesch die Leute die Daten sortieren lässt. Und das Lieferkettengesetz geht ja gar nicht. Wir sind im Grunde alle in dieser Situation, in der Ludnik in Davos sagt, wir Milliardäre wurden von der Globalisierung verraten.
Ja, ja, ja. Das ist absolut so. Ich mein, man liest es dann ja auch, zum Beispiel in der Financial Times, wenn dort Edward Lewis, der wird zitiert, sagt, dass Joe Biden einen ausgewachsenen Wirtschaftskrieg gegen China begonnen hat und sich damit nahezu verpflichtet, den Aufstieg Chinas zu stoppen. Das ist die Idee von Biden und von Trump natürlich auch. Die große Zusammenarbeit zwischen China und den USA hat ja stattgefunden durch Nixon und vor allem Kissinger im Hintergrund, der die Idee hatte, wir brauchen ein Bollwerk gegen die UDSSR. China und die Sowjetunion haben sich eh schon nicht mehr gut verstanden. Das war so ein sehr guter Zeitpunkt zu sagen, passt auf, wir öffnen uns, ihr öffnet euch für uns. Und dann hat man etwas gegen die UDSSR. Dabei hat aber dann man auch gesehen, wie China sich ja diesem Wachstumsfahrt verschrieben hat, was ja dann auch für Deng Xiaoping so wichtig war, dass er ja diese große Tournee durchs Land gemacht hat und wirklich wo andere bremsen wollten in seinem eigenen Land und sagten ja nicht zu viel, zu schnell ist Wachstum. Wo er sagte, nein, jetzt müssen wir radikal wachsen und das auch so durchsetzen, wie wir uns das gedacht haben, sodass dann dieser enorme Aufstieg entsteht wo ja dann die Frage ganz einfach ist, wie sähe die Welt ohne China aus und die beantwortet dann Patrick auch mit Ökonomen, nämlich da heißt es die Ökonomen Andy Summer und Eduardo Ortiz Juarez stellten dazu 2021 für die Vereinten Nationen einen Bericht vor, der die Zahlen nüchtern auf den Tisch legt. Zwischen 1990 und 2019 ist die Zahl der Menschen, die mit weniger als einem Dollar neunzig pro Tag auskommen mussten, ohne China lediglich von 1,1 Milliarden auf 680 Millionen zurückgegangen, was einem Rückgang von 28 Prozent auf 11 Prozent der Weltbevölkerung exklusive China entspricht. Nehmen wir drei weitere asiatische Länder aus der Rechnung heraus, Indien, Indonesien und Vietnam, dann fallen die Fortschritte bei der Bekämpfung der Anzahl der Menschen in extremer Armut gegen null. Von 550 Millionen Menschen blieben 530 Millionen Menschen unter der Schwelle von 1,90 Dollar pro Tag. Insbesondere in Afrika südlich der Sahara, Lateinamerika und einiger Teile Südasiens blieben Fortschritte bei der Verbesserung des Lebensstandards der Menschen aus.
Vier Länder mit besonderem Schwerpunkt auf China sind somit für das Wunder der Armutsbekämpfung verantwortlich.
Und nicht nur bekämpfen wir die Armuts, sondern sie haben auch ein anderes Verhältnis zum Klimawandel. Also in China ist ja noch völlig gängig, dass man dort ganz vogue, also es ist erklärungsbedürftig, warum man jetzt nochmal Benzin verbrennt, wenn man eine neue Fabrik baut und so. Wo man doch einfach die billigen Salaarpaneele bauen müsse. Und da verbindet jetzt Patrick diese beiden Punkte. Im Protektionismus Kapitel ist das, glaube ich. Oder?
Warte. Denke schon. Genau.
Wo er dann schreibt, dass die Klimaneutralität allein über bessere Rabenbedingungen erreicht werden kann, glauben nur noch ein paar versprengte Ordo-Liberale und Marktfundamentalisten, die jedoch in Europa und in Deutschland den Ton angeben. In dieser Hinsicht könnte man von China in den Bereichen, in denen die dortige Wirtschaftspolitik einiges richtig macht, durchaus was lernen. Ich hatte ja mal kurz dieses Buch von Ash Sarker angesprochen, Minority Rule. Also, dass wir alle von so einer eigentlichen Minderheit regiert werden, während uns immer Demokratie versprochen wird. Und das ist natürlich hier auch wieder. Und zwar sowohl in China als auch in Deutschland. In China wird den Leuten einfach die erneuerbare Energie oktruiert. Also, man kriegt irgendwo Land zugesprochen und dann heißt es ja hier, das ist vielleicht die Abundance Solaranlage dazu und so weiter. Das wird alles im Package verkauft. Die wollen ja einfach, dass Leute niemals sagen, oh man, ich habe zu wenig Energie, sondern alle sollen Energie haben. Und dann Harald Lesch hat wohl jetzt auch wieder einen Vortrag gehalten, wo er noch mal gegenüberstellt, wie China einfach in einem Jahr so viel erneuerbare Energie zu baut, wie Deutschland in immer. Ja. Das ist ja völlig verrückt.
Und noch nach Pakistan exportiert.
Und genau, sowas kommt dann noch dazu, wenn die geografische Lage günstig ist. So und jetzt haben wir in Deutschland natürlich auch eine Minority Rule nur genau umgedreht. Während sehr viele Unternehmen hier gar keine Chance bekommen, obwohl die Interpreneure, die wir immer abfeiern wollen, einfach sehen, wie Energie jetzt gemacht werden muss, kommt einfach die Reiche und sagt, wir bauen natürlich jetzt hier so Gaskraftwerke, weil wir brauchen ja eine Grundlast und so weiter. Es kommen die ganzen Ideen von vor 30 Jahren. Die Dunkelflaute, was ist im Winter und so weiter, der ganze Scheißer. Und nur die Chinesen machen es halt konstruktiv, während wir ja rumklammern an diesem Verbrenner und so weiter, als gäbe es keine Realität, die dann mal über uns hereinbricht. Und das finde ich besorgniserregend, ehrlich gesagt. Denn am Ende möchte ich ja schon zu den Top 10 Prozent der Welt weitergehören. Also ich fände es ja auch nicht so gut, wenn wir jetzt plötzlich afrikanische Verhältnisse hier haben. Nur offenbar sind unsere Minorities, die hier ruhen, so entkoppelt vom Lauf der Dinge, dass sie das einfach Aufopferung der kleinen Schritte, die dann gemacht werden müssen, im Großen und Ganzen geben, sie das komplette Bild verloren.
Naja, es ist ein reinstes Rückzugsgeflecht.
Er ist totaler Wahnsinn eigentlich.
Also es ist ja vollkommen klar, Porsche hat ja gerade das auch offen bekannt, dass immer weniger Porsche in China gefahren wird. Und Porsche ist eigentlich schon global für eine gutverdienende Elite. Da sind wir noch nicht bei den Superreichen. Ja, die kaufen noch mal andere Autos, aber für die gutverdienende Elite, auch für PMCs vielleicht oder so, das Auto, mit dem man zeigen kann, ich habe es geschafft. Das kauft man, wenn man zwei Kinder schon jetzt ins Studium gebracht hat. Und dann kann man sagen, jetzt kauft Fatih sich einen Porsche. Und dieses Auto ist in China nicht mehr gefragt. Das geht radikal zurück und man stellt sich darauf ein, dass das immer weniger werden wird. Was wir jetzt erleben, das nur als ein Beispiel, ist ein Rückzugsgefecht der deutschen Politik, dass man sagt, wie können wir dann die heimischen Märkte und alles, was so nah dran ist, also Europa, noch weiterhin mit unserem Kram bestücken? Und das geht ja nur so, indem man den Fortschritt auf der anderen Seite aufhält. Also indem man jetzt gerade nicht viel verbessert für E-Mobilität oder so, sondern dass man lange dabei bleibt und Diskussionen vermeidet darüber, wer soll eigentlich diese Autos dann noch fahren und kaufen. Also du weißt ja, was das Schlimmste wäre für die deutsche Autoindustrie. Das wäre die Prüfung ab 70 Jahren, alle zwei Jahre, ob man noch den Führerschein behalten darf. Das wäre der absolute Super-Gauer. Also wann immer diese Diskussion aufkommt, wir können über alles inhaltlich diskutieren, aber der Grund, warum es das nicht gibt, die letzten, die noch Geld haben, dürfen nicht mehr Auto fahren, das wäre das. Das ist der einzige Grund, warum man sowas niemals einführen wird, weil das wirklich die Hölle wäre. Und das ist die Idee, dass man eben jetzt versucht, mit dem zu handeln, was noch da ist, und versucht, da weiter die Preisschraube nach oben zu drehen. Es ist ja absurd, wie teuer diese angebliche Mittelklasse Wagen sind. Die Mittelklasse Wagen sind für die oberen, ich will schon fast nicht mehr sagen 10 Prozent, sondern für die oberen 5 Prozent gemacht. Von Mittelklasse kann da nicht die Rede sein. Die Mittelklasse kauft nicht für 80.000 Euro ein Auto. Es sei dann, man hat solche tollen Abschreibungsmodelle über die Firma, was ja auch schon zeigt, wie verrückt das System ist.
Das sagst du jetzt so nebenbei, das wollte ich mich gerade sagen. In Amerika heißt es ja immer, ja, da läuft die Krankenversicherung, also ein essenzieller Teil, den man braucht in seinem Leben, nur über den Arbeitgeber. Das ist in Deutschland mit dem Auto so. Nur wir diskutieren das halt nie so. Nur völlig verblödete Boomer-Ehrenmänner sagen noch, ich spare 7 Jahre und bezahle dann mein Audi irgendwas Cash. Und damit ist er der einzige Kunde in der ganzen Stadt in den letzten 10 Jahren. Alle anderen kommen natürlich mit ihren ganzen Finanzvehikels über den Arbeitgeber und so weiter. Nur ich habe ja gar kein Auto.
Also das ist ja auch eine Subvention, ne?
Ja, ich habe ja gar kein Auto. Ich will was aus dem Alltag schildern. Es ist mir jetzt wieder auf, also weil es gerade diese Woche betrifft. Ich habe einmal die Woche mit meinem Sohn eine Uber-Fahrt, weil wir einfach abends, er muss ins Bett und so. Und dann Öffis würde eine Dreiviertelstunde dauern, Uber halt 15 Minuten, ne? Und jedes Mal ist so, mal gucken, was kommt. Denn er fährt sehr gerne E-Klasse, weil die hinten diese farblichen Leuchten drin haben.
Weil es was Gutes ist, ja.
Genau, so. Nur, und das ist ja, das muss man sich jetzt, also du hattest von den 70-Jährigen, die dann ab und zu mal eine Uber fahren, oder wenn du auf Reisen bist, du hast dein Auto nicht bei dir, du fährst dann Uber und so, ne? Ja, klar. So, als Oberfahrer, Mitfahrer, Beifahrer, bin ich natürlich dem Strukturwandel, Mobilität extrem unterworfen. Also zu 80 Prozent, sag ich mal grob, kommt ein Toyota Corolla als einfach Arbeitstier.
Das kenne ich auch so.
Der kommt dann so langsam angesurrt mit seinem elektronischen, ich verbrenne grad nichts, sondern ich habe hier und so weiter. Und zwar war das ganz schön, aber man sitzt da drin und denkt, ja, wir werden grad nach Hause fahren. Hier ist grad nichts mit bunten Lichtern und so weiter. Wir sitzen halt drin und...
Dann musst du vielleicht für den Sohn immer ein Uber Premium buchen.
Ja, da bin ich sozusagen für die Unterhaltung zuständig während der Fahrt. Diese Woche kam so ein BYD-Ding und manchmal, ich saß ja auch schon in so einem IE von Neo oder so, wo wir den Fahrer noch fragen, weil es wäre unmöglich gewesen, in das Auto einzusteigen und nicht sofort zu fragen, wie viel PS haben wir hier so umgerechnet und er sofort 700 und so sagt. Also sowas kommt ja auch vor. Das heißt, über diese Uber hat unglaubliches Beförderungsdemand Nachfrage, die sie so in den Markt rein organisieren. Und die Autohersteller sehen das natürlich genau und wollen da partizipieren. Und meine Vermutung ist ja schon eine Weile, dass das die Einflugsschneise für die Chinesen ist. Die Uber-Flotten fit zu machen, weil hört man ja an mir, man steigt nicht nach 15 Minuten aus dem BYD aus und erzählt nicht zehn Leuten davon, was das für eine Fahrt war. Das ist einfach genial.
Das ist die beste Werbung, die es gibt.
Ja, ich steige in, von denen ich weiß, 120.000 Euro Audis und ich denke mir, was für ein Schrotthaufen. Ich habe hier keinen Platz. Ich kann das nicht. Ich sitze vorne in extrem großen SUVs und ich habe keinen Platz für meine Beine. Das würde mir in einem chinesischen BYD oder in so einem Neoding niemals passieren. Das ist einfach völlig ausgeschlossen. Da wird ewig viel mit Polstern hier. Dann wölbt sich in so einem deutschen Auto noch. Der sitzt unten um meine Lenden und lauter so ein Blödsinn und drückt so dagegen, wenn ich um die Kurve fahre. Das ist einfach Komfort für 100-Jährige. Das brauche ich alles nicht. Ich will da einsteigen, es soll leuchten, riesiger Bildschirm, alles und so weiter. Mein Sohn soll beeindruckt sein. Das Thema der Fahrt ist klar. Das ist ein krasses Auto und so. Von daher, ich weiß, auch bei dem KI-Ding und so, das läuft alles in Monaten, jetzt diese Entwicklung. Die Autoindustrie, ich weiß nicht, das macht mir wirklich Angst. Ich steige aus dem Auto aus und mir schlottern Friedrich Merz Knie.
Ich glaube, jetzt eine Antwort darauf, die ja auch so sein muss, dass man darüber nachdenkt, wie sieht das denn eigentlich mit der Arbeiterschaft in Deutschland aus. Es müsste eigentlich sein, man müsste mehr auf die Kooperation gehen und sagen, ja, dann sollte man wahrscheinlich dafür sorgen, dass nicht nur Tesla da irgendwo in Brandenburg produziert, sondern man müsste eigentlich sehen, bekommt man Teile der Produktion nach Deutschland, weil ja Know-how auch da ist. Von daher müsste man eigentlich da langfristige Kooperation eingehen, was auch dazu führen würde, dass man dadurch vielleicht wieder eine bessere, ja, ich will nicht sagen Freundschaft, weil das immer unsinnig ist, aber eine bessere Partnerschaft dann unter den Ländern hinbekommt. Und damit wäre allen geholfen. Aber da gibt es jetzt so viele Partikularinteressen, die jetzt wirklich noch glauben, wir können die chinesische Automobilität aufhalten. Und da brauchen wir nur so ein paar Barrieren hochziehen und dann ist gut. Das wird in dem Sinne nicht passieren, zumal auch die Sachen ja nicht mehr abgenommen werden dann im Ausland. Also dass Porsche nicht mehr sich verkauft, das ist ja auch eigentlich der Wahnsinn.
Also ich würde auch den Bundestag mal empfehlen, das ganze Budget für, die haben ihre eigene Flotte. Die fahren ja nur mit deutschen Autos und so. Ja, klar. Einfach mal einen Monat gezielt Uber Premium fahren in Berlin und dann mal die Autos erleben.
Ja, obwohl da in Berlin komme ich noch sehr häufig so Teslas an.
Also hier in Frankfurt ist eine Einflugschneise für die Chinesen irgendwie. Also ich profitiere natürlich davon, aber ich mache mir natürlich auch Gedanken. Deswegen, ja, da ist einiges in Bewegung.
Entwicklungshilfe, auch da mal kurz. Wir haben ja auch ein Ziel bei der Entwicklungshilfe. Es gibt das 2% Ziel bei der NATO. Inzwischen wissen wir von Friedrich Merz, es ist das 5% Ziel geworden. Also 500 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr sollen ausgegeben werden für das Militär. Es gibt aber auch ein 0,7% Ziel bei der Entwicklungshilfe. Da kann man aber sagen, das erreicht Deutschland auch eigentlich nie, bis auf einmal. Das heißt, die allermeisten DAC-Staaten haben dieses Ziel nie erreicht. Lediglich 15 Staaten haben es geschafft, die Zielmarke von 0,7% mindestens einmal zu überschreiten. Deutschland darf sich zu diesem Kreis zählen dank eines Sondereffekts. 2016, also mit 40-jähriger Verspätung, gab Deutschland zum ersten Mal mehr als 0,7% des Protonationaleinkommens für die Entwicklungshilfe aus. So, jetzt fragen wir uns, was war 2016? Wo haben wir da irgendwo in welchem Teil der Welt geholfen? Na ja, nicht so ganz. Dies war ausschließlich auf die Versorgung von Flüchtlingen innerhalb Deutschland zurückzuführen, die sich während der ersten 12 Monate auf die Entwicklungshilfe anrechnen lässt. Also das hat man auch, das war mir auch nicht klar, dass man also, wenn man hier Menschen hat, um die man sich kümmert, dass man sich da die ersten 12 Monate anrechnen lassen kann auf die Entwicklungshilfe. Dass man also sagt, die Entwicklungshilfe machen wir jetzt auch gerade hier, das muss dann schon mal nicht mehr ins Ausland fließen. Und dadurch kam das eben zustande, da ist noch an der Stelle, sehen wir bereits, dass das Bild der Entwicklungshilfe als freiwillige Wohltaten im Rest der Welt erste Risse erhält bei den Ausgaben für Geflüchtete, fließt nämlich kein Cent von den Ländern des globalen Nordens in den Süden, sondern die Ausgaben für Lebensmittel, Miete und so weiter, kommen dem hiesigen Privatsektor wie Hotelketten und Supermärkten zugute. Das heißt, die Entwicklungshilfe, die man da ausgegeben hat, die ging an deutsche Vermieter, Supermärkte und so weiter. Das war nicht eine Förderung für die Welt.
Also die Diskussion darum, ob man die inländischen, aber sind ja für die Flüchtlinge und so, das war ja damals also so in den typischen Robin Alexander. Ich bringe mal ein Detail rein so, wo das immer mal thematisiert, gerade auch, weil es dann so in die Programme reingerutscht ist, dass man sich das da so schön rechnet im Wahlprogramm. Also Entwicklungshilfe ist ja das, was als Finanzstrom über diese Institution, die wir jetzt genannt haben, abgewickelt wird. Weiter oben hat er noch mal eine Auflistung, da wollte ich dich mal fragen. Also, ich kenne Bricks.
Ja.
G77 plus China habe ich noch nie gehört.
Nee, ich auch nicht.
Die Asiatische Infrastruktur Investment Bank, AIIB, von der habe ich schon gehört, aber ich weiß, dass die sozusagen das chinesische Pandan, wo man ja auch dann schon die Truppen zusammensammelt und so, das ist also institutionell schon sehr gefestigt, aber noch nicht so bedeutsam. Community of Latin American and Caribbean States, CELAC. Habt ihr nie gehört?
Nein, ordentlich.
Afrikanische Union kennen wir natürlich. Jetzt habe ich mich gefragt, diese Institutionen sind ja schon mal gegründet.
Ja.
Ihnen fehlt nur noch ein bisschen Feuerkraft, die Schmiermittel Dollar und so. Also die Institutionen sind da, aber der Dollar als die Leitwährung, das fehlt da noch so ein bisschen. Also da haben die keinen Zugriff drauf, sag uns mal so. Und die Frage ist ja eigentlich, was fehlt in diesen Organisationen noch, um wirkmächtig zu werden? Und die Antwort lautet natürlich, naja, dass Amerika rausfällt aus dem Bild. Also das, was wir jetzt gerade sehen. Dieser Abbau Amerikas, also ich weiß, der Dollar und so weiter.
Das sagt ja Patrick dann auch, dass das eigentlich auf Jahrzehnten nicht so sein wird.
Ich hätte dir vor zwei Wochen noch nicht gesagt, was Claude Cote und Co. für Arbeit abnimmt. Also in deren Sicht jetzt steht alles im Wandel.
Also ich glaube sehr, dass alles im Wandel steht, nur da, wo das verfestigt ist. Also die Frage ist ja, gibt es ein Alternativwährungssystem, das eine solche Sicherheit verspricht wie der Dollar? Könnte man sich davon lösen oder sagt man, man agiert in beiden Systemen oder wird man dann eben gemaßregelt? Also er bringt ja dieses Beispiel, ganz simpel, Simbabwe. In den 90er Jahren haben die einen Sitz im UN-Sicherheitsrat und dann haben die sich entschieden, eine einzige Resolution der USA gegen den Irak nicht zu unterstützen. Daraufhin hat man dem Land gedroht, dass die gefürchtete Konditionalität bei der Auszahlung der nächsten Transchen der IWF-Kredite, also wir sind plötzlich gar nicht mehr beim Sicherheitsrat, sondern plötzlich beim IWF, also beim Internationalen Währungsfonds, zu verschärfen. Das heißt, die bekommen dann Zahlungsschwierigkeiten, weil im IWF man Leute sitzen hat, seitens der USA, wo man sagen kann, mit Simbabwe jetzt ein bisschen robuster vorgehen. Daraufhin hat Simbabwe gleich gesagt, ah nee, dann lassen wir das, dann stimmen wir nicht dagegen. Und solange man natürlich diese Finanzmacht hat, also sagen kann, ja dann bist du über beide Ohren überschuldet und wir erhöhen dir noch die Zinsen oder was auch immer, können die sich in dem Sinne nicht emanzipieren.
Richtig, ich sehe nur Veränderungen. Also zum einen die Marginalisierung der UN, also dass eine Resolution nicht mehr ganz so wichtig ist. Was sich Simbapfe ja hier wünscht, dass nicht alles davon abhängt, wie man in New York abstimmt und so. Diese Marginalisierung wird ja nicht von Simbapfe vorangetrieben, sondern vor allem von Amerika selbst, von Deutschland, dass man da einfach gar nicht mehr hinfährt und es nicht wichtig ist und so weiter. So da findet also schon eine Abschwächung dieser Institutionalisierung statt. Das Zweite ist beim US-Dollar. Also ja, jetzt gerade haben wir es, die Zahlen, die Erje nennt von 2025. Der US-Dollar ist an 89 Prozent der Transaktion auf den Divisenmärkten der Welt beteiligt und macht 56 Prozent alle Divisenreserven der Zentralbanken aus. Selbst in Europa wird noch ein Viertel des Handels mit US-Dollar abgewickelt. Das hat natürlich sehr viel damit mit dieser institutionellen Verflechtung zu tun. Weil Amerika überall beteiligt ist, wird der komplette Zahlungsverkehr auf Dollar gemacht. Statt zu sagen, wenn es die Commerzbank der Deutschen Bank Geld überweist, machen wir das einen Euro. Und danach rechnen wir es aber um einen Dollar um zur City Group oder so. Dann sagen die natürlich, na, bleiben wir einfach an einem Dollar. Also das sieht vielleicht auch viel mächtiger aus, als es wirklich ist. Falls diese Stränge da mal abreißen. Und Trump tut ja sehr viel dafür. Aus vielen internationalen Abkommen, der da jetzt Amerika ausgenommen hat.
Dann müssten aber wirklich die Mittelmächte und dann müsste vor allem auch Europa mit einem starken Euro dafür sorgen, dass dort ein sicherer Hafen geschaffen wird. Und man sagt, ihr bekommt von uns schon mal einen Schuldenschnitt und ihr könnt euch hier verschulden, ohne dass ihr diesen Auflagen, diesen strengen Folge leisten müsst. Und das passiert aber dann ja in der Regel nicht.
Ja, doch. Also wir haben ja einen großen Zug zum digitalen Euro, der ja dann wirklich bedeutet, ein eigenes Zahlungsverkehr, also ein eigenes Zwift, unabhängiges und so weiter und so fort.
Ja, ja. Es gibt keine Bestrebungen seitens der EU, das auszuweiten, also ein solches Regime für Entwicklungsländer.
Ach so, ja gut.
Also die stehen ja, erbringt ja dieses Beispiel dann, die FED macht eine Zinswende, die Zinsen gehen nach oben. So, das bedeutet, es gibt eine Kapitalflucht aus den Entwicklungsländern, weil man da plötzlich Zinsen bekommt bei der FED. Dann sagt man ja, warum denn nicht, US-Staatsanleihen super. Das heißt, der US-Dollar wird gestärkt. Bedeutet aber, aus den Entwicklungsländern wird Geld abgezogen und die Auslandsschulden, die wachsen dann ins Unermessliche, weil die plötzlich viel höhere Zinsen zahlen müssen. Und solange da nicht jemand eintreten kann, also in Form der EU und sagen könnte, so ab sofort könnt ihr euch hier verschulden und ihr werdet nicht, wenn wir eine Zinserhöhung machen, wird das nicht an euch in der Weise weitergeben, dann wäre das das eine. Nur wir sehen ja schon gerade auf der europäischen Ebene, dass es nicht gemacht wird, sondern dass man einfach die Zinsen erhöht. Christine Lagarde sagte, ich weiß noch gar nicht so genau, wie wir Inflationen neuerdings berechnen sollten. Und dann sehen wir ja, wie wir alle unter den Höhen hohen Zinsen leisten. Weil man dann plötzlich sieht, ach so ich soll ein Haus finanzieren mit vier Prozent Zinsen. Wie soll denn das gehen?
Aber vielleicht lohnt es sich von Leuten, die sich auskennen, also Patrick oder andere auch noch mal so ein, weil mich interessiert das zum Beispiel so ein pragmatischer Themenstrange.
Ja.
Also Europa wird von Putin belästigt und er beginnt dann wirklich einen Krieg in der Ukraine. Das bedeutet, Amerika ist an unserer Seite, es finden Militärhilfen statt, es werden in Dollarbeträgen Waffen gekauft, die werden darüber geschickt. Dann heißt es plötzlich, Amerika steht doch nicht mehr so an unserer Seite und die Europäer nehmen aufgrund der Erfahrung in Corona, diese Idee, und es ist jetzt wieder so gemacht worden, zu sagen, ja dann verschuldet sich jetzt die Europäische Kommission selbst, um Mittel zur Verfügung zu stellen. Das ist ja schon mal eine Geldquelle. Abseits muss es nicht des Euros, des Dollars sein, aber abseits amerikanischer Beteiligung. So hat man ja auch bei Corona, wir haben ja dieses Buch von Adam Tews gelesen, über die Ad-hoc-Aktion der FED, wie man einfach innerhalb von neun Wochen oder so, und die Leute sitzen alle im Homeoffice zu Hause, aber sie organisieren ein 16-Billionen-Dollar-Transfersystem, um die Welt von Corona, also da einfach Geld zur Verfügung zu stellen. So, und aus diesen Krisen wird ja gelernt. Also das ist ja, wenn das jetzt wieder passieren würde, würde ja die Europäische Zentralbank nicht wieder einfach daneben stehen, sondern auf zumindest die Zuschauer-Erfahrung zurückgreifen. Die Amerikaner haben gemacht, es geht. So wie die Amerikaner damals dieses Quantitive Easing einfach gemacht haben, als es hieß, ja wir gehen jetzt das Oval Office rein und sagen, also entweder stellt das Amerika so viel Geld zur Verfügung oder alles ist pleite. Und dann sagt Obama, ja was muss ich machen? Ja hier unterschreiben, fertig. So ja und plötzlich hat die FED da so die Möglichkeit, die Zentral-, also die, die vom Markt weg die Staatsanleihen wieder aufzukaufen und so. Und das sind ja alles Erfahrungen, die ja in Europa dann nachvollzogen werden. Also Staatsanleihenaufkauf ist ja nun Gang und Gebe, ist ja Alltag. Hier so ein Drittel aller Schulden liegen einfach bei der EZB im Keller und keiner interessiert sich eigentlich dafür. Und ich glaube, das institutionelle Lernen kann doch ein bisschen schneller sein, gerade wenn die intellektuelle Begleitung, also Adam Toos schreibt über diese amerikanische Erfahrung, wir kriegen diese Corona-Aufarbeitung, wie ist man mit Geldbedarf umgegangen, Deutschland macht einen extra Haushalt, er findet einfach so ein Jahresbudget, obwohl das Jahr gar nicht im Kalender steht. Leute, solche Sachen, ja. Und ich glaube, da kann man auch nochmal anders drüber schreiben. Es ist jetzt ja ein historischer Materialismus bei Patrick hier im Buch, aber man könnte ja auch nochmal so einen ideellen, fantastischen Pragmatismus reinbringen.
Ja, beziehungsweise es gibt ja eine ganz klare Antwort auf das, was du da jetzt ausführst, nämlich dann müsste man tatsächlich die EZB politisieren.
Das Mandat mal hinterfragen, ob man noch ein paar mehr als 100% stimmt?
Es ist dann ein politischer Kampf darum. Es ist dann eine starke Politisierung, die man vornehmen muss, weil er uns ja auch zeigt, dieser so angeblich neutrale Rahmen ist, keineswegs neutral, wie wir hier merken. Und darüber hinaus gibt es natürlich dann Unruhe an den Kapitalmärkten, weil die reagieren ja schon auf solche Sachen. Also das ist das eine, ob man jetzt sagt, wir finanzieren die deutsche Wirtschaft während Corona durch, damit es keine hohe Arbeitslosigkeit gibt und weiterhin die Autos übers Band rollen. Oder ob ich sage, ich nehme jetzt mir vor, irgendeinen Fonds aufzulegen, mit dem ich die Entwicklungsländer weitgehend von Schulden befreien kann oder zumindest entlasten kann. Ob die Kapitalmärkte, die ja daran auch verdienen, dass sich da sehr viele sehr verschuldet haben, wie wir gleich noch sehen werden, dass die sich darauf einlassen, das ist wiederum etwas, was ja dann gar nicht eine Frage ist von Intelligenz und politischem Gestaltungswillen, sondern eigentlich eine Frage, wer hat die Macht? Und da sehen wir einfach dieses Machtungleichgewicht ist schon sehr stark.
Also dass wir hier Neuland betreten, ja. Und dass Neuland, also Bewegung auf Neuland immer dann schwierig sind, wenn gerade eine Katastrophe ist, dann geht man doch lieber zurück und so weiter. Aber wenn 1944 die Idee aufkam, wir könnten ja eine supranationale Leitwährung für die Welt etablieren, dann hätte das auf jeden Fall die Frage bedeutet, wie ist sie dann institutionell angebunden? Hat die eine Adresse? Kann man da einen Brief hinschicken? Wie regelt man und so weiter? Man hätte also irgendwelche Gremien gründen müssen. Nur der Euro ist ja so eine supranationale Währung jetzt. Also man hat 40 Jahre später dann einfach die Entscheidung getroffen, wir machen das jetzt mal. Und zwar ganz ohne kriegerische Katastrophe, sondern unter dem Eindruck, es ist ja noch mal gut gegangen.
Ja, sogar, eigentlich heißt nie wieder Krieg. Kooperationen in Währungs- und Finanzfragen lesen wir ja hier.
Und das hat man sicher, also 89 stand das ja wohl offenbar dann mit in der Tagesordnung. Okay, der Kalte Krieg, an dem sind wir noch mal vorbeigerutscht. Was könnten wir denn jetzt mal tun? Die neue europäische Idee und es war dann plötzlich, wir spannen eine Währung von Portugal bis, und dann nimmt man einfach die vorherigen sowjetischen Unterjochtenländer dazu. Also, dass es geht, zeigt ja die Geschichte. Also, dass man durchaus so Neuland betreten kann. Die Frage ist dann nur, ob man dabei bleibt, auch in Krisenfällen oder dann, zum Glück ist der Dollar immer noch da, oder ob man da nicht einfach mal sich selber sagt, ne komm, wir machen das jetzt mal ohne Dollar. Und unter Trump scheinen ja solche Bewegungen hoffentlich.
Ja, das ist aber das heimliche Denken, das du beschrieben hast in der Vost, dass alle da sitzen und zu Gavin Newsome schielen und sagen, hoffentlich macht er das in drei Jahren.
Wir reißen jetzt nicht alles ein. Die Mittelmächte machen kurz, ohne Amerika weiter, in der Hoffnung, dass sie zurückkommen.
Ja, aber vor allem als rhetorisches Spiel. Nun können wir hier einige Seiten zum Derivate, Markt und Nebengaspreis lesen. Ich würde sagen, das überspringen wir, weil es gelesen werden muss. Es ist sehr gut aufbereitet. Es lässt sich auch nicht in dem Sinne eine Politik machen. Man kann damit keine Medienkampagne machen, weil es einfach zu komplex ist. Ich glaube, hier ist das Wort auch richtig.
Also wenn schon, QMX, die einfachste Sache der Welt, immer als, das ist so wahnsinnig kompliziert. Glauben Sie, Sie kriegen uns das noch mal kurz erklärt. Man hat so einen Fundborn als Eigentumstitel. Den kopiert man einfach. Dann geht man in zwei Revelle-Filialen und gibt den ab. Ja, Punkt. Das ist die Erklärung. Warum sagen wir mal alle, das sei so kompliziert. Also man könnte schon, aber dafür braucht man echt eine neue Großwetterlage im Morgenmagazin.
Jaja, ich will nur sagen, allein das zu erklären, merkt man ja auch schon bei Patrick, der braucht da ja auch ein paar Absätze zu, um uns deutlich zu machen, wie dort verfahren wird, wie das eigentlich sein kann, dass ja wenige Unternehmen eine unglaubliche Marktmacht plötzlich haben und dann diese Preise in die Richtung treiben können, die ihnen gerade zu passen ist, weil sie wetten darauf abgeschlossen haben, dass die Preise sich so entwickeln mögen.
Das allerdings ist so ein wahnsinnig interessantes Kapitel.
Also doch, gut, dann reden wir drüber.
Der Minsky-Moment. Nur über den einen Aspekt.
Jaja, okay.
Wir haben schon häufiger beim Blick auf Silicon Valley über das mimetische Begehren von Girard gesprochen. Und wir fragen uns, warum ist Elon Musk so superreich? Obwohl die Teslas überholte Technologie sind, die Roboter ein Versprechen, das nicht eingelöst wird und dass wir den Daten sendern im Weltall ja mal gucken. So, ja. Und jetzt kommt er hier und sagt, es gibt eine Dynamik aus Unsicherheit und der aus Unsicherheit erwachsenen Verhaltensweisen, die sich dann in Marktverhalten niederschlagen. Die New York Times hat jetzt einen großen The Daily zum Thema Polymarkets gemacht, wo auch die Frage aufkam, wer beobachtet hier eigentlich was und gibt es noch eine sachliche Grundlage?
Ich will das nur sagen für alle, die uns hören, wir gehen jetzt doch von den Derivaten weg und gehen jetzt zu den Erwartungserwartungen.
Genau, wir gehen allgemein zu den finanzgebaren, dass sich um solche Preisfindungen auf den Derivaten markten und so weiter. Und Patrick schreibt hier sehr interessant über diese mehrstufigen Spekulationen, die da drinstecken. Also, dass man verschiedene Grade hat, wie zum Beispiel Getreide. Getreide kann man durchrechnen. 50 Tonnen machen 50.000 Brote oder irgendwas. Und dann könnte man da ein Preisfeld dranhängen. Dann könnte man das aber abhängig machen von, wer braucht denn hier Brot, gibt es da eine Knappheit, wie weit kann man das liefern, welche Kosten kommen dazu. Dann wird da so ein Derivatepreis gemacht. Dann ist man so auf der zweiten Ebene, jemand verbrieft sich das Recht, Zugriff auf diese Getreide vorkommen. Dann kommt aber jemand zweiten Grades und verbrieft sozusagen die ersten Grades, welche Bedeutung hat eigentlich Getreide, so allgemein wie auch immer und so. Und es scheint dann mehrere Grade zu geben. Und als ich das so las, dachte ich mir, ja, das brauchen wir noch mal als Große. So wie Adrian Daub über Peter Thiel geschrieben hat, was die denken, nennen, ja, müsste man hier noch mal was die Preisfindung nennen. Dass also letztlich bei Polymarkets Milliarden damit verdient werden, dass auf dem Derivatemarkt etwas auf dem logistischen Markt, etwas auf dem materiellen Markt und irgendwo ist ein Bauer, der einfach nur sich für eine Getreidesorte entscheidet, die er dieses Jahr anpflanzt.
Minsky ist ja derjenige, der sagt, die Zukunft ist bekanntlich unsicher und deswegen greift man auf Vergangenes und Eingeübtes zurück. Und die menschlichen Entscheidungen orientieren sich dann sehr viel an dem, was gerade gegenwärtig ist oder was durchschnittlich so da ist. Und das verzerrt natürlich einiges. Und hinzu kommt dieses Problem bei Spekulationen oder bei Preisen, Wettbewerb, der ganzen Konstellation, das, was Keynes ja schon beschrieben hat mit dem Schönheitswettbewerb. Also worauf spekuliert man jetzt eigentlich? Also wenn ich jetzt heraus, wenn ich jetzt, wer gewinnt den Schönheitswettbewerb? Ist das jetzt, das wäre der erste Grad die Person, die ich schön finde? Da sage ich, ja, das ist die Schönste. So, ist jetzt Miss Germany. Oder muss ich mir die Frage stellen, ja, aber wer gewinnt? Also frage ich mich zum Beispiel, wen findet die Mehrheit schön? Und dann muss ich auf eine andere Ebene noch mal gehen, auf den nächsten Grad, und muss zum Beispiel darüber nachdenken, ja, was denken jetzt die anderen grade, was die anderen denken, wer die Schönste ist? Und damit bin ich sehr losgelöst von meiner Frage, wer ist denn nun die Schönste? Sondern frage nur noch über die Erwartung der Erwartung.
Also ich sehe etwas. Er schreibt ja dann, mit jeder Stufe, mit jedem Grad entfernt man sich weiter von der eigenen ursprünglichen Einschätzung, also der eigene Meinung, die man hatte. Statt die Person zu wählen, die man am schlimmsten findet oder die, die die Mehrheit möglicherweise am schlimmsten findet, wird im dritten Grad die, Zitat, Intelligenz darauf verwendet, welche Meinung die meisten Leute über die Meinung der meisten Leute haben. Und es gibt einige, glaube ich, die die vierte, fünfte oder noch höheren grade praktizieren. So, das können wir jetzt aus diesem Text herauslesen. Und es ist auch wahnsinnig interessant und auch wahnsinnig bescheuert. Nur die Kennzahl dazu hat Patrick im Podcast mit Maurice geäußert. Hast du den gehört? Nein. Also die reden so eine halbe Stunde über das Buch. Und ich finde das, also ich fand es schon in der Gesprächsdynamik wahnsinnig interessant, weil im Grunde die Sachlage so klar ist und Maurice Höfgen da auch so wenig Aufklärung braucht, dass es zwischendurch so Advokados-Diabol-Dingsfragen gab, wo sich Maurice so absichtlich dumm gestellt hat, was ich sehr amüsant fand, muss ich an der Stelle mal sagen. Aber sehr gut, denn am Ende hätte man sich auch einfach die Stichworte hinschmeißen können, um zu sagen, hier Kapitel 1, 2, 3, was auch immer. Nur selbst Maurice Höfgen war so überrascht über diese eine Kennzahl, weil er sie am Ende der Sendung noch mal selber aufgegriffen und wiederholt hat, nämlich wir haben eine Realwirtschaft und die produziert ein Proto-Inlandsprodukt der Welt, ein BWP oder wie auch immer man das dann nennt. So, an dieser Realwirtschaft sind Geldströme gebunden und dieser Betrag an Geldstrom, von dem wird es von mehreren Graden des Abstrahierens, also der Verbriefung, jemand erwirbt hier nochmal einen Eigentumstitel oder da und dann wird es so hin und her und dann wird es alles und so weiter. Ja, also wir haben es mit diesen Derivaten zu tun. Am 3. Januar hat dieser Derivatehandel mehr Geld umgesetzt, als die Realwirtschaft im ganzen Jahr. Der braucht dafür nur drei Tage. Das ist das Ausmaß von dieser, hier nochmal ein Grad einlegen, da nochmal, da nochmal eine Kalkulation, da nochmal einen Markt, da nochmal eine Börse, da nochmal eine Verbriefung und so weiter und so fort.
Und das fußt alles auf der Ideologie, dass am Markt sich der perfekte Preis herausstellen wird. Er kommt ja im Zuge dieser ganzen Überlegungen von Keynes und Minsky und dem, was du gerade geschildert hast, auf diese Effizienz-Markthypothese zu sprechen, die einfach davon ausgeht, dass alle verfügbaren Informationen vollständig und sofort da sind. Und dann entstehen so die Preise. Und die Marktpreise sind aber auch immer fair, weil man ja alles hat. Und eigentlich brauchen wir all diese Institutionen bzw. diese verschiedenen Grade, um den perfekten Preis am Ende auf dem Markt zu haben. Dass da dann so viel Spekulation passiert, muss sein. Aber dafür haben wir auch die Info über den besten Preis. Damit ist das sozusagen an einer Faktizität gebunden, die sich aus dem Wissen der vielen heraus ergeben hat. Und das ist natürlich eine unglaubliche Fehlallokation. Also wenn wir auch über das ja dein großes Thema darüber sprechen, welche Bereiche sollte die KI einfach so wegradieren. Ich glaube nur hier in dem Bereich sehen wir dann eher wird die KI eingesetzt, um da noch ein paar weitere Abstraktionsgrade hinzuzufügen. Was aber immer so deutlich wird und auch gut ist an dem Buch, dass es so zurückgeführt wird dann auf was ganz Konkretes, weil wer uns jetzt zuhört, wird vielleicht auch so ein bisschen denken, auf welchen Abstraktionsebenen sind die jetzt gerade angekommen. Er bringt dann so ein ganz klassisches Beispiel, wie einfach diese Preisentwicklungen, wie falsch Preisentwicklungen sein können. Das wissen wir ja auch schon bei Isabella Weber, Preiskontrollen können hilfreich sein. Im Übrigen bei China war das ja ganz entscheidend. Er bringt das Beispiel, Russland marschiert in die Ukraine ein, Energie wird plötzlich knapp. Alle sorgen sich, wie machen wir das mit der Energie? Energiepreise steigen. Deutschland ist in einer sehr komfortablen Situation und kann sagen, was kostet die Welt? Wir werden hier unsere Industrie und unsere Bevölkerung weiter mit Energie versorgen. Also wir nehmen Geld in die Hand. Wir können auch teuer Kohle einkaufen.
Genau.
Patrick fährt mit seiner Familie durch Polen und wundert sich, dass sie jetzt laufend an Bahnschranken halten müssen, weil da Kohle hin und her transportiert wird. Sowas kommt sonst nur alle paar Wochen quasi vor. Also alle paar Tage haben sie das mal sonst so gemerkt, wenn sie in Polen im Urlaub waren. Und jetzt plötzlich sehen sie überall, dass da Kohle hin und her gefahren wird. Aber wo wird diese Kohle hingefahren? Sie wird aus Polen rausgefahren nach Deutschland, weil Deutschland die jetzt einfach kauft. Was aber dann zur Folge hatte, dass Polen große Not hatte, dass sie genügend Energie haben, dass bei denen nicht die Lichter ausgehen, weil das für die heimische Industrie in Polen besser war, wenn sie für höhere Preise die Kohle ins Ausland verkaufen. Und dann merkt man einfach, dass diese Preise, die ja so logisch sind und sich ergeben, dafür sorgen, dass man erstmal den Leuten vor Ort die Kohle wegnimmt und sie dann nach draußen bringt. Und Deutschland hat eben diese finanzielle Kraft zu sagen, es ist uns egal, wir kaufen das. Und das ist ja jetzt nur ein Beispiel für ganz vieles, was immer bedeutet, die, die dann weniger Zahlungskraft haben, gehen dann in diesen Fällen leer aus. Und dann kann man zwar sagen, ja, das ist eben die gerechte Preisentwicklung, das ist eine Frage von Angebot und Nachfrage, stimmt. Aber es zeigt eben genau, von welchen Machtungleichgewichten wir da ausgeben, welche Ungerechtigkeit da zementiert wird.
Und jetzt versuche ich mal den roten Faden, wie ich ihn herausgelesen habe, aus diesem Samariter der Welt herauszulesen. Also ein Kohlezug fährt, weil jemand Finanzmittel zur Verfügung hat, die ihm auch zur Verfügung stehen, weil irgend so ein Derivatebörsen, da kommt es darauf an, wo die sind, denn da wird dann verrechnet, wie auch immer, Frankfurt am Main, London, New York, Singapur und so. So und dann hat man plötzlich diesen Derivatehandel, der also irgendwie so mit der Kohle zu tun hat, aber nicht so direkt und an drei Tagen das ganze Weltvolumen an Wirtschaft durchnudelt. Das heißt, die müssen quasi alle drei Jahre die Welt neu erfinden. Wenn sie es nicht machen, wäre alles erledigt. So und dann wäre am 3. Januar das alles erledigt. Da muss man nur noch die Güter hin und her schicken. So und dann schreibt er hier diesen Wahnsinnssatz. Der wahrscheinlich wichtigste Punkt aber ist, dass die Entwicklungshilfe kein geeigneter Hebel ist, um die enormen Kosten auszugleichen, die sich für die Entwicklungsländer durch die Dysfunktionalität der Kapitalmärkte ergeben. Also die Entwicklungshilfe ist also nur da, um den Schaden zu bereinigen, den wir durch unsere, am 3. Januar muss einmal das BIP der Welt durchgeprügelt sein und so. So und dann beschreibt er das hier weiter. Wenn wir nach IWF-Logik die Finanzkrise 2008, die ja in diesem Derivatemarkt geschah, aufgelöst hätten, wäre Amerika heute pleite.
Ja.
Es würde dort nichts mehr geschehen. Denn nur weil man auf alle drei Tage wird das BIP der Welt verrechnet, gesagt hat, ja dann erfinden wir jetzt noch mal diese Geldmenge, die ihr da braucht, um euch einfach drei Tage Platz zu schaffen, damit ihr dann am Tag sieben hoffentlich wieder bei Vernunft seid und es wieder gerade zieht, so ungefähr. Also man musste dieses ganze Geld erfinden, alle IWF Logik über Bord werfen, die man allen anderen Ländern aufgezogen hat. So und er macht ein krasses Beispiel, was es bedeuten würde, würde man Amerika in so einem Fall durch die Krise schicken, und das ist Russland, da breche ich kurz aus dem Kapitel auf, denn hier zwischen 1990 und 1996 sank das reale pro-Kopfeinkommen in jedem einzelnen Jahr. 1990 ging es drei Prozent bergab, 1991 fünf Prozent, Jahr drauf 15 Prozent, Jahr drauf neun Prozent, Jahr drauf zwölfeinhalb Prozent. Zwischen 1995 und 1996 noch mal vier Prozent, 1997 kurze Stabilisierung plus von 1,6 Prozent, doch bereits 1998 wieder Rubelkrise, noch mal fünf Prozent runter. Zwischen 1989 und 98 ist das reale pro-Kopfeinkommen um sagenhafte 44 Prozent gesunken. Also der Umgang Russlands mit dem Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion und der Umgang Amerikas mit der Lehman-Pleite und dem ganzen, was da im Wall Street und so, ja.
Weil man Russland keine andere Wahl ließ, was man hier sagt.
Genau, wir hatten kein Geld, die fanden sich überhaupt gar nicht.
Also das war Jeltsin-Regierung, die das so dann machen musste. Das heißt, 44 Prozent sinkt dieses Realeinkommen innerhalb dieses Abschnitts von neun Jahren. Wir hören jetzt immer so, die Pointe lautet ja dann so, es sollte bis 2007 dauern, ehe das Einkommensniveau von 1989 wieder erreicht wurde. Und der nächste Satz lautet dann, am 31. Dezember 1999 übernahm nach einem Jahrzehnt des Chaos und des Niedergangs ein gewisser Vladimir Putin das Amt des Präsidenten.
Genau. Und in dem Textteil, wo er diese Frage aufwirft, was wäre, hätte Amerika mit der IWF-Logik die Finanzkrise 2008 klären müssen, kommt danach ein Textteil, der nochmal von 1944 und dem Aufstieg Hitlers redet. Also, dass wir unter diesen Gesichtspunkten nur Putin dort haben, ist schon ein kleiner historischer Fokus wert.
Und wenn jetzt immer gesagt wird, ja, das ist ja merkwürdig, dass Putin und die Seinen den Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion als Katastrophe betrachten, dann würde ich sagen, ja genau, das ist jetzt an diesen Zahlen genau ablesbar. Das ist der Grund. Da brauche ich nicht noch einen ideologischen Überbau. Das ist der Grund.
Genau. Und dann kann man sich ja die Geschichte ausführlich von ihm darlegen lassen, was mit Argentinien geschah. Da muss man sagen, sind einfach Superreiche mit ihren, wie er schreibt, Geierfonds in das Land eingefallen und haben sie einmal komplett ausgeräumt.
Ja, wir müssen das mal mit diesen Geierfonds. Also das ist was ganz Erstaunliches. Und zwar heißen die im englischen Valsche Funds. Es gibt Finanzmarktakteure, die kaufen Anleihen zu Sportpreisen auf dem Markt und dann bestehen sie aber auf die volle Rückzahlung der Schulden. Das heißt, da gehen Leute wirklich, also es ist so eine Art Leichenfledderei. Das ist ein bisschen wie, ich habe jetzt mit Ole gerade über das Geld von Solar gesprochen, den Roman, da geht auch so eine Figur dann immer rum, wenn die große Pleite ist, und dann sammelt die die Schuldscheine ein und dann guckt die, aus wem die dann noch was rauspressen kann. In so einer großen Tasche wird das rumgeführt. Und so machen die das eben auf einer internationalen Ebene hier. Und dann haben sie diese Schuldscheine. Wie kann es eigentlich sein jetzt, dass sie dafür noch Geld bekommen, also wenn sie den Kram da kaufen? Wie versuchen wir das jetzt klar zu machen? Also, ich lese mal den Abschnitt vor dazu. Ein klassisches Beispiel dafür ist die Staatspleite Argentinien 2001, als das Land die ausstehenden Verpflichtungen aus Anleiheemissionen von etwa 80 Milliarden US-Dollar nicht bedienen konnte, wurde es offiziell zahlungsunfähig. In den Jahren 2005 und 2010 wurden daher zwei Restrukturierungsrunden durchgeführt, in deren Rahmen ein Schuldenschnitt von rund 70 Prozent vereinbart und zudem zugesagt wurde, bei einer wirtschaftlichen Erholung höherer Rückzahlungen zu leisten. Rund 93 Prozent der Gläubiger stimmten dieser Lösung zu. Eine Ausnahme bildete jedoch NML Capital, eine Tochtergesellschaft von Elliott Management, einem der aggressivsten Akteure auf dem Markt sowie einige weitere Geierfonds. NML Capital hatte kurz vor dem Zahlungsausfall argentinische Anleihen für lediglich 177 Millionen US-Dollar aufgekauft und forderte später die Auszahlung des vollen Betrags von 4,65 Milliarden US-Dollar. So läuft das in der Praxis. Staatsanleihen werden zu stark reduzierten Preisen erworben, oft für nur wenige Cent pro Dollar des Nenwerts. Anschließend wird auf vollständige Rückzahlung des Nenwerts plus aufgelaufene Zinsen geklagt. Und diese Klagen trudeln wo ein? Natürlich in London, in New York. Da hat man dann ein Team von Anwälten, das entsprechend ausgestattet ist und sich darum kümmert, dass die Länder zahlen müssen. Das ist so unglaublich, wenn man es dann liest. Und Argentinien ist da nicht ein Einzelfall, sondern wir lesen das immer wieder hier, wie man diese Geierfonds in Anschlag bringen kann, um damit Länder unter Druck zu setzen und wirklich auch in die Hungersnot treiben kann. Er kommt auf das Beispiel Malawi zu sprechen. Da heißt es, für die Menschen in den ärmeren Regionen der Welt sind die Folgen der Aasgeierjagd, bittere Armut, Prekarität und sogar der Tod. So war es beispielsweise im Falle Malawis in den frühen 2000er Jahren. Damals musste der Staat seine Maisvorräte von 40.000 Tonnen verkaufen, um die Geierfonds von mehreren Dutzend Millionen Dollar zu entschädigen, die diese vor einem britischen Gericht erstritten haben. Die Hungersnot 2002 kostete Tausende Menschen das Leben, weil der Staat nicht mehr auf die Nahrungsreserven zurückgreifen konnte. Also das ist die tödliche Spekulation. Das ist so unglaublich. Hast du jemals von Geierfonds gehört? Ich nicht.
Also der Begriff kam mir schon mal unter, aber ich wusste nicht, dass das so ein eigenes Geschäftsfeld ist, wo man gezielt bis hin zu politische Kandidaten kaufen. Die nennt er ja dann auch, die dann Argentinien regieren, weil sie durch Zufall so eine Wahl gewinnen. Und dann gibt es das große Siegerfoto mit der IWF-Chefin, die dann noch mal fröhlich verkündet, wow, jetzt haben wir das Land wieder stabilisiert.
Schaut sich klar, wird hier ja mehrmals erwähnt, der versucht dann dort was zu ändern. Also es geht dann darum, warum kann man das nicht eigentlich durchsetzen, dass diese Leute, die die Fonds kaufen, dann nur, also warum bekommen die das volle Geld von dem, was, das haben sie ja nie ausgegeben. Aber sobald man dort dann politisch wirksam wird, gibt es also sehr, oder wirksam werden will, gibt es dann einen sehr heftigen Gegenwehr bzw. ja, da werden Menschen dann aus dem Amt geputscht.
Wirklich kompliziert. Also die Formulierung von Ziegler, die er als Völkerrechtsnorm vorgeschlagen hat. Ich lese mal vor, weil da denkt man sich wirklich ohne Klot und Aufklärung kommen wir nicht weiter. Wenn ein Gläubiger mit dem Rückkauf der Anleihe oder des Schuldtitels eines Staates einen unbilligen Vorteil verfolgt, beschränken sich seine Ansprüche an den Schuldnerstaat auf dem Preis, den er für den Rückkauf der Anleihe oder des Schuldtitels bezahlt hat. Folglich dürfen keine Urteile gesprochen bzw. keine Schiedssprüche oder ausländische Urteile verstreckt werden, die eine Rückzahlung von Staatsanleihen oder staatlich garantiert Schuldtitel über die durch die vorliegende Norm gesetzten Grenzen hinaus vorsehen. Das muss natürlich erstmal Obskorität gelüftet werden.
Aber wir wissen auch, es konnte sich nicht durchsetzen.
Bevor wir uns hier den Ende neigen, hat er ein sehr großes Kapitel nochmal zu Argentinien später. Da kriegt man nochmal Aufklärung, dass der IWF irgendwie 50, wie nennt man das denn, Exkursionen dahin gemacht hat, um dem Land zu sagen, wie es jetzt richtig geht. Ja.
Wir erfahren ja hier sowieso in diesem Kapitel dann Krise als Normalzustand, dass wenn man als Land um 1800 schon ganz gut dastand, dann ist das 2000 wahrscheinlich auch immer noch so. Also das ist dieses lange Erbe des Kolonialismus, beziehungsweise ja genau wie mit den Erbschaften.
Ostdeutschland kommt auch noch in dem Kapitel vor. Ich war schockiert.
Ja, bring das mal.
Also ich komme ja selber aus dem Osten und das Gejama dort geht mir ja auch sehr auf den Sack. Allerdings die ökonomischen Verwerfungen. Er zitiert die Publizistin Daniela Dahn, die darauf verwies, dass die Bruttowertschöpfung des verarbeiteten Gewerbes in Ostdeutschland innerhalb von zwei Jahren um 70 Prozent zurückging. Das ist also ein Einbruch, wer noch zu gut formuliert. Die Publizistin Daniela Dahn verwies darauf, dass dieser Absturz, Zitat, einmalig in der Weltgeschichte war und, Zitat, nicht einmal der dreißigjährige Krieg Folgen dieser Art hatte. Vier Millionen Menschen wurden praktisch über Nacht arbeitslos und es dauerte ganze 18 Jahre, so führt sie aus, bis auch nur der Ach-so-Marode-Stand vom Ende der DDR wieder erreicht wurde. Was bedeutet? Westdeutschland hat durch die deutsche Einheit eine demographische Plünderung vorgenommen, die wirklich beispiellos ist. Ich habe ja schon ein paar Mal darauf hingewiesen, dass Ostdeutschland Pionier in diesem Alterungsszenario ist. Also niemand ist so alt wie Ostdeutschland. Plus habe ich auch schon häufiger angemerkt, dass die Südkoreaner sich sehr für diese deutsch-deutsche Geschichte interessieren, weil sie natürlich immer noch auf eine Wiedervereinigung mit Nordkorea hoffen. Und wir wissen ja, unter welcher demografischen Lage Südkorea ist, also noch schlimmer, noch größerer Baby-Bumer-Bauch, noch mehr blockierte Republik und blockierte Leben und so. Und hier noch mal so einen kleinen Fokus auf Ostdeutschland zu legen. Trifft dich!
Kommen wir noch auf, den IWF zu sprechen. Also diese IWF-Programme wurden immer stärker ausgeweitet. Zunächst einmal als Institution angelegt, um den internationalen Handel zu gewährleisten, durch die Währungen, die koordiniert werden müssen. Es geht also darum, dass man eigentlich eine Institution geschaffen hat, die zunächst einmal so aussah, als würde sie allen vielleicht zu Gute kommen. Aber es war immer schon so, dass wenn ein Land in Zahlungsschwierigkeiten kam, dann das IWF mit seinem Programm kommt und sagt, wir müssen da mal ein bisschen was restrukturieren oder reformieren. Interessant ist nun, dass also Ende der 80er Jahre das immer weiter an Fahrt aufnimmt. Das heißt also, die Anzahl der Bedingungen, die das IWF an das verschuldete Land stellt, immer weiter gesteigert werden. Und wenn man sich dann die Länder, die am meisten vom IWF sich anhören mussten, was sie alles tun sollen ansieht, dann kommt man bei Russland und der Ukraine heraus. Also, dass die insgesamt 143 bzw. 148 Bedingungen sich anhören mussten. Und was ist dann eigentlich das, was der IWF fordert? Nun, um schuldendos zu werden, um weiterhin Kredithilfen zu bekommen, muss dann gehandelt werden. Bedeutet, der Sozialstaat muss gekürzt werden. Wenn Papst Franziskus, auf den hier verwiesen wird, sagt, diese Wirtschaft tötet, dann ist das in der Tat in einen Zusammenhang zu stellen mit der IWF-Praxis. Nämlich dort kann man sehen, wo diese IWF-Bedingungen umgesetzt werden, steigt die Suizidrate von 4 bis 14 Prozent. Ist da der Anstieg, geh nach Land zu bemerken. Zudem fragt man sich auch, was geht in einem IWF vor. Wir haben ja jetzt schon mehrmals betont, gesund sparen kann man sich nicht. Und Amerika macht genau das nicht, ist deshalb so erfolgreich. China hat sich das auch nicht so diktieren lassen müssen. Aber andere schwächere Länder sollen sparen dort, wo wir wissen, dass das ein Land auf Dauer in die Krise bringt und vor allem auch alle Möglichkeiten nimmt, aus dieser Krise noch mal rauszukommen. Da heißt es zum Beispiel zum Thema Bildung. Der IWF hat in der Vergangenheit mit der Weltbank dafür gesorgt, dass Kindern der kostenlose Zugang zur Grundschulausbildung gestrichen wird. Stattdessen wurde die Einführung von Schulgebühren gefordert. So musste Bulgarien 2006 insgesamt 5500 Stellen bei der Bildung abbauen. Sierra Leone sollte 2002 die Gehälter der Lehrer frisieren. Tajikistan sollte 5 Prozent der Menschen im Bildungssektor reduzieren. Das ist also die IWF-Politik, die dann umgesetzt wird. Das heißt, man schlägt eigentlich mit der Axt zu und wundert sich dann aber auch, dass ein Land nicht mehr auf die Sprünge kommt.
Ja, crazy sind ja auch diese Einsparungen bei den Gesundheitsausgaben. Ja, also es gibt ja wohl Regeln oder so Vorgaben, was so adäquat wäre. Wo sind wir da? Weiß gar nicht genau, aber es gibt so einen Mindestwert, der wird immer unterlaufen, also wie viel BIP-Prozente gut wären. Je mehr Bedingungen ein Land in einem IWF-Programm erfüllen muss, desto geringer fallen die Gesundheitsausgaben aus. Im Durchschnitt belaufen sich die Kürzungen auf fast ein Prozent des BIP in Westafrika, wo der IWF sehr aktiv war. Legen die geöffentlichten Gesundheitsausgaben 2017 im Schnitt nur bei 1,3 Prozent des BIP und damit deutlich unter den internationalen empfohlenen Mindestwerten von 5 Prozent. Typischerweise nutzen die Länder sehr viel Mehrspielraum. Also wir Deutsche geben 8.000 Dollar im Jahr für Gesundheit aus. In Amerika sind es 15.000 Dollar und wir wissen ja, wie die das noch verteilen. Also da profitieren ja welche sehr. Westafrika, 17 US-Dollar. Absurd. Er hat dieses Beispiel Nigeria. Nigeria fand ich auch noch mal sehr interessant unter diesen demografischen Gesichtspunkten, denn wir wissen Nigeria ist ein wahnsinnig riesiges Land. Also über 200 Millionen Menschen. Und da gab es dann Programme, die dazu führten, dass, also es ging irgendwie um Benzinpreise, wie auch immer. Die haben sich dann verdreifacht. Es gab eine riesige Inflation. Die Landeswährung hat sich um 70 Prozent abgeschwächt. Und dann kam die Financial Times und hat sich die Lage angeschaut und sprach von die rasant steigenden Preise sind die schlimmsten Wirtschaft, sind die schlimmste wirtschaftliche Notlage seit Menschengedenken. Und das ist aber nicht, was der IWF beseitigt hat, sondern verursacht hat. Sind direkte Folge der IWF Politik. Man fragt sich, dass wir heute eine Nachrichtenlage haben, in der wir hören, dass Donald Trump unverblümt einfach da sitzt und sagt, Venezuela liegt nah an Amerika, sollte mir gehören. Kanada liegt ganz nah, sollte auch mir gehören. Krönland liegt auch relativ nah, sollte mir gehören. Dieses Denken überhaupt, dass man so eine Landkarte vor sich hat und dann einfach so markiert, diese Geisteshaltung. Diese Landkartengeisteshaltung ist beim IWF einfach. Also die operieren nur noch auf dieser, da ist halt eine Karte, das ist die Welt. Und jetzt machen wir so ein PIN dran und holen uns da 10 Milliarden. Und dass man das überhaupt unter Entwicklungshilfe laufen lässt, statt das hier einfach westliche Plünderung und so ein Wolfram Weimer denken, der einfach sagt, es gibt ja keine Städten des Kolonialismus, deswegen muss man dem nicht gedenken.
Da ist er. Ja, IWF ganz klar. Städte des Kolonialismus und zwar des heutigen Kolonialismus.
Also hier ist so ein Satz, den kann man wirklich für Weimer direkt da. Also Weimer sagt uns, es gibt keine Städte des Kolonialismus. Und Patrick schreibt, die Verantwortung der Industriestaaten, sowohl für die koloniale Vergangenheit als auch für die gegenwärtige internationale Ordnung, lässt sich dagegen nur herunterspielen, wenn man in Ahnungslosigkeit verweilt oder eine bewusste Realitätsverweigerung betreibt. Kann man ja mal auf eine Postkarte schicken und nach Berlin. Finale. Patricks Vorschläge. Und wir wissen ja, er hat oben geschrieben, Aufklärung, Idee, Landschaftspflege. Dass man hier die Welt nicht retten kann, ist klar.
Ich bin schon froh, es kommt bei den Vorschlägen nicht Bürgerrat vor. Man muss ja bei jedem Sachbuch froh sein, wenn nicht das Wort Bürgerrat am Ende auftaucht, wenn es um die Vorschläge geht. Sondern hier geht es jetzt um wesentlich mehr, denn die Sanktionen gegen die Ukraine, so Patrick, zeigen ja erst einmal die Schwäche der westlichen Macht, dass man eben nicht mehr dort alle Fäden in der Hand hat. Und die westliche Integrität ist nun ja hart angekratzt durch das Vorgehen der israelischen Regierung in Gaza, das vom Westen mit unterstützt wird. Wenn man jetzt glaubt, man müsse nur weiterhin auf eine Weltordnung bestehen, die man für sich bestimmt hat und dann kann alles so weitergehen, sagt er ganz klar nein. Es gibt eine große Abwendung, soweit das möglich ist, dieser Länder von der westlichen Ordnung. Und es ist auch eine Illusion, dass man glaubt, man könne mit China als Partner und als Systemrivale gleichermaßen kooperieren. Er schreibt der Glaube, dass man mit China Rosinen picken könnte, also dass man auf einigen Gebieten kooperieren und auf anderen die Bandagen anlegen könne, ist naiv. Die chinesische Regierung betrachtet Beziehungen in ihrer Gesamtheit. Er verweist dann nochmal darauf, was das für diplomatische Verwerfungen gegeben hat und auch dann wirtschaftliche Folgen hatte, dass Nancy Pelosi nach Taiwan gereist ist. Also man stelle sich gerade in den westlichen Ländern vor, man könne eigentlich so eine Ampel haben. Alle drei Lichter sind dann gleichzeitig an. Partner, systemische Rivale und weiß ich nicht, was das dritte dann noch ist. Das heißt, so kann es jedenfalls nicht gehen. Und es braucht eine tiefgreifende Reform dieser Institutionen, die, wie wir jetzt auf 200 Seiten lesen konnten, keineswegs neutral sind.
Ja, also die zwei Punkte, die ich hier wichtig finde im Finale, ist zum einen diese langfristige Stabilisierung der Finanzmärkte, Kapitalmärkte, was natürlich nur geht, indem man sagt, okay Leute, ihr kriegt jetzt ein Budget, wie so ein CO2 Budget. Ihr dürft nicht hundertmal im Jahr das Bruttoinlandsprodukt der Realwirtschaft durchjagen, sondern die Asymmetrien und Abstraktionen der derivaten Verbriefungen darf nur 30 mal im Jahr. Ja. Danach ist einfach der Computer sagt dann, sorry, die Nullen kann ich nicht mehr hinschreiben.
So, Punkt. Ist mir noch nicht so ganz klar, wie man das dann reduzieren will. Naja, Stabilisierung der Kapitalmärkte, man kann ja, es gibt ja Dauerregulierung und es sind ja viele Sachen auch verboten. Die Frage ist, warum sind andere Sachen nicht verboten? Also warum ist das mit den Gaspreisen so? Warum gibt es da diese Möglichkeiten, dass man dort auf mehreren Ebenen spekulieren kann und sich am Ende noch selbst dann in der Spekulation bestätigen kann, dass also die Wette, die man abschließt, auch so geführt wird, dass sie für einen funktioniert, dass man selbst eigentlich die Wette sich gewinnen lassen kann. Also das ist diese ganzen Dinge. Da müsste natürlich entsprechend reguliert werden. Viel wichtiger oder ebenso wichtig finde ich dann auch, dass er anspricht, dass wir eigentlich einen Lohn- und Wachstumspolitik brauchen. Also dass die Löhne sich nicht vom Wachstum entkoppeln. Denn das haben wir in Deutschland, das haben wir in den anderen Ländern natürlich auch. Bedeutet natürlich dann auch, dass wir darüber nachdenken, wie man eigentlich Industriepolitik auch den Entwicklungsländern möglich macht.
Ja, indem man sich aber nicht mehr einmischt.
Ja, das bedeutet ja aber, die Kapitalmärkte werden sich ja in irgendeiner Weise einmischen. Also das würde ja bedeuten, man lässt Entwicklungsländern Investitionsfonds zukommen, die nicht mit hohen Zinsen belegt sind und die nicht daran gekoppelt sind, dass man irgendwelche IWF-Auflagen erfüllt, bei denen die Schulen kaputtgespart werden und die Krankenhäuser geschlossen werden. Sondern dass man sagt, das sind gerade nicht Verschuldungen, sondern es werden Vermögensberge geschaffen, so wie wir das hier mit der MMT uns für Deutschland und Europa auch ansehen. Und das ist das große Problem, dass wir hier in noch verschärfter Weise finden, was Austeritätspolitik anrichtet, wo wir schon hier sehen, wie weit es damit gekommen ist. Und jetzt stehen wir natürlich vor dem Dilemma, dass wir es mit einer Politik zu tun haben, die Austeritätspolitik sogar schon im Inland gut findet und dann im Ausland umso mehr. Also es ist eine sehr schwierige Position. Aber ich glaube, wenn man sich mit globaler Gerechtigkeit beschäftigen will, dann kommt man eigentlich um all diese Kennzahlen und diese Analysen, die Patrick vorlegt, nicht umhin.
Also ich will zwei Vorschläge machen. Das eine ist diese Stabilisierung der Finanzmärkte. Wenn wir statt, sagen wir mal, vierter, fünfter, sechster und siebter Vergradung des Derivatehandels können wir auch sagen, wir beziehen jetzt auch die Finanzmärkte wieder, also wir besinnen sie wieder darauf, worum es geht, nämlich in der Realwirtschaft Sachen zu ermöglichen. Und wir haben eine demografische Lage, bei der die afrikanischen Länder dieses Jahrhundert noch von 1,5 Milliarden auf so vier, also der Bevölkerungsexplosion im wirklich nur historischen, wie in Europa, aber Afrikas halt zehnmal so groß so ungefähr, also irgendwie in diesem Maßstab. Wir müssen also dem Finanzmarkt sagen, sehr viele Sachen sind einfach verboten. Und wenn ihr ein bilanziertes Plus haben wollt bei euch, müsst ihr das aus der Realwirtschaft dort rausleiern. Also da müssen echte Produkte hergestellt werden, von den echten Menschen, die natürlich nur mit echter Lohnzahlung angehalten werden können, dafür euch zu arbeiten, wie auch immer. Also dass man dann wieder eine Verkirkung herstellt. Und das zweite ist, wir machen noch ein Angebot an uns selber und an die afrikanischen Länder und sagen, wir nutzen noch, wir nutzen den letzten Schuss, den wir haben, um die Nachkriegsordnung zweiter Weltkrieg zu retten, also UN und so. Und zwar mit konsequenter Umsetzung der Millenniumziele, die ja sehr gut sind. Niemand, der die liest, würde die irgendwie noch besser machen können. Also es ist einfach sozusagen ein perfektes Werk. Man hat da diesen riesigen Sonnenschein an verschiedenen Strahlen. Jeder weiß so eine Einrichtung, Gesundheitsbildung, Familie, Dinge, so weiter. Und dieses ideelle Werk, was da geschaffen wurde, zur Jahrtausendwende, übernimmt man einfach als konkrete politische Zielsetzung. Und man bilanziert, wenn davon abgewichen wird, ist dieser Vertrag gekündigt und dann wissen die afrikanischen Länder, jetzt ist es wirklich vorbei. Irgendwie so.
Zerfall der Weltordnung. Wir empfehlen dieses Buch. Man hofft, dass diese Argumente jetzt in vielen Debatten zu tragen kommen, vor allem, wenn wieder irgendwas kommt mit, wir können uns keine Entwicklungshilfe leisten. Wir müssen eigentlich sagen, wir müssen überhaupt mal anfangen, uns Entwicklungshilfe zu leisten. Und wie die aussehen kann, das kann man in diesem Buch nachlesen. Aber auch wie generell der globale, finanzmarktgetriebene Kapitalismus radikal reformiert gehört, auch das steht in dem Buch. Kurzum, wir empfehlen es. Beiten wir unseren Blick ins Globale mit Patrick Kaczmarczyk. Er hat ein herausragendes Buch geschrieben. Zerfall der Weltordnung, die Ignoranz des Westens und der Aufstand des globalen Südens. Wir erfahren hier anhand vieler Zahlen sehr gut, wo wir eigentlich stehen. Nämlich, dass die Entwicklungshilfe häufig im eigenen Land bleibt und gar nicht nach außen fließt. Wir erfahren, dass es Geierfonds gibt, mit denen man Menschen in die Armut treiben kann und selbst dabei sehr reich wird. Wir sehen hier eine sehr präzise, prägnante Kritik an den so neutral erscheinen Institutionen wie EWF und Weltbank. Es ist die Globalisierungskritik, die wir brauchen, die nicht zum Rückzug aufruft, sondern eigentlich sagt, jetzt brauchen wir wirklich mal ein Verständnis davon, dass wir in einer Welt leben. Und wir sehen hier, welche Allmachtsansprüche der Westen durch die Institutionen durchdrücken konnte und dass diese Zeit vielleicht nun vorbei ist. Und es ist gut, dass die Zeit endet. Die Frage ist nur, in welche Richtung geht es dann?
Das Buch kommt zur richtigen Zeit, denn wir machen ja gerade eh die Beobachtung, dass wir uns fragen, wer sind eigentlich die Opfer von allen Entwicklungen, die wir so sehen? Und beim Thema Globalisierung der Wirtschaft ist der globale Süden gar nicht so weit, wie man denkt. Also hier ist auch interessante historische Aufklärung zum Thema Ostdeutschland drin. Nochmal ein neuer Blick auf Griechenland und so weiter und so fort. Von daher sollte eigentlich eine Verbrüderung mit allen anderen sieben Milliarden 900 Millionen Opfern dieser Entwicklung, die wir hier beschrieben sehen, gar nicht so schwer fallen. Aber dazu muss dieses Buch erst mal gelesen werden. Wir rufen also insbesondere auf, sich mal wieder eine Ideengeschichte zuzuwenden, damit man eine materielle Geschichte neu schreiben kann.
Die Historikerin Dagmar Herzog hat ein schmales, aber sehr wichtiges Buch vorgelegt. Das heißt Der neue faschistische Körper. Sie beschäftigt sich da mit den Rechten in Deutschland wie in den USA und fragt sich, welches Körperbild bringen die eigentlich hervor? Gibt es jetzt so etwas wie einen sexy Rassismus? Was kann das sein? Der sexy Rassismus, schreibt sie, libidinös aufgeladene Botschaften, die Gefühle von Angst, Wut und Abneigung schüren oder andersherum ein erregendes Dominanzgefühl gegenüber rassifizierter Vulnerabilität erzeugt, wie ich zeigen möchte. Visuelle Echoes mit antisemitischer Bildsprache sowie der Verherrlichung arischer Perfektion aus dem dritten Reich. Auch die Behindertenfeindlichkeit der AfD hat komplexe Wurzeln in der Propaganda für eine Nation ohne Makel. Ja, das sind die beiden Themen, die sie vor allem anspricht, also welche Sexsinister produziert wird und auch wie Lust daraus gezogen wird, dass man andere abwertet. Und zudem diese Idee von einem perfekten Volkskörper, wo alles stört, was nicht dazugehört, also Menschen mit Behinderung werden dann verachtet. Auch beschäftigt sie sich damit, wie man darauf immer wieder jetzt zustößt, dass Menschen mit kognitiven Beeinträchtigungen oder mit psychiatrischen Erkrankungen als nicht dazugehörig gesehen werden. Und sie geht dann auch auf ein Beispiel an, auf das wir jetzt gleich kommen. Da wird man überrascht sein, wen sie da erwähnt. Man kann sich zum Beispiel die Wahlplakate von der AfD ansehen. Und da sehen wir zum Beispiel ein Plakat von 2019 in Sachsen. Da sehen wir eine Frau mit freiem Oberkörper. Auf dem Dekollet ist ein Schriftzug. Sie ist angekettet an einer Heizung. Und da steht, Pfefferspray hilft nicht immer, gute Politik schon. Also eine blonde, hübsche Frau. Und die wird beschützt von der AfD gegen all jene, die ihr Böses wollen. Wir ahnen, wo das dann hinführt. Wir haben also hier auch mit dieser Nacktheit hier eigentlich eine Grenzüberschreitung. So das Wohlanständige wird ja hier überschritten, dass wir hier so ein Plakat haben mit einer nackten Frau. Und zugleich aber wird der Anstand eingefordert. Wir sorgen dafür, dass dieser schönen Frau nichts passiert, finden es aber auch ein bisschen sexy, sie genauso zu inszenieren. Oder es geht um einen KI generierten Wahlkampf, Werbespot der AfD zu dem Remigrationshit. Da sieht man dann zum Beispiel Stewartessen in eng anliegenden Kostümen, die mit Sektflaschen da rumhantieren. Also auch da gibt es eine ganz klare Bildsprache. Wir sorgen dafür, dass unsere blonden Frauen nicht von irgendwelchen Ausländern betouched werden. Aber wir selbst gucken natürlich lustvoll auf diese Bilder. Und das ist eine Konstellation, die sie sehr interessiert. Auch, wenn Schwangere so erotisch noch aufgeladen werden. Der hinter-sinnige Humor bietet Unterhaltungswert und bei Kritik lässt sich einfach auch alles leugnen. Kontextabhängig stilisiert sich die Partei beispielsweise als zugleich homofeindlich und homo-freundlich. Einerseits feiern AfD-Politikerinnen einen nationalistischen Stolzmonat mit seinem Slogans gegen Regenbogen, Mist und Genderirrsinn, um ihren Antagonismus gegenüber der LGBTQ-Pride-Bewegung auszudrücken. Andererseits werden im Wahlkampf mit unverhüllt rassistischen Slogans schwule und lesbische Stimmen umworben. Zitat, mein Partner und ich legen keinen Wert auf die Bekanntschaft mit muslimischen Einwanderern, die unsere Liebe als Todsünde empfinden. Ähnlich gemischt sind die heterosexuellen Botschaften der Partei. Sie steht für die traditionelle Familie ein und verweist augenzwinkert auf Sex unter Jugendlichen. Sie zelebriert die Sinnlichkeit schwangerer Körper und keusche, anständige weiße Mutterschaft, stellt junge Frauen aber auch gerne in knappen Bikinis und als vollbusige Wirtenden dar. Das heißt, man bietet so beides und sie als Historikerin, die sich ja mit den Geschlechteridentitäten, mit der Sexualität im Nationalsozialismus beschäftigt hat, merkt natürlich hier ganz klare Parallelen. Nämlich ist es ja nicht so, als sei der Nationalsozialismus einfach eine prüde Erscheinung gewesen, denn man hat zugleich eine Entwicklung dort gehabt, die eine große Liberalisierung auch mitimplizierte, für bestimmte Frauen und für ein bestimmtes Weltbild, das durchgesetzt werden sollte. Das heißt, es ist immer das eine und das andere häufig. Bedeutet hier auch, dass sexualisierte Heraufbeschwören von Gefahren mittlerweile in der Mitte des politischen Spektrums angekommen und von Christdemokratinnen bis zu den Grünen hat einen Modus ungehemmter Pralerei einem Reich der Schadenfreude den Weg geebnet. Oder wie Adam Serwer es in Bezug auf den Trumpismus auf den Punkt bringt, die Grausamkeit ist Programm. Die Geheimbotschaft des Faschismus an seine Anhängerinnen ist nicht die Unterdrückung. Im Gegenteil, er stellt Freibriefe zu ungehemmten Verhalten bei Straflosigkeit aus. Also all diese Äußerungen, die wir ja von Donald Trump sehr gut kennen. Die AfD beschäftigt sich, so stellt sie fest, sehr stark, also stärker als jede andere rechte Partei, so will sie festhalten, mit dem Thema Menschen mit Behinderung und dass man ihnen gar nicht zu viel Zugang ermöglichen soll. Also ein Anti-Inklusionsprogramm. Und das wird immer wieder dann mit behindertenfeindlichen Nuancen so ausgedrückt, als müsse man eben alle retten vor denen, man muss ja, sich versuchen abzudichten. Und das ist aber etwas, was wir nicht nur bei der AfD finden können, sondern wir sehen es natürlich auch bei Donald Trump. Nicht nur erinnern wir uns daran, wie er dort einen Journalisten mit Behinderung nachgeahmt hat, sondern sie kommt auch auf was anderes zu sprechen. Das war mir gar nicht bekannt. Und zwar kommt es da zu Bemerkungen gegenüber Trumps Neffen Fred Trump, der Dritte, dessen erwachsener Sohn William ist schwer beeinträchtigt. Und nachdem Fred während der ersten Amtszeit von Trump mit einer Gruppe betroffener Elternaktivistinnen das Weiße Haus besuchte, äußerte sich Trump wie folgt. Diese Leute, also Spricherwachsene mit mehrfachen und schweren Behinderungen, der Zustand, in dem sie sind, das kostet nur. Vielleicht sollten die Art Leute einfach sterben. Er ging, schreibt dann Dagmar Herzog, zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt so weit, Fred direkt zu sagen, dass das vielleicht auch für William gelte. Diese Haltung, schreibt Herr Herzog, halt außerdem wieder in seiner absurden Behauptung, dass Kamala Harris zurückgeblieben sei. Also das ist auch etwas, was wir immer wieder da finden können, dass die sind zurückgeblieben, die sind debil, die können das nicht. Also das ist etwas, was wir dort genauso sehen. Und das verbindet sie dann natürlich mit den Diskursen aus dem Nationalsozialismus, wie dort auch über Intelligenz geredet wird. Und man sieht aber auch, wie dieses Denken in IQ generell bei Rechten vertreten ist. Sie kommt auf ein Beispiel zu sprechen, nämlich Ulf Poschert. Poschert hat einen Artikel geschrieben, der hieß Die Verächter des Freien Westens. Und da geht es darum, dass Poschert erst mal den Zivilisationsbruch, der Schoah beschreibt, dass er dann sagt, dass es eine unglaubliche Barbarei ist, was die Hamas tut. Alles in Ordnung, bis dahin. Doch inmitten der Bemühungen, Äquivalenzen zwischen den Nationalsozialisten und der Hamas festzustellen und unter Verweis auf das unsägliche Leid, das letztere Versuch ursacht haben, rutscht Poschert der Gedanke heraus, dass die Hamas dies im Geiste von Amon Goethe, Heinrich Himmler oder Josef Mengele, in Klammern, minus deren teuflischen IQ getan habe. Wie ist eine solche Betonung des IQs bekannter Holocausttäter zu verstehen? Umso mehr zu einem Moment unaussprechlichen Traumas. Die Aussage liest sich als seltsam durchsichtiger Versuch, drei Dinge auf einmal zu tun. Auf eine klar rassistische Herabwürdigung arabischer Intelligenz zu bestehen, dabei die Hamas und ihre unbestreitbaren Übeltaten auf der Stufenleiter historischer Kreu weit oben nahe des Holocaust einzuordnen, und gleichzeitig noch dem Selbstwertgefühl des deutschen Publikums zu schmeicheln. Wir haben ja den hohen IQ. Also das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Und sie bringt dann auch noch ein weiteres Beispiel von Matthias Döpfner, der dann ins Gegenteil geht. Der sagt dann, wir brauchen, Deutschland soll jüdischer werden. Und das begründet er damit, dass dann mehr Intelligenz nach Deutschland kommt und nicht so viel Schwäche hier in Deutschland ist. Denn man habe hier durch diese woge Bewegung die ganze Zeit immer gesagt, Schwache ist gut und stark ist schlecht. Und deswegen plädiert er da. Also man sieht dann, wie plötzlich solche IQ-Ideologien überall ihre Blüten treiben. Das ist also ihr Thema zum einen. Das andere Thema ist dann, wie die Körper aussehen bzw. auch, was Sexualität eigentlich bedeutet bei den Rechten. Zunächst ist festzuhalten, dass der Nationalsozialismus nicht annähernd so sexuell restriktiv und repressiv war, wie lange Zeit angenommen, jedenfalls für heterosexuelle arische Menschen ohne Behinderung, also die Bevölkerungsmehrheit. Im Gegenteil, kein anderes Regime der Geschichte hat sich so systematisch zum Ziel gesetzt, dass heterosexuelle Verlangen insbesondere junger Menschen zu stimulieren und fördern, während es leugnete, genau dies zu tun. Das Regime nahm die Rolle des Erlaubnisgebenden ein. Eine Kernbotschaft war, wie Slavoj Zizek es einmal scharfsinnig in einem anderen, aber verwandten Kontext formulierte, du darfst. Und das ist etwas, was wir ja gerade so bei Äußerungen von Maximilian Krah und so gut wiedersehen können. Also der potente Mann und du brauchst jetzt, guck keine Pornos, geh raus, dann findest du auch eine Freundin. Und du darfst, du darfst also jetzt Sex haben und all das. Aber zugleich müssen wir aufpassen, denn da sind die Menschen, die hier zu uns gekommen sind, die sind böse, die sind gefährlich. Mit denen lass dich lieber nicht ein. Ja, also darum geht es also um diese Trennung. Und das vergleicht sie dann sehr gut, wie man zum einen so eine fast hedonistische Praxis, könnte man meinen, wenn gleich sie immer auf so ein Staatsziel, Volkskörper hinaus war, bei den Nazis sehen konnte. Diese, sagen wir mal, enthemmte Sexualität, dieses du darfst, war aber wiederum abgegrenzt von einer jüdischen Sexualität. Diese wurde nämlich dann so dargestellt, als sei die, die einen kaputtmache, eine, die einen dazu führt, dass man den Sinn des Lebens verliert, dass man vom Wege abkommt, all das. Sie geht auch auf Sterbehilfe hier ein. Auch das ist, glaube ich, ganz wichtig zu lesen, weil wir sehr schnell jetzt so dabei sind, bei so einer Liberalisierung von Sterbehilfe, wir haben das ja auch schon mal im Podcast thematisiert, zu verkennen, welche Implikationen da eigentlich noch mit drin liegen. Interessant ist auch, wie sie da beschreibt, wie der Protestantismus in den Zwanzigerjahren schon bei Menschen mit Behinderungen, sich immer mehr dazu bewegte, zu sagen, dass Behinderung ein Resultat ist, aus sitenlosen Verhalten, dass er also aus sitenloser Sexualität heraus Behinderung entstanden sei. Und auch, wie der Protestantismus dann damals zwar sich lange sträubte, Euthanasie gut zu finden, aber dann doch so eigenartige Rechtfertigung fand, beziehungsweise sagte, in so einer Schrift, die man dann herausgegeben hat, Anfang der 30er Jahre, um zu beschreiben, warum man gegen Euthanasie ist, schrieb man, erschütternd wie kaum etwas mahnt der Anblick dieser Siechen und Elenden, den Gesunden seinen Leib unversehrt und reinzuerhalten und sich der tiefen Verantwortung bei der Familiengründung bewusst zu werten. Das heißt also, ein Hauptargument dafür, dass man Behinderte am Leben lässt, war, dass sie ein mahnendes, abschreckendes Beispiel sein soll. Also es ist schon wirklich erstaunlich, was sie hier auf wenigen Seiten prägnant noch mal zusammenfasst, aus ihrer Forschung zum Nationalsozialismus und der Forschung allgemein. Und was dann für Parallelen sehr gut heute erkennbar sind in den rechten Diskursen. Und ja, wir sehen dann tatsächlich so etwas wie einen neuen faschistischen Körper.
Ja, das passt auch sehr gut zu diesem Buch, denn ich hatte mir schon zwei Notizen gemacht, warum mich das, worüber ich jetzt rede, interessiert. Zum einen, wir haben eine KI-Debatte, bei der wir uns fragen, Sinnhaftigkeit, Bedürfnisse, Willen hat so mit Körperlichkeit zu tun und die ganze Intelligenz ist dann im Grunde nur Werkzeug und Mechanik, um dem nachzugehen. Aber was ist, wenn man jetzt diesen Ursprung gar nicht hat, wozu dann die Intelligenz? Und das zweite ist natürlich, dass wir in aufgeregten Zeiten sowieso immer so einen Rückzug in den Körper haben. Also Leute machen dann wieder Sport und so um sich, weil Yoga spielt eine Rolle, wie auch immer. Und jetzt hast du natürlich hier noch eine politische Dimension aufgemacht. Also, Giulia Enders hat ein Buch über den Körper geschrieben, organisch. Damals ging es ja um den Darm. Jetzt geht es um so alle. Ich sage mal Lunge, Immunsystem, Haut, Muskeln, Gehirn. Und wir fragen uns, wie hängt das miteinander zusammen? Ah ja, wir haben natürlich grundsätzlich einen politischen Diskurs, in dem gerade niemand so richtig entweichen kann. Und der Körper spielt da einfach auch eine Rolle. Und sie verbindet es ganz explizit, wenn auch nicht als politisch, aber zumindest als allgegenwärtige gesellschaftliche Dimension, die uns alle irgendwie interessiert. Was hat es mit unserem Körper in dieser Gesellschaft auf sich? Also die Lunge steht für unsere Grundbedürfnisse, das Immunsystem für unsere Sicherheit, die Haut für unsere Beziehung, die Muskeln für Kraft und Wirken und das Gehirn natürlich für Denken und Sein. Das ergibt ja erstmal grob Sinn. Und wir haben halt so ein ganzheitliches Konzept, bei dem ich denke, okay, so wie du hier eben auch, mahnende Beispiele werden gebraucht. Man versucht immer eine Ursache zu finden für irgendetwas. Also man hat so ein ganzheitliches, kooperatives Bild. Wenn irgendeine Krankheit auftritt, hat wohl jemand nicht so richtig um sich gekümmert oder wie auch immer. Dann ist es Handlungsbedarf. Und so würde ich sagen, passt dieses Buch organisch wirklich sehr gut. Aber es ist eben durch und durch wohlwollend geschrieben. Also es ist ganz gut gemeint. Es ist richtig so eine Ladung balsam, wenn man sich das so einer Autorin einfach vorlesen lässt, weil sie es eben auch mit ihrer Familiengeschichte verbindet. Das macht sie einfach in jedem Kapitel. Und so kann man das bei der Lunge mal angehen. Also sie hat eine Großmutter Hedwig, die immer so Stimmungsschwankungen zwischen schaffe ich und unschaffe ich, also ich bin hier grad gut drauf, oder nicht. Ihre eigene Mutter energisch schwank sich dann immer aufs Pferd, um zum Bürgermeister zu reiten und solche Sachen. Also da war einiges los damals. Und nach dem Krieg auch die große Abkehr von Politik, Ideologie und mächtigen Menschen. Man hat sich also, und das ist der Bogenschlag zur Physiologie, der Lunge, der stillen Kraft des Weichen verschrieben, sich passiv immer angepasst. So wie die Lunge auch. Einfach an den Rippen aufgehängt. Je nach Bedarf einatmen, ausatmen, völlig andere Zustände zeigt. Also ganz flexibel. Und so geht es dann hier durch beim Immunsystem eben auch. Da hat sie wieder diesen persönlichen Einstieg. Ein Freund Bill, ein Pianist aus Amerika, ein Freund der Oma Hildi, hat also ein Grundstück mit einer sehr dichten Hecke. Diese Hecke ist natürlich zum Schutz geplant gewesen. Und die Frage, die sich hier aber stellt, wenn jetzt meine Oma und der Bill sich begegneten, sind Welten aufeinander getroffen. Denn da kam ihr Kumpel aus diesem dicht behektem Unterschlupf, indem er Sicherheit gerang, ging zur Oma und die hat natürlich an Geburtstagen durch großes Eingebundensein in die örtliche Gemeinschaft 100 bis 200 Gäste da gehabt. So und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, was schützt einem eigentlich mehr? Die totale Abschottung oder die komplette soziale Netzartige Ich fühl mich hier aufgefangen. Alle sind da. Und das Immunsystem geht genau so mit Versuchen der Balance hier einfach rein, weshalb schon mal alle Werbesprüche zum Thema jetzt das Immunsystem stärken. Da sagt sie einfach, also ein starkes Immunsystem ist mal gar nicht so gut. Bei einer Allergie wird einfach jeder Pups von dem Immunsystem ganz wichtig genommen. Bei Autoimmunerkrankungen wird der eigene Körper bekämpft als fremd. Also man will eigentlich gar nicht ein starkes Immunsystem. Man will einfach ein Immunsystem, das sich auskennt, das klug ist, das sich auch verändert, das sich anpasst, wie auch immer. Und so kann sie dann auch endlich mal wieder, ja, kann man jetzt locker über Impfen schreiben. Denn ja, natürlich haben Impfen Nebenwirkungen, kommt dann auch in alle Millionen Fälle mal vor. Da ist einfach ihre Kernaussage, bei den Feinheiten gibt es Raum nach oben. Das heißt aber noch lange nicht, dass die Impfung an sich nicht wirkt. Und wer überhaupt über das Impfen die ganze Zeit reden will, sollte das vielleicht auch erst mal sich selbst gegenüber rechtfertigen. Denn das Immunsystem macht ganz viele Begegnungen mit ganz vielen Sachen und sagt uns darüber nicht Bescheid. Und wenn dann, sagen wir mal, alle drei Millionen Vorfälle mal ein gezieltes, und jetzt geben wir mal eine Spritze dabei ist, dann merkt das das Immunsystem gar nicht, dass jetzt gerade was anders war. Sondern es ist halt einfach nur eine unter vielen und so.
Interessant.
Und wer jetzt was gegen Impfen hat, sollte sich vielleicht beim Immunsystem noch mal nachfragen, ob das Immunsystem, also ob man jetzt für das Immunsystem auch die anderen eine Million Einflüsse mal politisch durchdiskutieren sollte oder nicht. Also sie geht da, macht das sehr gut. Die Haut. Hochinteressant. Also, wir haben es diesmal wieder mit ihrer Oma zu tun. Die hat einen unabgeschickten Brief. Es ist prima, was du alles schaffst, Mückchen. Geh dabei nur nicht zu schnell an den duftenden Blumen des Lebens vorbei. Also der Tenor lautet sei aufmerksam. Aber die Oma hat ihr das nie so gesagt, weil das wäre von Seiten der Oma, wie sie so sagt, so zu übergriffig. Das hätte nicht ihrem naturell gesprochen. Aber es war schon der Omananliegen, zu sagen, pass ein bisschen auf, seh die Augenblicke, die sich bieten, wie auch immer. Und der Brückenschlag zur Haut ist hier, so laufen wir herum in unserer Haut und verbergen darunter, wie nass, feucht, verletzlich und blutig wir sie wirklich sind. Und jetzt stellt sich die Frage, beschützt die Haut uns vor der Welt oder die Welt vor uns? Also wie sähe eigentlich die Welt aus, wenn wir alle als Blutlache und so weiter? Sondern wer beschützt eigentlich wen und wie funktioniert das? Und jetzt ein Wahnsinnsargument oder eine richtig tolle Pointe. Die oberste Hautschicht, die wir haben, ist, also sie kann nicht bluten, sie kann auch nicht groß verletzt werden, dafür braucht man dann schon tieferer Schnitte. Viren prallen einfach an ihr ab. Sie ist auch relativ, also sie ist schmerzfrei. Schmerz braucht auch erst, da muss man schon auf die unteren Hautschichten. Woran liegt das? Keine Nerven, keine Venen, keine Arterien. Naja, die Pointe ist, die oberste Hautschicht ist einfach tot. Das, was uns von der Gesellschaft sozusagen fernhält und an einer gesunden Distanz ist der Tod, der Tod selbst. Und wenn jetzt irgendwer kommt und sagt, ja, man kann so Gesichtsbehandlung machen, wo die oberste Hautschicht und so weiter, dann erneuert die sich. Nee, man kratzt einfach die tote Hautschicht einmal ab und danach muss halt eine neue Rinde draufgelegt werden, also legt der Körper eine neue tote Schicht drauf. So, ja, also es ist einfach, es ist der Tod. Fand ich sehr gut. Wir haben also eine Balance zwischen Sensibilität und Schutz, der immer wieder neu justiziert werden, eingerichtet werden muss. Und dann hat sie so ein paar kleine Spielereien, auch mit der Sprache, das Prinzip Hornhaut. Wird ja heute noch relativ häufiger für das Gefühlslieben, als für die echte Hornhaut benutzt. Brauchst du einfach eine Hornhaut und so. Das Bindegewebe, das ist wirklich ein Spektakel. Also ohne Bindegewebe würde der Körper formlos und suppenartig auf dem Boden liegen, sagt sie. Und reflektiert in ihrer Branche, in ihrem Milieu, in der Medizin, geht es immer darum, ja, bist du jetzt nur ein Chirurg für normale Organe oder schon Neurochirurg, darfst du im Gehirn rumschnippeln, ja. Dann wenn nee, nur verlebe und so, wie auch immer. Also so interpretiere ich das, was sie hier schreiben. Und der Tenor ist, alle haben immer so einen Zug zu den Protagonisten, aber das, was die Welt eigentlich zusammenhält, wird immer übersehen. Und sie selber macht diesen Punkt, dass wir immer so auf den Neurochirurgen ran. Und ich denke mir so, ja, das ist so ein bisschen wie mein Argument bei der Kommunalpolitik. Alle wollen immer Bundesliga spielen. Also, ich bin Journalist für Neuro. Ich kümmere mich nur ums Kanzleramt. Allenfalls vielleicht die SPD, auch wenn sie in der Opposition ist, aber eigentlich nur Kanzleramt und so. Und ich denke mir so, ja, aber schau dir doch mal das Bindegewebe an. Also 80 Großstädte mit Oberbürgermeistern und dann 160 Landräte wie hier rüber und so. Also diese Analogie finde ich sehr gut. Was ich nicht wusste, ist, dass unsere Alterung auf der Hautoberfläche zu 80 Prozent durch die Sonne verursacht wird. Ja, wenn du Anti-Aging machen willst, Sonnencreme, sehr dick und reflektierend, nicht nur biologisch, aber das ist auch ganz gut.
Trage ich jeden Tag auf.
Sehr gut, dabei hast du schon alles erledigt. So, ja.
Da wird mitunter gelacht, dass ich das immer mache.
Ich mach das auch immer.
Ich trage es.
Bei dem Wetter nicht.
Doch, ja, das ist der Punkt, Stefan. Da wird es erst interessant.
Bei dem Wetter bin ich nur fünf Minuten draußen. Ich hänge nicht stundenlang.
Nein, man fährt vielleicht dann auch mal mit dem Auto oder so, da kommt auch Sonne, das wird nicht abgehalten. Jeden Tag ins Gesicht. Also muss ich den ganzen Körper einhalten.
Du bist besonders gut da, aber ja.
Ja, das sind die Tipps vom Profi hier.
Also da freut sich deine Haut darüber. Das Aging-Wirrwarr kann man sich nämlich schenken, wenn man...
Und generell wenig in die Sonne gehen.
Ja. So, nun zurück zur Medizin. Genau, wenig in die Sonne, das sagt sie. Also Schatten schlägt alles. Sonnencreme ist manchmal tricky. Gut, das Fühlen. Wir haben in unserem Bindegewebe so kleine Fasern, die entladen sich wie Knallbonbons bei Berührung und melden sofort ans Gehirn. Das habe ich ja in der Alten Republik auch. Also da findet kein Umweg über Bewusstsein statt oder so. Das auch sehr wichtig finde ich für eine politische Debatte. Körperliche Gefühle, also durch körperliche, gerade gefühlsreißer ausgelöste Gefühle, sind jetzt mit politischen Diskussionen schwer einherzukommen. Weshalb die politische Diskussion zum Thema Rechtsradikalismus ein abstrahiertes Ekelgefühl sehr ernst zu nehmen ist. Und wie ist das jetzt hier bei Berührung? Wir berühren uns gegenseitig und wenn wir uns wohl gemeint begegnen, dann machen wir das mit Bewegungen von drei Zentimetern pro Sekunde. Das ist das Signal ans Gehirn, dass es hier gerade gut zugeht. Es ist nicht so sehr die Fläche oder der Druck, sondern es ist diese Geschwindigkeit. Das fand ich sehr interessant. Dann hat sie so einen Punkt. Man hat Neugeborene, die zu früh kamen, immer in so Brutkästen gelegt und ist dann relativ spät darauf umgegangen zu sagen, wir machen so viel Hautkontakt mit der Mutter wie möglich. Man hat dann rausgefunden bei diesen Frühchen, das, was der Kontakt mit der Mutter, der Haut, dem Frühchen gibt. Wenn man das als Medikament machen würde, wäre das ein atemberaubender Erfolg. Also, es ist am Ende wieder der Körper selbst. Und es gibt eine interpersonelle Synchronisation. Ich meine, ich habe jetzt auch viel über Oxytocin und so geschrieben, aber ich bin ja kein Mediziner. Sie sagt, wenn sich zwei Menschen wohlmeinend berühren, dann gleichen sich Atemfrequenz, Herzschlag und die elektrische Leitfähigkeit der Haut einander an. Wir wissen nicht, warum das passiert, aber es passiert. Also, eine Menschenkette im Sinne von, wir halten das jetzt durch, kann eine halbe Stunde dauern, wir nehmen uns jetzt alle in die Hand und so. Könnte auch noch mal ein Programmpunkt sein. Ich hatte das beim Immunsystem schon mal gelesen, dass, wenn Menschen sich einen Haushalt teilen, dass sich das Immunsystem so einander angleicht, weil ja alle den gleichen Reizen ausgesetzt sind, aber dass es hier unmittelbare, körperliche Synchronisation gibt, sehr gut. Die Muskeln kriegen natürlich ein großes Kapitel, weil ihre Mutter, die SSU-bereiterin, Marathonläuferin, Kraft, ja, sie strotzte vor Kraft. Das ist dann die Analogie. Mit schmerzenden Füßen kann man weiterlaufen, nicht aber mit gebrochenem Rückgrat. Das ist auch Familienweisheiten, die man hier hört. Also Stärke, Entspannung, sie macht einen großen Punkt. Ich bin über das Buch gekommen, weil ich auf Instagram so ein paar Videos gesehen hatte, wie sie Interviews gibt, wo sie zum Beispiel, passt auch zur Lunge, die Raucherpause. Wird dann immer kritisiert, als da raucht jemand Zigaretten. Aber was ja eigentlich passiert ist, jemand nimmt sich eine Pause von seinem Alltag und macht eine Atemübung. Natürlich dann mit Gift versetzt. Aber es ist ja trotzdem noch eine Pause vom Alltag, wo man so richtig sagt, ich geh mal kurz einen rauchen. Und keiner fragt nach, wie lässt du uns den Stich? Haben wir dich verärgert oder was auch immer? Sondern nee, er geht halt rauchen. So, keiner denkt weiter drüber nach. Also man ist sofort in einem anderen Moment und man macht eine Atemübung. Bewusst ist ein und außer.
Aber sie empfiehlt das jetzt nicht.
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Es geht nur um, was so alles dazugehört, wenn man es jetzt mal gesamtzeitlich betrachtet. Also macht sie auch nicht im Buch. Sie wollte nur sagen, das hat sie halt darauf verwiesen. Aber dieser Pausenaspekt, der spielt hier noch mal eine ganz große Rolle. Du bist ja jetzt wieder sportlich engagiert. Deswegen lasst dir gesagt sein, Entspannung ist nicht nichts, sondern dann eher alles. Alle Vorteile von Sport passieren in dem Moment der Erholung. Bevor ist einfach Belastung. Alle Systeme werden gestresst. Danach, alles wird verursacht durch Sport. Über Sport schreibt sie sehr viel und sehr gut. Aber es ist diese Pause. Die hochgelobten Effekte von körperlichen Bewegungen passieren fast ausnahmslos in der Ruhezeit danach. Plus, wenn man sich das gezielt, man kann auch noch mal über den Tag reflektieren, wie auch immer, wenn man immer mal kleine Pausen einlegt. Ich habe natürlich auch für Stefan Kühl damals eine Hausarbeit geschrieben über die Bedeutung der Pause. Also im Unterricht, was bedeutet eigentlich die Pause? Und die Pausen sind immer so ein kleiner Reset auch, wo sich alle noch mal gegen den Lehrer verschwören und erst dann richtig Gemeinschaft bilden oder wie auch immer. Dafür braucht man immer Pausen. Und so ist das hier beim Körper auch. Dass der Körper schläft, ist nicht unbedeutend. Man braucht einfach eine Pause. Außerdem verweist sie aber noch mal an Sport. Passt sich der Körper an. Wer wirklich abnehmen möchte, muss alle Einflussfaktoren und damit ist vor allem auch Ernährung gemeint nehmen. Ansonsten war es das nämlich nicht. Also hier ist einfach sehr gut. Und nun das Gehirn. Das Gehirn ist ihre Schwester, denn sie hat festgestellt, sie schreibt ja die Bücher und ihre Schwester malt immer dazu. Und so wie diese Arbeitsteilung ist, haben sie wohl ihr ganzes Leben so ein bisschen aufgeteilt. Man hat immer festgestellt, okay, ihr ist so beides. Denken und sein mit verschiedenen Schwerpunkten. Und so wie sie die Pause beim Sport, kommt ja auch noch mal der Schlaf für das Gehirn. Das Schlaf ist so hart reset, dass man sich, also klar, wir haben alle irgendwie so das Thema Schlaf kommt immer wieder, aber man muss sich immer wieder bewusst werden, wie wichtig es dann doch ist, so wie...
Sagt sie was wie lang? Wie lange man schlafen muss? Da gehen ja immer die Meinungen dann doch etwas auseinander.
Nee, es ist kein Ratgeberbuch.
Es ist kein Ratgeberbuch, sieh mich mal.
Du findest jetzt nicht, du findest beim Thema Gehirn, beim Schlafen andere Verweise. Ich gehe hier mal wieder auf die Analogie-Ebene, die mich so interessiert. Also sie hat sich darüber gewundert, dass sie immer so angesprochen wird als die große Buchautorin, während sie das Buch mit ihrer Schwester entwickelte und die auch mit ihren Bildern da drin und Grafiken wirklich für die Veranschaulichung sorgte, also für sehr viel Verständnis auf Seiten des Publikums. Aber warum wird sie immer angesprochen als Autorin? Weil man natürlich immer sagt, das ist die eigentliche intelligente Leistung, wie auch immer. Das andere ist ja nur Zuarbeit. Und so fragt sie auch, ist das Gehirn eigentlich immer der Chef? Und wenn es immer der Chef ist, warum ist er Chef? Naja, weil er die Spitze in der Hierarchie ist, also muss man doch die ganzen anderen Körperfunktionen, die kann man ja einfach rausrechnen. So, was ist schon der Chef ohne, was sind die Milliardäre und ihre Mitarbeiter? Ja, so ungefähr. Nur diese hierarchische Sichtweise, dass man dann auch immer so von der grauen Eminenz spricht und so, geht, wie sie sagt, eben völlig an dieser, wie man es ganzheitlich und balanciert betrachten müsste, vorbei. Auch beim Thema Schlaf. Und das ist dann die Ebene, auf der das Buch operiert. Der Schlaf ist ein Machtwechsel. Plötzlich übernehmen die Organe und so weiter. Und das Gehirn ist also kurz vor Tod. So, ja, so in die Richtung geht es. Und es ist wirklich eine Freude, das einfach zu lesen. Das Gehirn wird geboren und ist im Grunde, wir sind im Zustand eines Affen. Nach zwei Jahren, okay, wir können es als Mensch klassifizieren. Nochmal weitere 23 Jahre. Jemand ist 25 Jahre alt. Okay, wir können so richtig auf Augenhöhe miteinander und so. Also es sind alles langwierige Prozesse. Es ist wirklich toll. Schlaf ist, wie sie vergleicht es hier so mit Urlaub, Tiefschlaf. Tiefschlaf ist einfach Urlaub. Der Tiefschlaf zeigt uns, was wir in einem schönen Urlaub zu ahnen beginnen. Ohne die ganzen Einflüsse von der Welt da draußen ist das Leben ein friedliches Hauchen mit entspanntem Gesicht. Also Schlaf einfach als das Komplette ausgeschaltet sein. Und dann kommt sie auf den Kruschtil, Samstag zu sprechen. Der Tiefschlaf wirkt für den Körper wie für uns und Samstag, wo wir alle Aufgaben erledigen, die völlig normal jetzt mal gemacht werden müssen. Und nicht von außen diktiert oder wie auch immer. Also dieses Wechselspiel aus, das Gehirn ist nur etwas, wenn es seine Macht komplett abgibt. Wenn es kurz vor Tod in einem Bewusstleinszustand ist, dann kann man davon sprechen, wenn man den Zyklus einhält, dass irgendwo mal eine Entwicklung stattfindet. Also ich hatte immer wieder diese tollen Analogien zur gesellschaftlichen Entwicklung, die sie dann und ich dachte so, okay, das erschöpft sich hier schon sehr gut. Das ist toll. Und dann wird es eben unten noch mal strapaziert. Ein Punkt noch zu den Gefühlen. Wir haben ja auch über Eva Illoues das Gefühlekapitel und so. Vielleicht macht es echt noch mal Sinn, das auch wirklich aus einer medizinischen Sicht von einer an Gesellschaft teilnehmenden jungen Frau zu betrachten und so. Weiß ich ja noch mal, während sie bei vielen anderen Sachen so eine Balance immer sucht, ist bei einem Gefühlskapitel völlig klar, dass Verstand und bewusstes Wissen sind in unserer Entwicklung nicht hinzugekommen, um unsere Emotionen abzulösen. Sie haben allenfalls eine Assistenzfunktion. Also, dass die Gefühle, die das Eigentliche sind und Wissen, Bewusstsein, aktives Arbeiten, was auch immer, das ist sozusagen ganz klar nachrangig dem zugeordnet, wenn ich unterstellt, ich musste dann wieder an Stefanie Stahl, wie sie im Allesgesagt-Podcast sagt einfach, also, sich selber mit den Emotionen im Clan und reflektiert zu sein und Trump wählen, das geht gar nicht. Was halt bedeutet, wenn Trump tatsächlich 81 Millionen Wähler überzeugt, für ihn zu stimmen, dann nützt uns die Katastrophe der Quantität gar nichts, dann haben einfach 81 Millionen Menschen in Amerika Redebedarf. Und dem sollte man dann auch nachkommen, um stattdessen einfach aus der Straße auszuleben und zu sagen, ihr könnt jetzt einfach bei Eis eintreten und Leute verprügeln. Ja, also so, da ist sie auch ganz hart. Sie hat ja noch so einen kleinen christlichen Satz, den fand ich sehr gut, zu den 200 typischsten Denkfehler, die wir so haben. Also das Gehirn hat eine emotionale, sagen wir mal, Realität, an der man sich orientiert. Und darüber hinaus wird so intellektuell und mit IQ, wie wir es eben auch schon gelesen haben, so versucht, die Sachen irgendwie am Laufen zu halten. Aber man stolpert von einem Denkfehler in den nächsten, also Kahnemann und so weiter. Nobelpreise wurden vergeben. Und sie macht hier so einen kleinen historischen, katholischen Satz, der sehr gut ist. Gott als Wesen zu betrachten, das sich mit Ablassbriefen kaufen lässt, ist ein ganz bizarrer Gedanke. Da dachte ich so, das stimmt, das sollte man echt normal ganz viel drüber nachdenken, was so jahrhundertelang und alle Menschen betreffend grundsätzlich immer los ist. Also es gibt, sagen wir mal so, 200 typische Denkfehler, die werden schon aufkummuliert bei so Sachen, die wir sehen. Na ja. Und dann am Ende hat sie, als ich schon dachte, okay, das ist sehr toll, so geschrieben, hat sie die Frage, was kostet ein Mensch? Wenn man ein Auge bauen würde, 576 Megapixel, Autofokus, Lichtempfindlichkeit, 3 Millionen Euro, relativ kostengünstig. Eine Lunge hat man ja schon gebaut, also während Corona, Beatmung außerhalb des Körpers und eine sauerstoffreiche Blut zurückgepumpt. 500.000 Euro Herz, 500.000 Euro Leber, schon eine Million. Darm und Nieren, noch mal eine Million. Knochen, Gelenke, bis zu 10 Millionen. Haut, können auch so 10 Millionen Euro kosten. Muskulatur, da sind wir schon bei 100 Millionen. Nervensysteme, Hormone, Gefäße, 500 Millionen, alles zusammen. Also ein Organoid, würde man echte Zellen, biologische Strukturen, inklusiv Bewusstsein und so. Wir sind bei 10 Billionen Euro. Was einfach heißt, das was der Finanzmarkt an einem Tag durchjagt, so ungefähr. Also wir sind, es geht um alle Kunstwerke der Welt, um die zehn größten Konzerne der Welt, müssten komplett ihr Kapital nur in dieses eine Projekt, das man so ein Mensch herstellt. Merkst schon, worauf es hinausgeht. Wie fühlt sich der Gedanke an, dass wir das Wertvollste, was ein Mensch besitzen kann, schon längst haben, dass wir selbst sind. Das finde ich, das klingt so kitschig auf der einen Seite, aber das ist die Frage, die man auch diesen ganzen Milliardären stellen muss.
Die wollen ja gerne darüber hinaus.
Was wollt ihr? Ihr habt doch schon alles.
Dann wollen sie noch mal über andere Menschen in jeder Hinsicht verfügen und dann wollen sie sich selbst verewigen und nicht mehr sterben.
Genau. Also euer Körper ist 10 Billionen wert. Ob ihr jetzt noch so eine Milliarde habt, ist ja unentscheidend. Mit einem klaren Körper kann man wenig verbriefen. Das ist natürlich auch eine Arbeitsmarktdebatte, finde ich. Also kommt so eine 10-Billionen-Euro-Maschine reinmarschiert und hier 1.900 Euro netto. Also sehr gutes Buch. Es ist wirklich eine Freude. Es ist wirklich jeder Satz zumindest interessant, wenn nicht sogar, dass man so, das ist so wichtig schon wieder. Also man weiß auch gar nicht, ich habe es so gehört und habe so mitgeschrieben, dachte mir so, eigentlich müsste man das noch mal, keine Ahnung, in ein größeres Projekt irgendwie einweben, dass man hier noch mal so ein, so wie du, ja, schon die Interessanz des Körpers allein durch faschistische Politik, ja, aber Körper und Politik in der Systemtheorie, ganze Gesellschaftstheorie abgeleitet aus symbiotischen Mechanismen, weil Körper Bedarfe haben und sich koordinieren müssen und sich immer wieder gegenseitig überraschen und so weiter und so fort. Also es geht so in so viele Richtungen. Sie hat dann am Ende so ein Satz, niemals sollte eine Antwort aus dem Körper die Einzige sein und niemals sollten wir Körperliches bei unseren Antworten völlig vergessen. Also auch da wieder diesen Mittelweg zu finden und so. Wirklich sehr gut, kann ich sehr empfehlen.
Thomas Wagner beschäftigt sich mit der Frage, muss es immer der Nationalstaat sein? Sein Buch heißt Wege aus der Gewaltimpulse für ein neues politisches Denken. Vor mehr als 5000 Jahren, da gab es zwar Gewalt, aber Kriege im Sinne dessen, was wir heute darunter verstehen, also nicht nur zwischenstaatlich, sondern generell so größere Gruppen, gehende aufeinander los. Das ist doch vielleicht eher nicht das, was da anzutreffen ist. Das heißt, wir haben dort schon Gewalt. Aber es ist vor allem die Selbsthaftwerdung, die Krieg produziert, was auch bedeutet, also ehe moderne Staaten gegründet sind, gibt es natürlich schon Krieg. Aber durch den Nationalstaat intensiviert sich diese Gewalt. Dann intensivieren sich diese Kriege. Er beginnt sein Buch damit, dass er auf eine Debatte aus dem Jahr 1985 eingeht. Da ist der Politikwissenschaftler Eckehard Krippendorf. Und der legt ein Buch vor, das heißt Staat und Krieg. Und sagt, es gibt da diese fatale Logik, dass der Staat diese Kriege produziert, dem widerspricht jemand wie Herfried Münkler schon. Also wir sind dann in alten Debatten, aber zum Teil sind die Leute noch heute da. Und der Herfried Münkler sagt dann, naja, da gibt es generell in den Menschen so eine Kriegsbereitschaft. Belligerenz nennt er das. Und das können wir nun in der Geschichte sehen. Aber wenn man sich eben auf die Geschichte weiter zurück konzentriert als jetzt die vergangenen 5.000 Jahre, dann ist das Bild nicht mehr so klar. Wagner schreibt in den vorherigen 99 Prozent der Gattungsgeschichte, gab es zwar auch vereinzelt Gewalt, aber eben nicht in dieser organisierten und gehäuften Form. Die Frage, also die sich hier stellt, hilft der Staat tatsächlich dabei, eine Gesellschaft und auch die Welt zu befrieden? Oder sorgen die Staaten eher dafür, dass die Gewalt zunimmt? Letzteres ist wohl das, was man eher erkennen kann, zumal ja auch gesehen werden muss, der Frieden nach Inneren ist ja auch häufig ein sehr repressiver Frieden, wie wir jetzt in den USA gerade am allerdeutlichsten sehen, aber natürlich auch hier mit Polizei, Gewalt und so etwas, uns alles gut vorstellen können. Die Frage ist also, wo wäre eine Alternative zu einer Organisation der Gesellschaft, die nicht nationalstaatlich ist? Es ist so, dass der Staat nicht als die Lösung begriffen werden muss, sondern als Teil des Problems. Wagner schaut sich nun föderative Strukturen an, statt eines zentralen Staats, um zu zeigen, dass es auch durchaus Gegenkonzepte gibt. Gegenkonzepte auch zu dem, was jetzt zum Beispiel jemand, den ich das letzte Mal vorgestellt hatte, als wir über Davos geredet haben, wie Brandon Sims sich ausgedacht hat. Wir brauchen jetzt den Superstaat, den Europa-Staat und dann können wir für mehr Frieden und Sicherheit sorgen. Gibt es auch vielleicht kleinere Organisationswege? Wir haben es hier mit einem Autor zu tun, der sich mit Craver und anderen beschäftigt, der auch weiß, wie anders Gesellschaften organisiert sind, der auch einen ethnologischen Blick einnehmen kann. Er zeigt auch, wie Konfliktforschung ganz anders aussehen kann, als das, was wir heute haben. Er spricht beispielsweise über die Nuwea, das ist eine Ethnie in Südsodan. Und die haben eine interessante Praxis zur Schlichtung. Also bei Tötungsdelikten wird eigentlich ja dann so ein unmittelbarer Fedemechanismus in Gang gesetzt. Das heißt, die einen bekriegen dann die anderen. Aber es gibt da auch eine Institution, mit der in anderer Weise Konflikte geschlichtet werden können. Und zwar ist es so, dass der Täter die Möglichkeit hat, Zuflucht im Haus eines Leopardenfellhäublings zu suchen. Das heißt, der Täter des Gewaltaktes kann in dieses Haus. Da heißt es, der Häubling wartete einige Wochen ab, bis sich die Gemüter beruhigt hatten und eröffnet dann die Schadensersatzverhandlungen zwischen den Angehörigen von Täter und Opfer. Bei einem Tötungsdelikt lag der zu zahlende Betrag bei 40 oder 50 Kühen. Der Häubling agierte nicht als Entscheidungsinstanz, sondern als Vermittler, Zitat dessen man sich auch nur dann bedient, wenn beide Parteien zu einem Abkommen gelangen und den vorherigen Stand der Dinge wiederherstellen wollen. Der Häubling fordert eine Seite zu einem Vorschlag auf, der von der anderen in der Regel abgelehnt wird. Schließlich drängt er eine Partei, den Vorschlag der anderen anzunehmen, was diese mit oft zu Schau gestellten Wiederwillen tut, wobei sie darauf beharrt, sie tue es nur dem Häubling zuliebe. Mit anderen Worten, der Häubling bietet einen Weg, auf dem man sein Gesicht wahren und einen Kompromiss, der zum Wohle der Gemeinschaft notwendig ist, finden kann. Er geht noch auf weitere solche, ja, doch ganz kreativen Lösungen ein, wie Konflikte, ja, beschwichtigt werden können, wie Frieden wiederhergestellt werden kann. Aber es soll nicht nur darum gehen, wie kann man eine andere Form der Diplomatie wagen, sondern wie könnte man auch anders Gesellschaft organisieren. Er bringt das Beispiel der Post. Da gibt es ja zum Beispiel keine supranationale Struktur, mit der alles geregelt ist, sondern wenn ich jetzt einen Brief schicke von hier nach China, dann kann ich sehr davon ausgehen, dass diese auch ankommt. Bedeutet also, wir haben hier zwar komplexe Infrastruktur, die aber nicht unbedingt eine staatliche Ordnung braucht und trotzdem funktioniert. Wir haben eher so ein System, in dem sich verschiedene Konföderationen, so sagen wir mal Postorganisationen zusammengeschlossen haben. Was jetzt für ihn wichtig ist, ist, diese Opposition zu machen zwischen Staat und föderaler Struktur, Föderalismus. Denn so eine föderale Struktur bedeutet, dass sich da freiwillig Leute zusammengeschlossen haben, während wir ja als Staatsbürger nicht mal gefragt wurden, wollen wir das eigentlich so oder so. Die Referenz für ihn ist jetzt zum einen der Kurdenführer Öcalan, der als er inhaftiert wird, plötzlich anfängt, den Theoretiker Muray Bookchin zu lesen. Und darüber löst sich Öcalan von einer leninistischen Vorstellung von Staat, also als Ordnungsprinzip, und denkt über das von Muray Bookchin vorgeschlagene Prinzip der Konföderation nach. Dieser demokratische Konföderationismus ist als politisches Modell zu verstehen, in dem verschiedene Minderheiten, Religionsgemeinschaften, kulturelle und geschlechtliche Gruppen miteinander leben können. Und dieses Projekt ist, so Öcalan, so aufgebaut als kommunale Selbstverwaltung, die sich in Form von Bürgerversammlungen, Kommunen, Gemeinden, Kommunalparlamenten und Volkskongressen organisiert. Nicht staatliche Behörden sind der Träger dieser Selbstverwaltung, sondern die Bürger sind es, die das verwalten. Interessant ist nun, dass auch Daniel Grabber sich damit beschäftigt hatte und sich mit Öcalan auseinandersetzte und sagte, das sei wirklich erstaunlich, was da passiert sei. Grabber schreibt, vielleicht das erste Mal in der Geschichte, dass der Führer einer vertikal strukturierten politischen Bewegung von der Sorte, die diesen immer auch als ersten Theoretiker betrachtet, sich dazu entscheidet, seine theoretischen Schriften zu benutzen, um seine Anhänger zur Ablehnung dieses Modells zu bringen. Dafür, wie das gehen könnte, gab es keinen echten Präzedenzfall. Thomas Wagner kommt dann darauf zu sprechen, dass das aber nicht nur eine Sache von Ötcherland ist, sondern interessanterweise zaubert er an mehreren Stellen den doch arke konservativen Historiker Michael Wolfson aus dem Hut, der interessanterweise auch immer wieder konfederale Modelle vorschlägt. Für die Ukraine oder auch für Nahost hatte er solche Dinge schon gebracht. Also auch eine Ordnung jenseits des Nationalstaates. Wenn ich das aber so sage, muss ich vielleicht gleich einwenden und sehe da auch eine gewisse Schwäche im Buch, dass doch bei dieser Idee, man macht eigentlich eine Bundesrepublik Ukraine mit den verschiedenen Teilen, also da gibt es den russischen Teil und dann diesen Teil und diesen Teil, sich ja auch immer noch die Frage stellt, aber was ist darüber noch mal übergeordnet? Also gibt es dann bei einer Bundesrepublik doch noch mal eine staatliche Ordnung? Gibt es also mehr, was man vom Staat wegdelegieren kann, aber am Ende und so scheint es dann doch an einigen Stellen, bleibt der Staat für so etwas wie Sicherheit hauptsächlich zuständig, wo ich dann aber sagen würde, naja, dann hat man zwar den Nationalstaat verschlankt auf ein konfederales Modell, hat aber damit ja die entscheidenden Dinge, die ja auch relevant sind, wenn wir über Krieg sprechen, nämlich Sicherheit, ja dann doch noch beim Staat belassen. Er kommt auch dann im Zuge, auch wenn die sich alle wahrscheinlich nicht gut riechen könnten, auf Omri Böhm zu sprechen, der ja auch so ein konfederales Modell eigentlich vorschlägt für Israel, was er da in seinem Buch ausbuchstabiert hat. Die Idee ist also jetzt hier von Wagner, dass man durchaus anders über Organisationen von großen Menschengruppen nachdenken kann. Auch auf Rojava kommt er zu sprechen. Aber auch hier bei all der Pluralität, die gegeben ist, muss dann auch Thomas Wagner selbst eingestehen. Dadurch, dass es diese äußeren Bedrohungen dann bei Rojava gibt, durch die Türkei nicht zuletzt auch, haben wir es dann doch damit zu tun, dass diese Organisation sich immer mehr eigentlich in einen Staat verwandelt. Zudem ist es ja auch durch die Unterstützung der USA wird das aufrechterhalten. Und so ist dann für mich die Frage, ob eigentlich diese Idee jenseits des Staates zu denken hier eingelöst wird, wenn wir doch am Ende sagen, als so ein grobes Gerüst brauchen wir ihn dann doch. Also vielleicht sollte man da eigentlich noch einen Schritt weitergehen oder schauen, wo mit einer anarchistischen Theorie oder so möglicherweise man weiterkommt. Weil ich sage, diese Ideen von Wolfsson und so ist interessant, dass man dann bei Böhm Parallelen da finden kann, obwohl die sonst wenig miteinander gemein haben. Würde aber doch behaupten, dass wir damit der staatlichen Logik nicht so richtig entkommen können.
Nee, das würde ich auch mal sagen. Außerdem haben sie ein bisschen mit der Pointe vielleicht gespielt, dass die Gewalt überhaupt nur der Grund ist, warum es Staat gibt. Also der Staat ist ja die befriedende Instanz, die es ermöglicht innerhalb von Staaten, dritte Streitschlichter, Richter, Leute, also so, denen ein formales Gerüst zu geben, bei dem es am Ende heißt, falls hier jemand zuschlagen möchte, ein Gewaltmonopol liegt beim Staat. Genau, also der Staat bleibt unsichtbar, bis Gewalt auftaucht, um sie dann einzuhägen. Was wir heute sehen, ist ja eine Perversion, dass der Staat selbst als Institution missbraucht wird, von Leuten, die null Leistung da reingebracht haben, dass wir so ein soziales Gefüge haben, sondern diese einfach für sich ausbeuten. Und dann, wenn man da hinweist, das kann man nicht auf Dauer stellen. Also was wir jetzt in Amerika sehen, kann man nicht auf Dauer stellen.
Ja, und da wäre ich mir nicht so sicher. Denn ich würde festhalten, dass der Staat immer solche Gewalt ausübt, nur ist das jetzt hier besonders explizit und laut und so etwas.
Ja, der Staat schlägt dich nicht auf der Straße zusammen.
Nein, genau, das macht er normalerweise in dieser…
Ja, normalerweise.
Ja, das macht er dann da. Aber sonst ist er ja auch im hohen Maße gewaltsam. Also weil ich ja weiß, dass wenn ich zum Beispiel Gesetze übertrete, er dann kommt. Er schlägt mich dann vielleicht nicht auf der Straße zusammen, aber er bringt mich ins Gefängnis, was auch nicht angenehm ist.
Aber der Staat ist gewaltsam und ist auch zu kritisieren unter den Benefits, dass niemand sonst gewaltsam ist.
Genau, das ist die Idee des Gewaltmonopols. Aber hier geht es ja tatsächlich auch um die Frage, kann man dem Gewaltmonopol des Staates entkommen? Und wäre das über eine zentrale, über eine nicht zentrale Regierungsorganisation möglich, dann stellt sich aber auch die Frage, wie schließen die sich zusammen? Weil ja, es verschiedene Ideen gibt. Also wenn ich jetzt sage, ich gehe da jetzt mit ethnischen Kriterien dran, dann kann ich dann sagen, und da sind die Russisch sprechenden Ukrainer die bildende Einheit. Aber ich bilde ja mit denen auch. Also das ist ja genau unser Thema, wo wir uns nicht darauf einlassen würden. Wir würden ja nicht sagen, wir machen das jetzt wie Maximilian Krah und sagen, ja, wir haben jetzt hier diesen Staat Deutschland, aber wir Deutschen, wir müssen sehen, dass wir größtmögliche Distanz haben zu jenen, die eingewandert sind, zwar eine Staatsbürgerschaft haben und eingewandert sind. Und bei mir ist dieses Organisationsmodell, das dann vorgeschlagen wurde, also einfach auf einer kleineren Ebene, da ist mir nicht klar, ob man wirklich davon profitieren kann. Vielleicht bin ich aber auch zu libertär dafür.
Also für mich wirkt dieses Buch, ich habe es jetzt nicht gelesen.
Jetzt werden manche erschrocken sein, dass ich libertär sage, aber ich habe natürlich so einen großen individualistischen Drang in mir und sehe mich auch nicht in der Konföderation im Sinne von jetzt sind wir hier alle gleichgesinnt.
Es gibt sehr viele Leute, die den Staat ersetzen wollen und spätestens der dritte Gedanke ist dann, egal ob man in der Bitcoin-Blase oder bei irgendwelchen Neufeudalistischen, die unternehmen sollen, es lösen dann wie auch immer, dass Sicherheit ein Problem ist, das dann nicht mehr gelöst wird. Es gibt keine libertäre, feudalistische, historische, fantastische Idee, in der das nicht beobachtet wird. Und ich möchte nur anwergen, wenn auf einem Buchtitel Gewalt und Staat steht.
Nein, es steht nicht da. Wege aus der Gewalt, Impulse für neues politisches Denken.
Genau, aber es wird ja dann sehr viel über Staat.
Ja, ja, es soll um Staat gehen.
Für das eigentliche Problem, das man behandeln möchte, in der Soziologie immer Gewalt, ist der Staat bisher die Lösung.
Historisch? Nee.
Materiell?
Aber nicht bezogen auf Kriege. Weil bezogen auf Kriege kann man ganz eindeutig sagen, dass mit den Staaten die Kriege zugenommen haben und sich intensiviert haben.
Ja, aber...
Also das ist ja ein Problem. Du meinst ja jetzt auf der Ebene, dass ich nicht den Revolver raushole, wenn ich was zu klären habe, sondern ein Vorgericht ziehen kann.
Also die Pointe ist doch wirklich super easy. Wir haben doch failed states sozusagen. Also Orte, in denen keine Staatlichkeit ist. Flächendeckend in Afghanistan.
Ja, das ist diese Wanzes Fukuyama-These. Wir müssen nur ganz viel Nation Building machen und dann kommt Frieden. Aber das stimmt nicht.
Also wir können natürlich jetzt von außen beobachten und sagen, Afghanistan ist gerade in einem Zustand, in dem es für andere Länder nicht kriegerisch bedrohlich ist. Ja, schon klar. Weil wie soll man zum Krieg kommen, wenn man intern mit Gewalt, wenn Gewalt das einzige Problem ist am Tag, das man löst. So klar sind diese.
Nein, er geht ja in der Geschichte zurück, so wie Graeber das auch tut oder wir haben das ja bei den Anfängen gelesen. Da geht es ja darum zu sagen, es gab also Organisationen von größeren Menschen, Gruppen, die nicht gegeneinander Kriege geführt haben. Dann kommt aber der Nationalstaat. Plötzlich gibt es andere Parameter, andere Ideen, die verteidigt werden müssen. Dann geht man tausend Kilometer entfernt von zu Hause wohin, weil irgendeine Grenze wo verschoben wurde. Man denkt, warum kämpfe ich jetzt eigentlich gerade diesen Krieg? Und das ist ja etwas, was mit dem Staat kommt. Und deswegen ist ja dieser Ansatz genau richtig zu sagen, wie kann ich eigentlich dann etwas anderes jenseits des Staates denken, wenn wir gerade sehen, dass die Staaten, und es gibt ja mehr Staaten denn je auf der Welt, dass diese Staaten gar nicht dazu führen, dass die Welt befriedet wird, sondern dass Staaten gegenseitig sich bekriegen. Und da ist die Frage, und wir auch wissen, dass wir uns ja gar nicht mit denen, wie du ja heute mehrfach betont hast, mit den Regierungen dieser Staaten gemein machen wollen. Wir identifizieren uns ja nicht mit den Leutchen da in Davos. Und da ist ja schon die Frage berechtigt, wie könnte man über den Nationalstaat hinausgehen oder wo wäre er zumindest abzuschwächen, um solche kriegerischen Auseinandersetzungen zu reduzieren, weil die Prämisse, die Herr Fritz Münkler da hat, in den 80ern schon Staaten befrieden, im Inneren möglicherweise stimmen kann. Aber nach außen sehen wir das eigentlich nicht.
Also ja, man kann alles denken. Aber bei dem Thema Gewalt möchte ich, dass der Körper eine Rolle spielt, weil nur darum geht es. Und es muss eine materielle und historische Grundlage geben. Und diese Nachkriegsordnung auch. Also klar, Zweiter Weltkrieg ist nur möglich, wenn man Staaten hat. Aber eine Nachkriegsordnung ist auch nur möglich, wenn man eine Staatenordnung hat. Und vor allem, wenn man einen Staat hat, kann man mit dem Staat und in dem Staat noch mehr machen als Gewalt. Produktives, wirtschaftliches Wachstum und so weiter. Und das kann man aber nicht ohne Staate. Dafür haben wir noch kein historisches Beispiel.
Und das ist ja ein Buch, das nur fragt, gibt es da irgendetwas und gibt es vielleicht in der weit zurückliegenden Geschichte oder aktuell zum Beispiel in Rojava Ideen, die man weiter denken könnte, um eine andere Organisation herzustellen als die staatliche Ordnung. Weil der Nationalstaat als solches, wie wir ihn heute kennen, ist ja eine ziemlich neue Erfindung. Das ist ja etwas, wo wir sagen können, das ist so 300 Jahre alt, wenn überhaupt. Manche würden ja sogar von rechts sagen, naja, das ist eine liberale Institution, da hänge ich gar nicht dran.
Ja, aber es ist ein sehr einfacher Punkt, aber der ist eben auch ganz wirkmächtig. Noch vor 100 Jahren, und wir wissen schon damals Weltkrieg und so, konnte man sich halt einfach aus dem Weg gehen. Also es sind halt jetzt acht Milliarden Menschen. Wenn wir jetzt historische Beispiele aus Shakepears Zeiten, wo in England drei Millionen Leute gelebt haben, und wir sehen dann, wow, die haben es irgendwie hingekriegt mit weniger Gewalt. Das sind halt Faktor 20 weniger Leute.
Es geht wirklich um Zeiten, die David Graeber in Anfänge beschreibt.
Das ist ja noch älter.
Ja, genau. Aber es geht ja wirklich um eine Zeit vor über 5.000 Jahren, weil das zu Shakepears Zeiten hatten wir ja Kriege, hatten wir Erhoberungen.
Selbst bei drei Millionen Leute schon.
Aber das ist ja nicht eine Frage von Anzahl der Leute. Oh doch. Nein.
Gewalt?
Aber doch nicht kriegerische Gewalt.
Muss ja was zu verteidigen geben.
Ja, aber es verteidigt doch jetzt gerade niemand. Irgendwie ist ja nicht so, dass die Russen zu wenig Land haben und dringend ein bisschen mehr brauchen, und deswegen die Ukrainer angreifen, sondern das ist ja ein anderes staatspolitisches Interesse. Da geht es ja nicht darum, dass wir unbedingt zehn Quadratkilometer mehr brauchen, weil wir 380 Millionen sind oder so.
Kriege sind nur möglich, wenn noch Menschen diese Kriege führen.
Das stimmt.
Aber die Ukrainekrieg sind jetzt mehr Menschen gestorben, als vor 400 Jahren überhaupt auf so einer Familie gelebt haben.
Das stimmt. Aber es ist nicht eine Frage von, der Krieg wird geführt, weil die Menschen sich da aufeinander, da treffen nicht Menschen aufeinander.
Das ist nicht so. Man braucht halt Menschen.
Hier ist es so voll geworden. Es ist so, klar, wenn ich, also es ist ja nicht das Bild, die Frankfurter Innenstadt ist so voll und da haben sich dann ein paar geprügelt. Sondern es ist ja so, dass da nun mächtige Interessen widerstreitend sich gegenüberstehen und daraus kommt Krieg. Und da ist die Frage, wenn also jemand wie Putin z.B. sein nationalstaatliches Interesse durchsetzen will, über die Köpfe auch der eigenen Bevölkerung hinweg, beziehungsweise mit den Männern, die dann da rekrutiert werden, dann ist das ja nationalstaatliches Denken. Er ist ja ganz in der nationalstaatlichen Denkweise. Und dann kann man ja fragen, vielleicht ist also auch der Staat ein Problem, wenn die israelische Regierung sagt, wir müssen da eigentlich noch mal ein paar Kilometer vom Gazastreifen haben und müssen dies und das noch haben, dann ist das ja nationalstaatliches Denken. Weshalb ja zu fragen ist, könnte man das eigentlich auch jenseits dieser Grenzen organisieren? Und da ist ja schon auch die Idee dann bei den Ansätzen, die ja vorgestellt werden im Buch bei Wolfshaun oder Böhm, zu sagen, okay, es gibt verschiedene Gruppen mit Interessen, aber könnte man nicht denen einen Rahmen bieten, wo nicht alles unter den einen Nationalstaat fällt? Das ist die Frage, bei der ich aber dann, wie gesagt, anmerke, aber gibt es da noch mal so drum herum einen Rahmen, und den nennen wir doch Staat, weil dann möglicherweise kommen wir genau da raus, wo es auch Thomas Wagner beschreibt, dass man dann doch wieder sagt, na ja, so für die Sicherheit, da machen wir das wieder mit dem Staat. Und dann haben wir aber immer noch den Nationalstaat, haben wir nur noch mal mehr Föderalismus oder so.
Ich will nur meine Vorsicht und ich weiß, ich formuliere das jetzt so, dass ich in ein Westennest steche, aber ich will es dann trotzdem. Bei mir nicht? Du weißt ja doch nicht, was ich gleich sage.
Ich weiß, was jetzt da bestimmt kommen könnte. Kommt jetzt irgendwas mit dem Gegenstandpunkt?
Nein, nein, nein, gar nicht, gar nicht. Ich will nur sagen, es gibt Menschen, die sind grob unzufrieden mit grundsätzlich und so weiter. Und anstatt dann punktgenau, gezielt und ergebnisorientiert in eine Diskussion einzusteigen mit Leuten, die das in der Hand haben, und es hat ja immer jemand in der Hand, wollen sie einfach pauschal den Kapitalismus abschaffen. Und sie haben aber nicht mal eine andere Idee. Also sie können nicht mal in Gedanken eine Alternative formulieren, geschweige denn auf den Boden bringen. Und wenn man unter der Maßgabe, ich will Gewalt vermeiden, sagt, wir müssen den Staat in Frage stellen. Du hast jetzt zumindest Alternativen genannt, Konfederation und so weiter und so fort. Aber das sind ganz heikle und schwierige Diskussionen, die manchmal, so wie Kriege nur stattfinden, wenn genug Leute da sind und genug zu verteidigen ist, die manchmal einfach nur geführt werden, weil Leute vielleicht am Abend sich ein bisschen langweilen und in der Küche bei einer Party noch ein Gespräch führen wollen. Und dann muss plötzlich der Kapitalismus und der Staat überwunden werden. Und vielleicht sind das auch die Orte, wo solche Diskussionen stattfinden.
Ausnahmemaxistischen Positionen sowieso, weil der Arbeiter kein Vaterland hat.
Genau so was.
Das ist aber so.
Ja, das stimmt ja auch.
Das ist ja Internationalismus nicht zu machen. Sonst muss ich ja nur im Standortwettbewerb denken. Und dann muss ich genau das Buch lesen von Patrick Kaczmarczyk und sagen, danke, ich nehme es als Gebrauchsanweisung, um weiter Standortpolitik zu machen und meine Interessen durchzusetzen.
Ich bin ja auch total dafür, zu sagen, der globale Jüden sind wir alle. Solange wir nicht zu dem Wert der anderen gehören.
Dann sind wir aber schon sehr weit weg von der nationalstaatlichen Souveränität, die eigentlich verteidigt wird.
Zurück zum eigentlichen Wolfgang. Wir müssen uns das wichtigste Thema überhaupt kümmern. Die wichtigsten Themen werden natürlich KI. Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Das ist sehr viel wichtiger. Die Heritage Foundation, Trumps großes Projekt 2025 und so weiter. Du weißt, sie haben jetzt ihr großes Policy Paper vorgelegt, Saving America by saving the Family. Die Familie.
Gibt es da bei dieser Heritage Foundation jetzt Autoren, die in diesem Paper namentlich genannt werden? Das ist nicht einfach nur so ein Memorandum allgemein.
Also hier geht es auch nicht zur Sache. Das ist alles gebunden nicht nur an Autoren, sondern auch an Institutionen, die sich damit laufen, beschäftigen, Veranstaltungen machen. Und es ist auch nicht das einzige Papier.
Aber kennt man die Autoren? Das sind jetzt nicht irgendwelche Think Tank Leute, die sonst auf Ted Talks rumspringen und jetzt nicht am gediehen haben.
Also Roger Severino, Jay Richards, PhD. Wow. Muss man unbedingt dazuschreiben. Emma Waters, Delanos Queers, Rachel Sheffield und Robert Director. Ich würde sagen, die haben wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Posten da einfach. Hier werden natürlich sehr viele Leute dran arbeiten und es so in wissenschaftlicher Mittelbau-Manier irgendwie zusammengeklamusert haben. Wie auch immer. Da schreibt jemand sein Name drüber. Jedenfalls, es geht hier um einen Special Report, denn ein Termin liegt in der Luft. Im Juli möchte ja Amerika zum 250. Mal seine Unabhängigkeit erklären. Und dieser Fokus auf Familie ist einer der großen Pfeiler, sehen wir ja auch schon in der amerikanischen Politik, der Zeit, der da eingeschlagen wird. Weshalb hier zum einen stop punishing family formation. Es geht auch um eine Abklärung und Abwendung bisheriger Politik, die man sieht. Und sie möchten die neuen Pflöcke einschlagen und eben aktiv fördern. Sie haben konkrete politische Programme. Und ich will schon mal ein Fokus auf die Sprache werfen. Die Regierung Clear the Weeds ist der Aufgabe, unkraut die Etten. Ich nehme nur die deutschen Übersetzungen. Den Boden bereiten, enrich the soil and plant the seeds. Also den Boden fertig machen und dann die Samen drauf. Poisoning the ground. Außerdem in der Kultur. Sie reden von Deadly Weeds, von Cultural Toxins, die zu beseitigen sind, von Perverse Regulations. Also wir haben wieder eine sehr biologische…
Da könnte Dagmar Herzog gleich das nächste Buch schreiben, ja.
Genau. Und außerdem wird hier auch historisch erinnert, ein Problem der Größenordnung erfordert ein kulturweites Manhattan-Projekt. Also die Familie wird jetzt wie die Atombombe einmal neu erfunden. Sie machen einen kurzen Hinweis, dass die 54 von 56 unter Zeichnen der Unabhängigkeitserklärung waren verheiratet. Zusammen hatten sie 337 Kinder, also the founding fathers.
Da war noch was los, ja.
Die Familie ist das Fundament. Es ist nämlich die natürlichste Gemeinschaft. Das haben wir ja auch schon bei dem Hasoni da im Gespräch mit Esra Klein besprochen. Und die Familie ist die Kinderstupe des Staates, sozusagen. Also sie machen so Analogien und so weiter. Nun gut, worum geht es? Um eine Kaskade Familie, Tugend, Selbstregulierung, der Publik. Das mit der Selbstregulierung ist super wichtig, denn das kommt hier immer so, ja gut, kann man dazusagen, wie auch immer. Aber sie haben dann später ein Bild der Bürogemi. Bürogemi. Da geht es um den Staat, der einspringt, wenn der Vater ausfällt. Zum Beispiel durch, haben wir in Deutschland auch Unterhaltsvorzahlungen oder wie auch immer. Also der Staat, Schuld ist dann nicht mit dem Kind, sondern dem Staat. Oder der Staat zahlt schon mal. Wir haben Wohngeld und so weiter, wenn der Vater nicht da ist, um die Miete zu bezahlen, dann springt der Staat da ein. Sie haben hier einen sehr interessanten historischen Vergleich mit Amerika selbst und zwar so in 50er, 60er Jahre. Damals heirateten die Frauen im Schnitt mit 20, die Männer mit 23. Das ist heute jeweils acht oder sieben Jahre später. Und nicht-eliche Geburten waren damals 25 Prozent, heute 70 Prozent. Also es kommt gar nicht mehr zu Eheschließungen. Und die nicht-eliche Geburtenrate, damals gab es gar nicht, wurde gar nicht aufgeführt, heute 40 Prozent. Kinder bei Alleinerziehenden 25 Prozent, sie sagen, das sei die höchste Rate weltweit. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Könnte sein, dass es hier, also in den westlichen Welten, grundsätzlich so hoch ist. Die Geburtenrate, damals 2,1, war ja in Deutschland auch. Und jetzt 1,59, also unter 1,6 gefallen. Deutschland ja zu 1,4. Das sind also diese dramatischen Zahlen, die wir von überall her kennen, von denen ich nicht sage, das ist dramatisch, weil so wenig Kinder, sondern weil wir wissen, dass der Kinderwunsch eigentlich höher ist. Und Leute eben ihr blockiertes Leben, also es ist ein wichtiger Indikator für ein blockiertes Leben, dass man da nicht sein Wunschleben führt. Und wenn diese Trends anhalten, werden die Todesfälle bald, sie sagen innerhalb eines Jahrzehnts, die Geburten übersteigen, wo ich mir denke, also China hat jetzt von Jahr auf Jahr, 2024 auf 2025, minus 17 Prozent Geburten gemeldet. Das ging um mehrere Millionen zurück. Das ganze Land ist um drei Millionen geschrumpft, weil natürlich sehr viel mehr Leute sterben als nachkommen. Also Amerika ist noch so weit weg von dem eigentlichen Benchmark der neuen Modernität Westeuropas, Chinas, Japans und so weiter, dass sie sich eigentlich darüber freuen sollten, dass es noch so was wie zumindest die materielle Grundlage für Familie gibt. Die Frage ist dann, kann man es nicht so gestalten, dass die Familien noch so ein bisschen Luft zum Atmen haben oder muss da einfach jeder nochmal seine Wertschöpfungskette bis ins Elementare reinprügeln? Also eigentlich hätte man policy paper gegen den Mietmarkt, den Arbeitsmarkt, den Gesundheitsmarkt schreiben sollen, statt jetzt irgendwie so, wir hofieren hier nochmal die Familie als Idee und so. Naja, was ich jedenfalls beobachten ist ein war on poverty, der in den 1960ern begann und es ist super interessant. Also Lindley Johnson beginnt damals ein war on poverty, der bedeutet, plötzlich wurde der Wohlfahrtsstaat erfunden, der sich eben in familiäre Belange einmischt. Also es ist genau so, wie ich es beschrieben habe, wie es viele beschreiben und die so nur als Problem. Ja, egal, also das ist das Problem, wo ist denn hier das Problem? Und sie beziehen sich dann, finde ich ganz interessant, auf so ein Text von 1965, The Necro-Family, The Case of Before National Action. Damals hat der Autor festgestellt, Daniel Patrick Moynihan, dass die schwarzen Familien besonders häufig ähm, ausereheliche Geburten haben und die Kinder dort ohne Väter aufwachsen. Nur, das was damals für die schwarzen Familien galt, gilt heute noch viel mehr für alle Familien. Also damals hat der Alarm geschlagen, weil 25 Prozent der Geburten bei den schwarzen unehelig stattfindet und heute sind aber 40 aller Geburten. Und da würde ich sagen, eins plus eins ist zwei. Das war bei den schwarzen damals so, weil die ein Armutsproblem hatten. Was bedeutet, dieses Armutsproblem seht ihr heute im Quadrat. Also die Familie scheitert einfach aus Armutsgründen. Aber wird natürlich hier null reflektiert. Ich habe mich noch einmal gefragt, siehst du irgendwo Ansätze einer Reflektion? Oder wird das einfach nur durchgeprügelt, so ein Argument? Nee, wird einfach nur durchgeprügelt. Also ich habe auch nichts zu überlesen. Also auch 100 Seiten hier. Ich habe es natürlich schnell durchgehört. Aber es ist wirklich in Brutalität und Engstörnigkeit, wie hier einfach so eine Axt eingeschlagen wird, ohne Rücksicht auf irgendeine Argumentation, irgendeine historische Begebenheit oder irgendwas. Also es ist wirklich crazy. Und dass es jetzt ein Wort dafür gibt, dass ich, wie ich ja sage, also mein Tenor ist ja, wenn die Familie ausfällt für die Kinder, muss der Staat einspringen. Sie sagen, nee, genau, gerade nicht. Und machen das unten mit dem Bild der Bürokratie. Also Bürokratie und Family zusammen als Bürokratie, oder wie sie auch immer aussprechen. Dass der Staat nicht länger als Ersatz-Ehemann vor allem, weil sie sind ja alleinerziehende Frauen, die dann die Kinder und so weiter. Also sie gehen genau in die nicht richtige Richtung. Sag ich mal, um das hier...
Aber was ist das Ziel dieses Textes dann, nur darauf hinzuweisen, dass alles nicht mehr wie früher? Oder haben sie einen Plan, wie die Familie der Zukunft aussehen soll?
Also sie haben schon Anmerkungen zum Thema Wohnkosten. Sind zu hoch und so, ja. Aber es ist doch vor allem DEA und sowas. Also dass hier so Rücksicht genommen wird auf irgendwas. Dieser Eifer und die Taktiken, die zur Anerkennung von allen Abweichungen führen und so. Ja, das geht doch nicht. Wir müssen uns doch besinnen auf das. Und dann überall gleich bitte Vater, Mutter, Kind. Staat hält sich raus, dass sie am Anfang diese, dass der Vater im Grunde der Bauer ist. Ja, das Feld muss bestellt werden und so weiter und so. Das ist ja auch so diese Idee, wie man sich es verbildlicht, wenn man sich schöne Bilder aufhängt. Also einfach Vater, Mutter, Kind stehen halt auf ihrer Ranch und das Getreide wächst so. Das ist halt so dieses Bild. Man fragt sich so, aber ihr wollt doch schon so ein bisschen an der Zukunft teilnehmen. Euch ein bisschen mehr geben als einfach nur die Kartoffelsuppe und so. Aber findet ihr einfach, also es ist wirklich so erarmisch für alle einfach. Dieser kleinen Gemeinschaft wie auch immer. Also solange das Umfeld stimmt, kann man sich das ja auch selber gönnen. Aber es geht halt einfach gar nicht auf. Na gut, zu den Policies. Also verschiedene Zielsetzungen natürlich. Mehr Kinder, frühere Ehen, längere Ehen und so. Das ist alles ganz wichtig. Die sagen auch nicht, nicht das Kind ist das Wichtige, sondern die Ehe. Denn aus der Ehe dann kommen die Kinder. Aber die Ehe selbst, ja, marriage first wird ja einfach gesagt. Und sie haben verschiedene Programme. Wie zum Beispiel sie möchten, dass ein staatlich gefördertes Sparkonto zur Heirat ermöglicht wird. Also du heiratest und kriegst ein Trump-Account, auf dem einfach schon mal 1000 Dollar dann für die Geburt des ersten Kindes auf dich warten. Wo ich mir so denke, also ihr kennt schon die Realität in Amerika, wir haben ja über die Kosten gesprochen von allem. Und es geht dann um 1000 Dollar bei Geburt eines Kindes für College, Hauskauf, Firmengründung.
Ja, da kommt man natürlich sehr weit mit.
Es ist wirklich Wahnsinn. Nur gut, es gibt eine Starteinlage für Heirat 2500 Dollar.
Das ist ja eigentlich das Verrückte an diesen neuen Rechten oder wegen mir kannst du auch faschistischen Strömen sagen, dass die ja nichts gestalten können, weil die ja gleichzeitig immer sagen, wir haben kein Geld. Also wenn die jetzt wirklich ernst machen würden mit einem Programm, da kriegt jeder 40.000 Dollar pro Kind, dann wäre das ja so eine Mobilisierung im faschistischen Sinne. Jetzt nehmen wir alles in die Hand, wir gestalten jetzt hier unsere weiße amerikanische Zukunft, so ein Programm. Aber da sind die ja völlig blank, deswegen können die zum einen Verbote machen gegen Regenbogenfamilie oder so etwas und sie können vielleicht noch vielleicht noch 1000 Euro jedem geben und man auch denkt, gut, wer wird wegen 1000 Euro irgendeinen Anreiz verspüren?
Ja, also Thema Anreiz. Ich mache ja in meinem Buch immer wieder den Hinweis, man gibt den Eltern bitte einfach Geld, damit sie die üblichen Kosten, die einfach an mehr Aufwand da sind, durch Kinder bezahlen und dann haben sie ein bisschen Kopf frei. Also man zehrt die Familie nicht finanziell aus, sondern man gibt ihnen Geld, um die Möglichkeit einzuräumen, dass man sich mal einen Babysetter oder so was regelmäßig holt, um einfach wieder Date Nights zu haben. Und dann kommt immer dieses Familie, Liebe, Ehe und Geld. Die sollen sich doch lieben aus freien Stücken, wie auch immer. Da sag ich, der Freiraum drum herum muss halt bezahlt werden, damit dann da freie Liebe und so weiter. Die Heritage Foundation sagt jetzt einfach, also zu den Trump-Accounts, die es ja schon gibt, die 1000 Dollar. Es gibt ja nichts Vergleichbares für die Heirat. Das ist ja erst mal nur Geld für das Kind. Trump hat das also nicht zu Ende gedacht, weshalb sie sagen 2500 Dollar Starteinlage bei der Eheschließung. Aber das Geld wird über drei Jahre verteilt, damit die Ehe drei Jahre mindestens und so weiter. Und wenn du die dann entscheiden lässt, musst du das auch zurückzahlen und so. Also es werden einfach so billigste finanzielle Anreize. Das ist wirklich Transactionalism auf dem, was ihm so wichtig ist.
Das klingt wirklich alles nach einem sehr schlechten Handyvertrag.
Das ist wirklich alles ganz schlimm. Ich glaube auch, hier sind einige Ideen, die sind so banal, dass man sich manchmal denkt, hat hier einfach jemand wirtschaftliches Verständnis mit so einer GPT-Grammatik einfach verbunden, um dann so ein Programm aufzuziehen. Außerdem natürlich sehr viel Tax Credits. Die kriegen wohl bislang sehr viel bei Adaption. Steuergutschriften von 17.000 Euro. Weil hier ja die Kalkulation ist, ist ja auch nicht verkehrt, vom Staat aus zu denken. Und da muss ich sagen, da ist auch ein kleiner Punkt drin. Wenn du ein Kind adoptierst, ist ja völlig klar, dass du den Staat von finanziellen Lasten befreist. Also für Güten, die dir das und geben dir 17.000 Dollar. Warum gibt es aber diese gleiche Kalkulation nicht bei Geburten? Weil eigentlich ist ja die Rechnung dieselbe. Nur man hat halt noch kein Kind, das man loswerden muss. Können wir es abschieben in eine Familie.
Man könnte es vielleicht erst abgeben und dann wiederholen.
Das ist im Grunde die Pointe, dass man sagt, okay, dann gibst du ein Kind zur Adoption, weil du kaufst es zurück und kriegst dann 17.000 Dollar dazu. Also so in diese Richtung sagen sie, okay, auch die Familien brauchen hier einen Bonus ab dem dritten Kind. Kennen wir ja auch aus vielen anderen Ländern. Außerdem Herdprämie. Ganz wichtig hier, die Herdprämie. Es kann doch nicht sein, dass der Staat jetzt für Kindererziehung bezahlt und die Familie, wenn sie diese tolle Aufgabe selber übernimmt, dann keinen Staat bekommt. Also wenn der Staat nicht zahlt, ja auch Erzieher, dann zahlen wir auch die Eltern. Da würde ich sagen, ja, mit diesen Gedanken mal über Dreiecken noch weiter gedacht und so ein Programm entwickelt und dann wird auch ein Schuh draus. Aber nicht so salopp, dass man einfach, wie die Bayern, hier einfach Herdprämie fordert und so. Naja, es ist jedenfalls, wie man sich das vorstellt, so wie Trump jetzt die EI abgebaut hat, den Fuhruhr beseitigt, sollte er den Familienfuhruhr aufbauen. Das ist die Idee. Also das Pendeln muss jetzt richtig in die andere Richtung umschlagen. Und ich will noch einen klotzenden Hinweis hier. Ich komme ganz kurz auf Europa zu sprechen. Und das Problem ist immer so ein bisschen, wie bei der Migrationsdebatte auch, diese Umfolgungsidee kommt ja aus Kalkulationen mit echten Zahlen. Aber die werden halt von Leuten, die den Kontext nicht verstehen, die sich noch nie mit dem Thema befasst haben und so weiter, einfach, oh ja, das ist ja wirklich krass so. Und deswegen will ich es kurz vorlesen. Also hier auf Deutsch steht in dem Text drin, letztes Jahr 2023 verzeichnete Frankreich weniger Geburten als 1806, dem Jahr, in dem Napoleon die Schlacht bei Jena gewann. Also um eine Stadt kommt auch noch ein Wort. Italien meldet die wenigsten Geburten seit der Wiedervereinigung 1861, Spanien die wenigsten seit 1859, Polen hat die wenigsten Geburten seit der Nachkriegszeit, ebenso Deutschland. Die EU ist seit 2012 eine Netto-Sterblichkeitszone mit vier Todesfällen auf drei Geburten im Jahr 2022, eine Lücke von über 1,2 Millionen. Stimmt alles, nur wo ist das Problem? Das Problem ist einfach nur, dass wir mit dieser Schrumpfung, die da drin steckt, nicht umgehen können. Das kritisieren genau die Leute, die vorher von der Bevölkerungsexplosion die ganze Zeit rumgejammert haben und so weiter und so fort. Also hier ist auch einfach eine, wie ich ja mal sage, Unaufgeklärtheit einfach drin. Wir sind einfach über grundsätzliche Sachen einfach nicht aufgeklärt. Und dass wir uns bei die Milliardäre sind schon wieder so viel reicher geworden. Wir haben schon wieder so viele neue Möglichkeiten. Jetzt kommt noch ein Klot dazu und so. Die ganze Zeit rumjammern, weil angeblich die Welt untergeht. Das ist wirklich nicht zu vertreten. Von daher, ja, diese Zahlen sind halt im historischen Vergleich einfach super krass, weil sich einfach das Vorzeichen einer Entwicklung, an die wir uns gewöhnt haben, immer Wachstum umgedreht hat. Das wird irgendwann in 1000 Jahren einfach als, ja, ja, da gibt es so Pendelschläge wie auch immer und so. Aber so ist es halt. Und von daher versuchen die halt hier so ein Drama, also so eine Drama-Grundlage für ihre politischen Ideen zu sagen, bei denen ich sage, einfach mal komplett allen die Luft rauslassen. Das ist alles absurd, was hier steht.
Kommen wir zur Streaming-Plattform Mubi. Will Tavlin schreibt in Vulture über diesen Streaming-Dienst. Ich weiß nicht, bist du da angemeldet?
Nee, ich kenne den gar nicht. Mubi, M-O-O oder?
M-U-B-I.
Den kenne ich vom Namen, aber nee.
Also das ist die Plattform für die Szeniasten. Da gibt es die großen A-Taus-Filme.
Ich bin ja kein Szeniast, ich bin Michael Bay-Film.
Du guckst Michael Bay, Michael Bay gibt es dann definitiv nicht. So viel kann ich versprechen. Vielleicht kann man auch Mubi so charakterisieren, dass man einfach sagt, die Plattform, auf der es keine Michael Bay-Filme gibt. Also man will jedenfalls etwas anderes sein als Netflix und ist damit auch erstaunlich erfolgreich. Momentan gibt es aber gewisse Schwierigkeiten. Man hat die Risikokapitalgesellschaft Sequoia Capital mit ans Boot genommen für 100 Millionen Dollar. Allerdings ist es so, dass diese Firma Sequoia Capital auch investiert hatte, nach dem 7. Oktober, in ein israelisches Verteidigungsunternehmen. Weshalb sehr viele Filmemacher, aber auch Fans, sturmlaufen gegen dieses Unternehmen. In den letzten sechs Monaten haben mindestens 10.000 Mubi Nutzer aus Protest gegen die Investition von Sequoia ihr Abonnement gekündigt. Also etwas, was wir jetzt immer wieder finden können. Wir haben das ja schon in Bezug auf Kimmel gehabt. Also es gibt da immer den Konsumentenstreik. Das ist aber jetzt nicht ein Artikel, der nur davon handelt, sondern eigentlich vom Aufstieg dieser Plattform. Wie konnte das eigentlich sein, dass eine Plattform so groß werden kann, die sich mit dem Indie-Vertrieb ja in den USA und darüber hinaus identifiziert, beschäftigt, die ja immer gesagt hat, wir machen die innovativsten amerikanischen Filme auf unserer Plattform zugänglich. Mubi hat auch immer mehr jetzt Filme produziert, große Kassen-Erfolge, wie zum Beispiel The Substance mit Demi Moore, der ja 80 Millionen Dollar an den Kinokassen eingespielt hat. Der Gründer Yves Sacquerel ist jemand, der ein Cineast ist, aber nicht direkt aus dem Filmischen kommt. Er war im Urlaub in Japan und er hat da plötzlich so eine tiefe Lust verspürt, sich einen Film von Wong Kar Wai anzusehen und stellte fest, dass er ihn nirgends sehen kann. Er konnte ihn nicht kaufen, er war auf DVD, er hat ihn im Internet nicht gefunden und daraufhin hat er diese Idee entwickelt. 1976 wurde er in der Türkei in einer Unternehmerfamilie geboren, studierte dann Elektrotechnik und Informatik am MIT, auch an Stanford und arbeitete als Investmentbanker bei Goldman Sachs und war auch App-Entwickler bei SAP. Er hat aber dann einen anderen Weg eingestangen. Wie gesagt, er hat In The Mood For Love, ein sehr schöner Film von Wong Kar-Wai sehen wollen. Er sagte, ich hätte alles dafür bezahlt, aber niemand bot mir diesen Film an. Und so beginnt er dann in 2006 ein Unternehmen zu gründen, das dann noch anders hieß, The Auteurs, also an den Autorenfilmen angelehnt, der Franzosen. Und damals hat diese Plattform dann als allererstes mit der Criterion Collection, die diese hochwertigen Plurays herausgeben, kooperiert. Man hat dann so ein Archiv zusammengestellt, hat aber auch gemerkt, okay, das ist ziemlich kostspielig, das zu tun. Man hat dann darüber nachgedacht, ob man nicht so ein soziales Netzwerk rund um diese Plattform aufbaut. Da könnten sich dann alle austauschen, dass so eine Community gebildet wird und dadurch auch die Interaktivität erhöht wird. Im Prinzip hat man da das schon versucht umzusetzen. Das hat man dann so nicht gemacht, was man heute als Letterboxd vorfinden kann. Jedenfalls hat dann diese Plattform, die man da so Letterboxd-artig gemacht hat, doch plötzlich Anhänger gefunden. Es waren dann 2009 bereits 40.000 Mitglieder. Sackerel hat dann auch seinen Firmensitz nach London verlagert, weil Europa wohl als wichtiger Markt erkannt wurde. Mubi führte 2012 dann aber ein neues Modell ein und da bin ich, glaube ich, das erste Mal aufmerksam geworden auf Mubi, nämlich, dass man einen Abo-Preis zahlt. Das war damals 5 Dollar im Monat und man hat 30 Filme zur Auswahl und mit jedem Tag verschwindet ein Film und kommt ein neuer hinzu. Das heißt, ganz klare Kuratierung, nicht Überangebot, nicht Netflix. Die meisten Leute switchen ja bei Netflix und Apple TV schon eine halbe Stunde rum und dann gehen sie müde ins Bett und sagen, heute lieber keinen Film mehr. Das war also dann nicht die Idee. Man hatte so ein Karussell und konnte dann zwischen diesen 30 Filmen wählen. Bedeutete dann auch, man musste nicht so viele Filme einkaufen, nämlich nur 365 im Jahr. 2016 hat dann Mubi selbst Filme vertrieben, hat bei Festivals direkt gekauft, auch Autorenfilme dann direkt für sich gewinnen können. Es geht immer darum, auch an das Kinoerlebnis zu denken. Das heißt, bei Netflix ist es ja eher selten, dass da mal irgendwas ins Kino kommt. Mubi setzt schon sehr stark auf den Weg Kino und dann Streaming Service. Bei Suspiria hat man das 2017 schon sehr groß gemacht, mit dem Film von Luca Guadagnino, der dann zum Beispiel in UK in 100 Kinos gelaufen ist. Da heißt es dann, Mubi begann auch in die Infrastruktur von Programmkinos zu investieren. Es sponserte lokale Filmfestivals, Sondervorführungen in Museen und Repertoire-Kinos und ging Partnerschaften mit lokalen Kulturmagazinen ein. Sie hatten auch mal eine Werbekampagne, die so ein bisschen das Editäre herausstellen sollte, aber da gab es dann zu viel Ärger. Das war zu abgehoben, klang das. Also zum Beispiel hatte man plakatiert. Wenn sie glauben, dass Tarkovsky Schwanensee komponiert hat, dann brauchen sie kein Mubi-Abo. Also man wollte sagen, wer da den Unterschied zwischen Tarkovsky und Tchaikovsky nicht kennt, der muss nicht zu uns kommen. Hat man aber dann wieder zurückgefahren, dachte, das vielleicht ein bisschen zu versnoppt. Im Mai sickerte dann, also jetzt, wir sind dann jetzt im Jahr 2025, die Nachricht von der Investition von Sequoia durch. In der folgenden Woche brachte Variety eine Titelgeschichte über den Aufstieg des Unternehmens und seine neue Milliardenbewertung. Das Profil war buchstäblich strahlend. Sackerel wurde in seinem 200 Jahre alten, sonnendurchfluteten Stadthaus in Notting Hill fotografiert, während er bei Schokolade von Marchesi 1824, einer Konditorei im Besitz von Prada, über seine Strategie sprach. In einer Welt, in der niemand wirklich für etwas steht, sagte Sackerel gegenüber Variety, wollen wir für etwas stehen. Aber innerhalb weniger Wochen begann dann doch ein großer Druck, der von Filmemachern kam, von Fans kamen, auch Filmfestivals, die sagten, wir wollen jetzt nicht mit Mubi zusammenarbeiten. Wir haben da auch den Filmemacher, der No Other Land gemacht hat, der plötzlich nicht mehr bei Mubi gesehen werden will mit seinem Film. Später verkündete Sackerel bei einer Vollversammlung, dass mindestens 10.000 Nutzer aus Protest ihre Abos gekündigt haben. Es gibt dann noch einen anonymen Brief von Mitarbeitern. Sackerel hat aber dann trotzdem diesen Deal ausgehandelt. In den letzten Jahren, heißt es, da hat Mubi Führungskräfte von Netflix und Discovery eingestellt. In diesem Jahr hat das Unternehmen seinen ersten neue Fernsehserie erworben. Mussolini, Son of a Century, Joe Wrights Dramatisierung des Aufstiegs von Il Duce, die die Geschichte des Faschismus in aufregende Popkultur verwandelt. Und da ist dann die Frage, geht also jetzt Mubi auch mehr in die Serie? Sackerels Vorbilder, heißt es hier, für kreative Kontrolle sind, und das klingt natürlich ein bisschen erschreckend, Mark Zuckerberg bei Meta und Elon Musk bei Tesla. Sackerel kontrolliert die Mehrheit der Sitze im Vorstand von Mubi und plant seine Mehrheitsbeteiligung auch im Falle eines Börsengangs zu behalten. Ja, das ist ein bisschen tragisch, wenn man das hört, weil ich wirklich sage, diese Plattform ist so wichtig, weil sie die Filmkultur sehr belebt hat und auch in den sozialen Medien sehr präsent ist. Das ist ja etwas, was sonst fehlt, wenn es wirklich um Filmkultur geht, weil wir bei Netflix eben so zugemüllt werden mit Mist und hin und wieder ist da mal eine gute Sache dabei. Das ist schwierig. Ich bin gespannt, ob sich da Sackerel eigentlich mehr so auf den Kern wieder besinnt oder ob das jetzt einfach so ein Netflix für Besserverdienende werden soll, was tragisch wäre. Der Artikel endet dann damit, dass sonst in so Programmkinos in New York schon mal so Tragetaschen auslagen. Da steht dann Mubi drauf. Die waren dann ganz schick. Die wollte man unbedingt haben. Und jetzt war man im Juli wieder im Programmkino in New York und Los Angeles. Da waren auch wieder Tragetaschen. Die Tasche, die von Hollywood Entertainment, einer in Los Angeles ansässigen Gruppe für Repertoire, Filmprogrammierung entworfen und verkauft wurde, sah fast identisch aus wie die von Mubi mit dem gleichen Cut Minimum Blau und dem gleichen Dogo, aber mit einer wichtigen Änderung. Mubi wurde durch ToBe ersetzt. Kennst du ToBe?
Nein.
Die kostenlose werbefinanzierte Streamingplattform von Fox, die für ihr breitgefächertes Programm bekannt ist, das sowohl schund als auch hochwertiges bis hin zu Marenade und Klotschreibroll umfasst. Ähnlich wie The Auteurs hat ToBe eine kultartige, durch Mundpropaganda entstandene Anhängerschaft gezogen. Zeit für eine neue Tragetasche hieß es auf der Website von Hollywood Entertainment. Der Erlös würde an einen Hilfsfonds in Palästina gespendet werden. Innerhalb weniger Tage war sie ausverkauft. ToBe, haben wir jetzt aber erfahren, gehört zu Fox, zu Rupert Murdoch, der mir jetzt auch nicht dafür bekannt ist, dass er um das Leid der Palästinenser, dass er denen irgendwie helfen will und dass ihm dieses Leid überhaupt in irgendeiner Weise wichtig ist. Jedenfalls ist ToBe sehr am Wachsen. Ich habe da noch so einen Bericht gesehen bei Business Insider oder Reuters war das, dass tatsächlich die starke Werbeerlöse haben und Fox jetzt gerade sehr darauf baut, diese Plattformen nach oben zu schrauben. Mir war die hier auch noch nicht präsent.
Also diese ständige Wiedererfindung des Fernsehens inklusive aller Verhaltensweisen wie Zapping und so, sind wirklich manchmal denke ich mir auch dieses Letterbox ist ja ganz gut in Verbund mit dieser einen App Just Watch. Wenn man einfach nachschauen kann, da trägt man so die Streamingdiese, die man gebucht hat, eine sucht einen Film und dann wird einfach angezeigt wo. So. Das ist sehr hilfreich, wenn man Kinder hat, weil dann wollen die einen Film gucken, dann guckt man einfach und dann okay, dann müssen wir nicht ewig suchen. Und am Ende weiß ich gar nicht, ob wir einen neuen Streaming Service brauchen. Also das Mubi begann, weil Filme gar nicht verfügbar waren, ist natürlich ein Problem für Leute, die Filme von vor 1975 sehen wollen, weil das gibt es ja alles nirgendwo. Aber manchmal denke ich mir, die eigentliche Lücke ist die Kuration, die Liste. Also die müsstest du eigentlich machen, oder irgendwer einfach ohne einfach klares...
Du guckst heute das hier.
Genau. Also Letterboxd stellt das hier so ein bisschen dar, aber im Grunde fehlt es an der Liste. Ich schließe nur vorhin an die Familienpolitik, die geplant ist an mit einem Text in der New York Times in search of a platonic co-parent. Es geht also darum, jemanden zu finden, mit dem man Kinder erzieht und sonst nichts. Jetzt gucke ich gerade, wer den Text geschrieben hat. App Tracking ablehnen. Continue. Jetzt kein Abo abschließen, sondern ich kann es tatsächlich nicht sagen, ohne dass ich mich jetzt bei der New York Times einloggen müsste. Also steht ja dann in den Show Notes, wie auch immer. Und zwar nur, um nochmal diese Zahlen zu nennen. Es gibt Datingplattformen, die dir Co-Parents vermitteln, zum Beispiel Moe Damily, also moderne Family Co-Parents und Let's Be Parents. Und die haben 2020, 30, 85, 1000 und 1200 Mitglieder gehabt und sind jetzt bei 100.000, 150.000, 100, 10.000. Also Wachstum zwischen 50 und 700 Prozent, wenn noch auf niedrigem Niveau. Aber ich nehme ja mal an, dass hier um Plattformen geht, bei denen man sich wirklich nur anmeldet, wenn man das Problem konkret hat. Und so häufig ist das jetzt auch nicht. Müssen wir ja schon von flächendeckenden, zumindest Bekanntheit umgehen. Und jetzt ist ja die Frage, ein Policy Paper und eine App. Wer gewinnt den Wettstreit? Und die App scheint das zu gewinnen. Denn in Amerika ist es jetzt doch gang und gäbe, dass man und dann eben nicht nur, ich bin ja männlich und heterosexuell, also date ich jetzt und suche eine Frau, sondern ich suche einen Co-Parent. Muss das unbedingt eine Frau sein? Kann ja auch ein Mann sein vielleicht. Macht es natürlich ein bisschen schwieriger in der einen oder anderen Formaljahr und so. Aber dass sich mittlerweile gleichgeschlechtlich oder sogar drei Eltern dann zusammenfinden, ist, also wir werden wirklich neue Familien jetzt erfunden und die Ranch, wir haben eben noch uns lustig gemacht über das Bild, was die Heritage Foundation hat. Nur die New York Times fährt eben zu Sacree und Lose und die leben natürlich auf einer Ranch in Texas und erziehen ihre Kinder in platonischer Partnerschaft. Also ja auch ganz witzig. Diese Kinder sind mittlerweile auch sprechfähig. Also da geht es um hier fünf- und dreijährige Kinder und wenn dann erst mal die erste Generation da ist, die ganz selbstverständlich davon erzählt und dass man nicht, wie auch immer, was wie alles zu schwulen Beziehungen und bitte nicht die Kinder und es schleppte sich bei Friedrich Merz bis 2024 und so. Das sind ja alles solche Sachen. Irgendwie hilft dann einfach das konkrete Leben und die konkreten Beispiele und die scheint es ja alle zu geben. Es gibt ausführlich Forschung dazu. Niemand sieht hier irgendwelche Probleme und das ist eine, finde ich, sehr positive Entwicklung. Denn diese Entkopplung von Gefühlshaushalten, also man hat eine Beziehung zu anderen Menschen und zu den eigenen Kindern, wird ja in traditionellen Familien alles in einen Topf geworfen, was ein ernsthaftes Problem ist. Da können noch so viele Witze gemacht werden, wie von Esther Perel, die dann sagt, naja, den Leuten ist schon Monogamie wichtig, aber halt seriell, so. Wenn man dann mit jemanden Kinder hat, ist es mit dieser Serialität schwierig. So, weil so richtig Abschied von Leuten, die man nicht mehr liebt, kann man wenig machen, wenn man noch gemeinsam Kinder hat oder wie auch immer. Und das hier zu entkoppeln, und zwar auch gegen eine politische Strömung gerade, finde ich nicht uninteressant. Da könnte man sich auch in Deutschland mal ein bisschen mehr mit befassen, was hier vorbildhaft in anderen Ländern geschieht.
Ich sage ja auch gerne, man sollte die eigene Familie nicht so sehr mit seinem Privatleben behelligen.
Ja, genau. Es ist ein wichtiger Punkt.
Das Handelsblatt hat recherchiert, genauer gesagt Sabine Gusbett hat sich gefragt, wie ist das eigentlich jetzt mit dem Öl aus Venezuela oder auch Iran und Russland? Wie, wo kommt das an, wenn es nicht in den USA ankommen soll? Nun, es gibt da Möglichkeiten, nämlich in Dongjing, Shandong, von dort schreibt sie. Sie setzt sich da mit dem Konzern Hongrun auseinander. Eine frühere Tochter des Staatskonzerns Sinuqiem, das heute unabhängig formiert und gehört, es gehört zu den kleineren chinesischen Raffinerien. Und diese laufen so ein bisschen unter dem Radar. Und die können durchaus Schweröl mit hohen Rückständen, ja, dort in Empfang nehmen aus Venezuela, obwohl das ja eigentlich gar nicht so vorgesehen ist. Vor Ort schreibt sie, kann und will niemand sagen, woher das verarbeitete Öl kommt. Aber es gibt dann doch Gerüchte. Hier in der ostchinesischen Provinz Shandong, einem der wichtigsten Raffineriezentren des Landes, sollen nicht nur sanktioniertes Öl aus Venezuela verarbeitet werden, sondern auch aus dem Iran und Russland. Öl, das ebenfalls mit US-Sanktionen belegt ist. Bezeichnet wird dieses Öl, diese Raffinerien als Teapots. Also Teapot, der Name kommt daher, neben den kugelförmigen Metallkesseln zur Lagerung des Öls, steigt weißer Rauch in den tiefblauen Winterhimmel wie aus einer Teekanne. Daher kommt dieses Bild. Beim Angriff auf Venezuela ist ja jetzt unklar, wollen eigentlich die amerikanischen Konzerne dieses Öl haben. Unklar ist auch, ob jetzt Trump das ganz verboten hat, dass das woandershin exportiert wird gerade. Es findet nämlich wohl doch auch statt. Im vergangenen Jahr hat die Volksrepublik China Öl im Volumen von rund 395.000 Borel pro Tag aus Venezuela erhalten. Das schätzen zumindest Industrieexperanten. Obwohl Chinas Ölmarkt von den drei großen Staatskonzernen dominiert wird, sind zwei Drittel der Importe aus Venezuela an kleine, unabhängige, private Raffinerien, wo man wie gesagt nicht so genau hinsieht. Interessanterweise ist das auch ein Zeichen für eine gewisse Pluralität in der chinesischen Gesellschaft. Denn diese unabhängigen Raffinerien, die es da gibt, die wollte man eigentlich schon in den 60er Jahren von Peking aus schließen. Aber das hat zu Widerstand bei den Lokalregierungen geführt, weshalb man die so gewähren ließ. Pekings Versuche in den 1990er und 2000er Jahren heißt es hier, die Kontrolle über den Ölmarkt auszuweiten, Überkapazitäten abzubauen und die Teapots aus dem Geschäft zu drängen, scheiterten. Denn die Lokalregierungen schützten die Unternehmen, die wichtige Arbeitgeber und Steuerzahler in der Region sind. 2015 änderte die Zentralregierung in ihre Politik und teilte den unabhängigen Refinerien erstmals wieder Quoten für importiertes Rohöl zu. Also man sieht da jetzt auch eine gewisse Wichtigkeit. Das dort verarbeitete Öl ist günstiger. Also da wird dann zum Beispiel von einem Tanklaster berichtet, der vorfährt und man spricht mit dem Fahrer, der sagt ja hier ist der Liter ja 55 Cent günstiger. Weshalb sich das auch lohnt, 1000 Kilometer zu fahren, um da hinzukommen. Maduro war selbst in Shandong mehrmals zu Gast, auch 2023 noch. Interessant ist nun, dass geschrieben wird, in Folge der US-Sanktionen sei die Zahl sogenannter Dark Calls am Hafen von Dongjing stark gestiegen, schrieben die Experten der auf Schifffahrts-Logistik spezialisierten Publikation Lloyd List. Im vergangenen Jahr. Was ist das? Dark Call? Dabei schalten Schiffe vor dem Hafenanlauf ihr GPS-Ortungssystem aus. Und dann kann man da Ungesehen stattfinden.
Warte mal, also GPS ist ja, die schalten ihre, was sie senden aus.
Ja, damit sie nicht mehr gefunden werden. Und so kann dann eben im Dunklen agiert werden. Man hat sowieso ja sehr viele Schattenflotten unterwegs. Wir wissen ja auch was anderes zusammenhängen.
Mit so einem riesigen Tanker. Im Dunkeln da so.
Es ist so interessant. Also diese Schattenflotten sind jetzt wohl vermehrt unterwegs ohne Sicherheitsdokumente, ohne Flagge auf hoher See. Also es findet da echt sehr viel Anarchie auf hoher See statt, muss man festhalten. Ob die USA jetzt diese Transporte erlauben, weiß man nicht. Unmittelbare Auswirkungen auf China dürfte jetzt jedenfalls der US-Zugriff auf Venezuela erstmal nicht haben, denn man geht davon aus, dass derzeit 82 Millionen Varell auf Tankern in den Gewässern vor China und Malaysia unterwegs sind, also quasi so ein fahrendes Lager.
Ich glaube auch, es gibt zu viel Öl gerade. Es war ein riesiger Raum im Weißen Haus, wo die ganzen Ölbosse saßen.
Aber daran kann man auch wiederum gut sehen, wie schwer das überhaupt noch einzuhägen ist. Wir haben ja auch tausende Artikel zum Thema gehabt, wie die Chinesen doch auch die Chips bekommen haben, die sie eigentlich haben wollten.
Na gut, die Herstellerfirmen wollen die ja da auch verkaufen.
Jaja, aber so ist das ja hier überall.
Anders als Amodai, der will das nämlich nicht. Das finde ich ganz erstaunlich. Es gibt eine klare politische Zuordnung vom Anthropic Chef. Also mein letzter Text, The Adolescence of Technology. Ein Text, von dem ich kein Wort gelesen habe. Ich habe nur einmal durchgescrollt und gesehen, wow, das ist wahnsinnig lang. Und ich wollte mich aber nicht vereinbaren lassen von jemandem, der den Text auch nicht geschrieben hat, dass ich den jetzt lese. Sondern es reicht völlig, wenn wir uns jetzt die Stichpunkte geben lassen. Von Claude natürlich. Also es gibt wohl diesen Film, den ich auch kenne und sehr gut finde, Contact. Carl Sagan, Judy Foster und so. Die Aliens kommen, aber nicht so direkt, sondern man nimmt so Kontakt mit ihnen auf über diese komische Maschine. Und man fragt die Aliens, wie habt ihr das geschafft? Wie habt ihr euch entwickelt? Wie habt ihr diese technologische Adoleszenz überlebt, ohne euch selbst zu zerstören? Diese Frage stellen wir uns jetzt vermehrt und häufiger. Also mit Atombombe ging es los. Dann kam irgendwas mit Biotechnologie. Dann agrarmäßig, jetzt sind wir bei KI angelangt. Und er greift die Frage auf. Sieht man ja schon an der Überschrift. Und dann kommt er auf die methodischen Selbstpositionierungen, also auf seine. Er möchte sich nicht als Vertreter des Dumerism sehen, auch nicht als overconfident, dass es alles gut geht und auch nicht als Overreaction. Also das ist zu viel Regulierung, sondern hier muss man Backlashs voraussehen, wie auch immer. Und das sollte chirurgisch sein. Da denke ich mir natürlich, ja, okay. Das sagen auch immer alle Technotypen, dass man hier. Na gut, diesmal sagt er selbst. Damals hat man einfach beim Social Media Zeug, Jeff Jarvis und so vorgeschickt, der immer sagt, nee, das ist so neu. Das dürfen wir jetzt nicht regulieren. Wie auch immer. Wir werden auf eine rhetorische Spannung hingewiesen. Amodei betont Nüchternheit, endet aber mit quasi religiöser Rhetorik. Sprich also von dem menschlichen Spirit und der Nobility, die wir alle haben. Nun gut, wir als die weisen Menschen das Dokument auszulieren zwischen Policy Paper und Predigt. Aber das kennen wir ja von dem vorigen Test. Gut, also die Macht Powerful AI. Er hat hier so eine zentrale Metapher, sagt Claude. Das finde ich ganz interessant, denn wir haben ja in Davos von Harari eine Migrationsdebatte bekommen zum Thema. Und jetzt sagt Amodai. Stellen Sie sich das Bild vor. Da ist ein Datencenter, in dem leben 50 Millionen Menschen, die als Arbeiterschaft in ihren Arbeitsmarkt hereinfallen und die zehn- bis hundertmal schneller die Arbeit erledigen, die sie erledigen können. Und das sind relativ häufig die, die bisher Menschen waren. Und da denke ich mir so, ja, das ist echt ein gutes Bild. Also an dem sollte man irgendwie so bleiben. Das ist eine Invasion, die stattfindet. Bekämpfung ist schwer möglich, denn gegen Körper vorgehen können wir. Also Freihandel, Freizügigkeit, Finanzmarkt, bitte alles vereinheitlichen, Binmarkt. Aber dann Schengen. Hier darf niemand durch. Wir machen nur mal eine Passkontrolle und so. Dann denke ich mir, okay, den Körper haben wir hier nicht. Also diese KI werden einfach runtergeladen. Und dann sind die halt bei Siemens vor Ort. So was passiert dann eigentlich? Außerdem, vielleicht kann ich ein bisschen vom Text abweichen. Ich habe mich mit jemandem unterhalten, der in der IT Beratung arbeitet. Und mir wurde mal wieder verdeutlicht, möchte ich sagen, es ist sozusagen eine mechangetragene Erkenntnis, die ich aber so krass finde, immer wieder, wenn sie mir begegnet, dass die großen Banken ihre Technologie selbst nicht unter Kontrolle haben. Die sitzen halt an Microsoft und an ihrem Kernbankensystem und dem ganzen Kram. Und wenn da irgendwas nicht klappt, müssen die halt einen Techniker anrufen. Und da ist aber niemand in der Bank, der der Techniker ist, sondern da muss niemanden buchen, der dann kommt. Und da denke ich mir so ein bisschen, ja, also dann kann ich doch auch all in gehen mit meinen Sachen. Also wenn dann jemand kommt und sagt, Stefan, du hast jetzt eine Webseite gebaut, aber du kannst doch dieses Jahr was kribbt gar nicht. Und ich so, ja, ne, kann ich auch nicht. Ich hab mir halt einen IT-Typen aus dem Data Center kurz rüber telefoniert, so für 200 Euro im Monat. Also von daher, die ganze Welt scheint so zu operieren, dass wir hier so ein bisschen haltlos einfach Sachen ausgeliefert sind. Gut, Eigenschaften von Power AI, Powerful AI. Intelligente als Nobelbeisträger in allen relevanten Feldern, kann Text, Audio, Video, Maustastatur, Internet nutzen, arbeitet autonom, Aufgaben über Stunden, Tage, Wochen, alle physischen Tools stehen zur Verfügung, Roboter können gesteuert werden, Laborequipment sowieso. Und all diese Millionen Instanzen können parallel und kollaborativ arbeiten. Ja, also wir sind kurz vor einer Soziologie der Maschine. Würde ich mal sagen, müssen wir uns nur im Alltag angucken, was das so bedeutet. Wann das alles? In ein bis zwei Jahren. Ah ja, möglicherweise weiter entfernt steht hier, aber in ein bis zwei Jahren. Wir haben die Scaling Laws. Wir haben, dass jetzt schon sehr viel Code, den Atopic benutzt, um Claude besser zu machen, von Claude selbst geschrieben wird. Menschen orchestrieren dann nur noch. Wir haben diese Feedback Loops, die jetzt geschlossen werden sollten, wie wir gehört haben. Die fünf Risiken gehen wir mal durch. I'm Sorry Dave, also noch eine Filmanleihe, die wir alle vielfach kennen. Bitte unter hier. Dann die Biowaffen. Misuse for Destruction. Misuse for Seizing Power. Also das ist eine KI-politische, das finde ich auch eine super interessante. Wir haben immer diese Idee von, oder nicht wir, sondern Leute, dass es Unternehmen gibt, die milliardenschwer sind, aber nur noch ein Chef. Was ist mit politischen Parteien? Also wäre das da auch irgendwie denkbar. In diese Richtung sollte man mal. Wirtschaftliche Disruption, die einfach passiert. Details können wir jetzt mal verzichten. Und indirekte Effekte. Black Seas of Infinity. Announce, Announce. Kennen wir ja auch. Das hier in der Biologie AI-Psychose. Also, dass die KI selbst eine AI-Psychose bekommt. Oder wir zu viele romantische Beziehungen mit KIs machen. Oder Suizide durch KIs. Also, all die Themen, die wir kennen. Puppeting. Menschen lassen sich komplett von KI durchs Leben leiten. Also, da kenn ich einige Kandidaten dafür. Und neue Religion, ja. Was, wenn KI Millionen Leute einfach konvertiert? Klot-Kult und so. Wissen wir ja. Sinnverlust, ja. Es droht tatsächlich ein Sinnverlust. Nun ja, seine Ansätze als Verteidigung da geben. Constitutional AI. Zentrales Wertedokument, das bei Klot wie so ein Handbuch immer im Hinterkopf ist. Das ist natürlich auf Systemprompt-Ebene, wie auch immer schon beim Alignment. Keine Ahnung, wie er sich das vorstellt. Müsste man im Text dann mal ausführlich lesen. Interpretability, also dass man versteht, was passiert. Wir brauchen eine Neurowissenschaft für KI. Das finde ich nicht verkehrt. Wir brauchen sowieso ganz viel Roboter-Forensik. Transparenz von Seiten der Anbieter. Klar, das kann man natürlich mal einfordern. Er hat hier einige Transparenzgesetze, die er nennt. SB53, Race Act, wie auch immer. Und einen Biowaffen-Classifier. Er redet hier von 5% Kosten, die bereits als Inferenzkosten aufgewendet werden, um Clot robust zu machen gegen so einen Missbrauch. Also, dass jede Antwort kurz noch mal durch einen extra Prozess läuft, dass hiermit bitte keine Biowaffen hergestellt werden. Denkt man sich so, okay, wenn die so ein hohes Preisschild daran hängen und es ist aber keine exklusive Technologie von, also Croc macht das ja auch, Elon Musk und so. Man will nicht wissen, was abseits von nackten Fake-Körpern und so weiter hier noch so alles von Elon Musk hergestellt wird in seinem Kämmerchen. Schlimm. Also, guter Versuch von Amudite es noch mal einzufangen, aber mal sehen, wie es weitergeht die nächsten Tage. Gucken, ob wir noch ein paar Monate geschenkt bekommen von der KI.
Musik zum Schluss vom Trio Wanderer. Die sind also nach dem Wanderer der Romantik benannt.
Sind sie auf Tour?
Man geht hinaus. Das Trio Wanderer, ein französisches Trio, gibt es seit fast vier Jahrzehnten. Sie sind herausragend gut und sie legen nun ein Programm vor mit französischer Kammermusik, denn diese hatte es im 19. Jahrhundert gar nicht so leicht. Sie zitieren auch im Cover eine Äußerung von Camille Saint-Saint, der sagt, es ist noch nicht lange her, vielleicht 15 Jahre, da blieb einem französischen Komponisten, der die Kühnheit besaß, sich in den Bereich der Instrumentalmusik zu wagen, keine andere Möglichkeit, seine Werke aufführen zu lassen, als selbst ein Konzert zu geben und dazu seine Freunde und die Vertreter der Presse einzuladen. Was das Publikum betrifft, das richtige Publikum, so war daran nicht zu denken. Stand der Name eines französischen und obendrein noch lebenden Komponisten auf einem Plakat, hatte dies das Zeug, alle in die Flucht zu schlagen. Was wollten die Leute hören? Die deutschsprachigen Komponisten, Beethoven, Mozart, Haydn, Mendelssohn, also die großen Galeonsfiguren der Kammermusik und die französische Kammermusik tats sich schwer. Das hat aber einige Komponisten nicht davon abgehalten oder vielleicht auch erst ermuntert, Kammermusik zu schreiben. Und mit diesen Komponisten beschäftigt sich dieses Klavier-Trio. Also wir haben es mit Trio zu tun, Klavier, Shadow, Geige. Sie spielen Kompositionen von Eduard Lalot, Claude Debussy, Maurice Ravel und eine Entdeckung für mich zumindest. Ich kannte sie vorher nicht, die Komponistin Mel Bonis, die sehr kantable Sonaten geschrieben hat. Sehr schön ist hier ein Stück, das heißt Soir Matin, also Abend und Morgen. Es ist eine Musik, die tatsächlich auch sehr anders ist, zumindest wenn man das so grob sagen darf, als die Komponisten aus Deutschland und Österreich, die ich jetzt eben genannt habe. Es ist eine Musik, die fälschlicherweise mit Salon-Musik assoziiert wird, was vielleicht ein bisschen daran liegt, dass man sehr so einen warmen Klang hat und dass da immer so ein Klavier da ist, das eine gewisse wärmende Stimmung aufschafft. Wir haben sehr singbare Melodien darüber. Aber wenn man dann ein bisschen weiter hört und sich damit auseinandersetzt, dann sieht man eigentlich, wie voll diese Musik ist, von ganz vielen kleinen Schätzen, die da auftauchen, überraschende Wendungen, die diese Musik nimmt. Und das Trio versteht es einfach, diese Musik so zu spielen, dass es mit so einer packenden Energie ist. Es hat was sehr Dynamisches. Es ist in keiner Weise irgendwie altmodisch, klingt es, sondern es ist ein sehr frischer Sound, den sie da gefunden haben. Und es sind Kompositionen, die sicherlich nicht alle, so die absolute Meisterschaft der Kammermusik sind. Aber es sind eben Werke, die einen unmittelbar berühren können. Ich finde, dass man eigentlich keine große Einstiegshürde hat, auch wenn man dann natürlich bei Ravel oder Debussy ein bisschen mehr gefordert wird, wie vielleicht bei La Loa. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine Musik, die man sofort mitgehen will und bei der man dann aber viele Überraschungen erlebt. Ein, wie ich finde, sehr schönes Album. Ich gestehe auch, dass ich ein bisschen zu wenig französische Kammermusik gehört habe. Und jetzt dieses Doppelalbum bei Harmonia Mundi Schienen gibt da eine gute Möglichkeit. Ist natürlich auch alles wieder streambar.
Sehr gut. Und schön, dass wir dann noch mal ohne so viele negative Gedanken in Nationalitäten denken dürfen. Genau.
Da kann man das noch machen.
Wir meinen nur den Kulturraum.
Wir meinen nur den Kulturraum. Zum Schluss noch das nächste Mal werden wir das neue Buch von Ulrike Herrmann lesen. Wir sind sehr gespannt.
Ich werde dir noch ein zweites vorschlagen, damit wir es vielleicht nicht nur bei einem belassen, bei dem vielleicht unser Urteil viel schneller kommen sollte, als wir wirklich jedes Seite.
Es ist ja schon so, dass wir das schon gründlich... Ich glaube, unser Publikum will eine gründliche Auseinandersetzung. Wie wir das damals auch gemacht haben bei dem Ulrike Herrmann Buch, da waren wir nicht unfair.
Nein.
Nein, das sind wir nicht.
Wir machen es gründlich.
Wir sind gründlich.
Carla Hinrichs hat auch ihr Buch jetzt fertig. Und vielleicht sollten wir noch mal ältere Autoren, alte Welt, neuere Autoren, neue Welt. Also ich werde auf jeden Fall das eine dann ergänzen.
Ich glaube, Ulrike Herrmann will die neue Welt beschreiben, nämlich eine Welt des Krieges. Und wie finanzieren wir die Aufrüstung? Das ist zumindest ein Thema, das man so der Vorankündigung lesen konnte.
Okay.
Bis dahin alles Gute.
Ciao.